[Musique]
et bonjour à tous bonjour à toutes
bienvenue pour cette dernière 9e et
dernière ronde du championnat d'Europe
des nations avec l'équipe de France
féminine actuellement 3e de la
compétition qui peut obtenir n'importe
quelle place sur le podium en fonction
des résultats évidemment ça serait bien
de commencer par gagner notre match
avant de regarder les résultats des
autres équipes et on affronte ma chère
Natacha l'Ukraine comment tu vas
Natacha salut Yosa bonjour tout le monde
ben ça va ça va très
bien assez impatient de voir la suite de
la compétition les Françaises ben elles
ont un appariment qui n'est pas le plus
simple la forte équipe d'Ukraine avec
des des figures euh
ouais ouais ouais par exemple de grand
menina qui qui a été championne du monde
il me semble kenina a été championne du
monde en 2012 si je ne m'abuse euh donc
euh ouais c'est deux grands maîtres dans
l'équipe dont une ancienne championne du
monde c'est c'est clairement une bonne
équipe après c'est aussi une équipe euh
vieillissante et on connaît également le
contexte euh m de l'Ukraine c'est pas du
tout facile pour les Jes ukrainiennes
certaines vivent encore en Ukraine
d'autres ont émigré mais dans tous les
cas c'est c'est compliqué pas forcément
la meilleure période pour les joues
ukrainiennes mais mais vas-y tu nous
présentees l'équipe et les les quatre
matchs avant avant qu'on commence à
15h15 à à commenter les coup
oui oui oui bien sûr donc bah tu as
commencé par l'échiquier numéro 4 donc
euh Natalia zukova euh grand maître
grand maître international avec les
Blancs contre Pauline Guichard sans top
rating est-ce qu'elle a déjà passé les
2500 Natalia zuukova je me pose la
question je ben je je crois ouais ouais
je je pense au moins virtuellement vu
qu'elle est devenue grand maître euh
shenina est devenue grand maître en
devenant championne du monde mais elle
aussi je crois qu'elle a eu plus de 2500
tout pile mais elle les a eu à son top
donc non ouais non c'est c'est de vrai
de vrais grand maîtres il y a pas pas de
souci sur la valeur de leur titre euh
juste juste elles ont perdu en mai alors
certainement qu'elle a passé en comme tu
dis elle est grand maître donc en fictif
et j'ai un pic à
pour ouais donc elle a peut-être perdu
la dernière partie
mais pour les titres enfin par pour tous
les titres c'est le classement ho fictif
qui compte donc 2500 pour les grands
matres quandbien même vous passer 2500
effectivement vous perdez la partie du
coup publier vous n'avez que
2499 vous pouvez quand même devenir
grand mître si vous avez les trois
normes comme a priori c'est le cas de
Natalia jokova
ok ça c'est pour le 4e échiquier je peux
les mettre au fur à mesure qu'on
commence trè
échiquier on a
euh Mitra qui affronte Inna gaponenko et
ouais vas-y je t'en prie ou Ina qui qui
est une DT coéquipière en class me ou et
du coup coéquipière de Pauling Guichard
également on a on joue ensemble dans la
même équipe au top 12 féminins on a fait
disputé également à la coupe d'Europe
des club et peut-être que c'est une des
raisons pour le choix de mettre Pauline
au 4e échiquier pour éviter qu'elle
affronte sa coéquipière euh mais je ne
sais pas là je je n'ai pas posé la
question je ne suis pas dans la
confidence de la composition mais ça
peut être toujours compliqué pour un
match important de jouer une
coéquipière euh pense Coline aurait eu
aurait eu peur entre guillemets de jouer
contre
inagaponenko à mon avis j'ai du mal à le
croire hein mon avis si on lui dit ça
serait bien pour l'équipe que tu joues
in avec les Blancs elle dit d'accord
c'est a priori mais mais peut-être que
c'est quand même un facteur à à à
prendre en compte je je je ne sais pas
en tout cas c'est notre coéquipière à
Pauline et à moi dans le club danière
euh
[Musique]
tu est-ce que tu veux qu'on se risque au
jeu des pronostique ou
pas
non
c'était un nom Fran clair je sais pas si
tu te rappelles au à la Coupe du monde
je crois pas qu'on a été très très bonne
à ce à ce jeu alors on va on va éviter
de les poisser et donc évidemment
bonjour à tous et à toutes dans le chat
ça fait plaisir de vous
voir aussi nombreux à à suivre notre
belle équipe de France féminine on
jetera quand même des coups d'œils
évidemment à à la section open même si
l'allée bleu ne jouent plus pour de
médailles en tout cas pas de médaille
par équipe alors deuxè
échiquier je te laisse présenter
oui tu tu parlais de
médaille oui bah faut pas oublier Mitra
qui
a combien 7/ 8 non une défaite et donc 6
et demi/ 8
il me semble que c'est 6 et demi sur 8
hein attends je vais regarder mais là
c'est sa 9e partie ou c'est sa 8e partie
sa 8e elle est sortie elle était sortie
hier oui donc elle a 5 et dem sur 7 5 et
demi sur 7 tu vois je prédit l'avenir 5
et demi/
7 de manière inconsciente he donc c'est
ça qui est encore meilleur et Pauline
Guichard qui a 6 et demi sur 7 oui donc
a priori des des médailles individuelles
en jeu
pour ces euh deux joueuses mais c'est
pas les médailles qui qui compent hein
je pense que si on demande aux deux de
si elle préfère une médaille collective
ou chacune des médailles individuelles
je crois que la question ne se pose même
pas attends la réponse est évidente mais
si ça peut être un petit bonus la suérie
sur le gâteau c'est c'est toujours bon à
prendre juste une petite mini mini
parenthèse j'ai sous les yeux la
performance de Pauline Guichard alors
combien popo combien notre cher
popo 2721
ouais c'est pas mal une performance à
2721 elle a fait un un tournoi mais
officiement et espérant performance au
encore mais oui mais carrément c'est
dommage hein parce que oui elle a pas
joué de elle peut pas jouer pour la
norme c'est ça
ouais ouais oui donc guich ou qui est
déjà maître international hein donc
ouais parce que ça on peut le rappeler
ce système des normes juste avant que
les parties commencent
euh norme de grand maître c'est une
performance à 2600 mais ça suffit pas
faire une performance à 2600 sur ne9u
parties c'est pas suffisant pour
forcément avoir une norme de grand
maître il faut avoir rencontré au moins
un/ers de ces adversairirees grand
maître plus la moitié enfin plus de la
moitié de joueurs titrés et cetera plus
à bon là les étrangers évidemment ils
sont bon dans un championnat par équipe
mais il y a il y a beaucoup de
conditions beaucoup de petites
astérisques c'est comme signer un
contrat
euh pas se faire avoir alors et au
premier échiquier juste avant de lancer
les parties plutôt que les parties se
lance toute seule on en parlait de cette
championne du monde ukrainienne Anna
enina championne du monde je pense 2012
parce que elle a enfin en tout cas ce
que je sais c'est qu'elle a perdu son
titre contre ouan en 2013 13 donc est-ce
qu'elle avait gagné un an ou deux avant
ça je me rappelle plus mais donc grand
maître international champion du monde
ex joueuse à plus de 2500
ho c'est ça ça envoie un personnage
euh mais bon démanté à les pièces
blanches euh et Anna fait pas non plus
un tournoi qui est exceptionnel elle a
elle a juste gagné une partie contre une
joueuse classée 2047
elle a une défaite contre une joueuse à
2390 et des matchs nuls contre un panel
de joueus entre 2100 2003 Alex contre
Alexandra cenu qui a 2500 donc c'est pas
non plus un tournoi
oufissime je dirais c'est c'est pas
oufissime allez c'est pas oufissime
ouais donc à la porté de Démé Démé Ben
qui vient de jouer son premier coup donc
E4 E4 D6 waouh c'est R ce petit D6 au
premier coup au top niveau pour une
partie aussi importante D3 non mais
qu'est-ce que c'est ça non ouf ah
d démonter donc là non mais là j'allais
croire à l'erreur quoi mais dis-moi
dis-moi oui donc là la joueuse
ukrainienne peut choisir différents
setups donc pour la française on imagine
qu'elle va jouer cavalier C3 du moins
j'imagine sur C C3 et là B on peut
transposer dans une dans dans une
filidor après E5 ou dans une Pirque
après C6 si je me trompe pas au niveau
des donc G6 c'est la pire E5 la filidor
l'autre hors de coup de la filidor
cavalier des7 pour je5 ça évite cette
possibilité de finale là on peut jouer
cavalier F3 ça transpose dans les
grandes variantes on peut jouer prise
prise dame prend D8 c'est un peu le
problème de choisir cet ordre de coup
avec E5 au 3e on peut jouer cavalier D7
euh pour jouer5 sans de la finale le
problème de cet ord de coup c'est qu'il
y a G4 ici ou alors comme tu m'avais
joué Natacha il y a bien longtemps on
était jeune tu m'avais joué F4 et tu
avais gagné une belle partie au top 12
ou Top 16 je ne sais plus quelle année
inchallah pas très oui euh et donc c'est
une des punition de l'UR de Coupal les
des7 donc les noirs sont obligés de
faire une concession
ouais dis-mi juste pour information
enfin démoné joue en tout cas a joué pas
mal de filidor avec les Noirs donc
normalement elle connaît bien donc elle
connaît bien avec les noirs elle connaît
les
variantes les variantes je pense qu'elle
connait elle comprend les finesses dans
les différentes variantes donc c'est
assez surprenant comme choix d'ouverture
par la joueuse ukrainienne par la
grand-maître et bon ben tant mieux hein
c'est je pense qu'elle doit être
démontée doit être au point là-dessus
peut-être qu'elle voulait faire une
dédicace
an naouinina à notre spécialiste
français de la filid d'or à savoir stouf
évidemment notre maître international
préféré Stouff fidèle de ce chat fidèle
de cette chaîne évidemment qui joue la
filidor avec les les Noirs depuis des
années avec plutôt des bons résultats on
est là cavalier des TR cavalier F3
cavalier P des7 oui si SIG aura reconnu
stouf avant que je le dise euh à noter
on nous pose la question salu elles
peuvent encore remporter le titre oui on
l'a dit tout au début de stream pour
l'instant la France est
3e derrière
euh la Bulgarie et
l'azerbaadjan on peut obtenir n'importe
laquelle des places sur le podium selon
les résultat évidemment on aimerait
gagner avant tout bon déjà il on veut
gagner et si on gagne ce qu'on veut
c'est que la Georgie batte la Bulgarie
et que la Serbie batte l'Azerbaïjan
ou que la Serbie fasse match contre
l'Azerbaidjan a priori si on gagne on
aura un meilleur départage donc il y a
clairement des possibilité de médaille
d'or si la la Bulgarie ne perd pas son
match si enfin Forie si elle gagne son
match on peut pas terminer première mais
on peut terminer 2e si la Serbie fait au
moins match nul et il y a même des cas
où scénario catastrophe on perd le match
mais on peut quand même finir 3è en
perdant selon les résultats donc donc
les trois médailles sont possibles
aucune médaille est possible aussi ça
serait horrible on refuse d'y croire
d'envisager ce scénario mais c'est pas
totalement possible et
euh mais en tout cas la première est euh
tout à fait
envisageable ce petit coup de A4 euh
j'ai joué la fille d'or avec les Noirs
pas seulement contre toi ma chère
Natacha et quelqu'un navait joué a4
avant même que je fasse C 6 ou à 6 c'est
d'habitude à 4 c'est pour empêcher B5 et
ce quelqu'un c'était monsieur Cornette
et non pas Madame euh donc je sais pas
si c'est dans le couple il s'entraîne à
jouer à 4 avant C 6 mais c'était c'était
ça oui h c'est le coup qui est proposé
par il me semble c'est ngy c'est ça
c'est le livre de ah oui
c'est le ouais en gros l'idée c'est que
par exemple si tu joues pas à 4 et que
tu fais euh si on revient petit rock
petit rock tour1 h HM là les noirs
sur il me semble que c'est ça ouais sur
A6 si tu joues A6 avec l'idée de jouer
B5 A4 les noirs peuvent jouer avec B6 il
me semble que c'est ça ouais on n pas le
se tempo qui nous permet de jouer A5 et
de bloquer l'expansion euh des
des noirs sur l' dame donc l'idée c'est
que très très tôt les Blancs jouent à 4
comme ça sur un C comme ils peuvent
directement jouer à 5 et
et et empêcher les noirs et ralentir les
Noirs dans leur développement prennent
aussi de l'espace sur l' dame et c'est
que ça ça contient le contrejeu des
Noirs
ouais donc là à 4 jouet petit rock donc
démter se rappelle de tout ça elle prend
un peu de temps ou pas pour réfléchir je
pense qu'elle doit juste se remettre les
idées en place non elle joue
tranquillement et je pense qu'elle
connaît bien elle connait bien avec les
noirs elle est plutôt à l'aise dans
c'est parti avec les noirs avec la la
filidor je pense qu'elle doit être
également à l'aise avec les Blancs ouais
il y a à noter qu'il y a peut-être aussi
une autre idée à jouer à 4 c'est sur les
variantes à la Stouff justement qui
consiste à donner le centre non pas pour
le statut euh on se fait attaquer le fou
on n peut-être pas obligé de le jouer en
B3 où il peut y avoir des thèmes de C5
C4 et cetera on peut peut-être aller en
A2 bon je sais pas à quel point c'est
pertinent là je suis pas spécialist oui
on crée aussi une case de retrait pour
le fou le fou C4 aussi ouais bien vu ya
ok euh on passe à l' Chiquet numéro 2 où
tu as quelque chose à rajouter sur cette
filée
d'or non non non on va voir je suis
impatiente de voir quelle est la
surprise de la joueuse avec les noirs de
la joueuse ukrainienne qu'est-ce qu'elle
a prévu dans cette fille d'or ah ouais
on va suivre ça si les noirs ne sont pas
très au point s'ils n'ont pas de
surprise ben souvent c'est un petit
avantage pour les blancs ouais alors
après c'est vrai que moi je j'ai du mal
à être totalement anti antiilid d'or je
l'ai joué des années alors j'en ai eu
des pouelle ou là pas seulement contre
je sais mais mais je l'ai joué moi aussi
la FID et je pense que je suis eu oui en
fait je pense
que c'est la seule ouverture les CIN
premières fois où j'ai joué j'ai pris
CIN
bulles
ouais c'est peut-être plus mon style que
ton style a peutêtre que tuarrêtes quoi
mais non il il y a pas mal de joueurs et
joueuses à à 22 23 qui qui l'ont joué en
France je veux dire euh mathil choisi on
a joué aussi euh B on a cité stouf bon
qui est même 24 mais il y a je sais que
gerto on a joué beaucoup aussi il y a eu
un effet de mode à un moment c'est vrai
que pendant quelques années avant les
nouveaux ordis c'était quand même même
une ouverture qui demandait peu de
travail et avec laquelle tu pouvais
obtenir des positions jouables sans trop
de travail c'était ce qui nous
corresponda à ce moment-là alors là pas
du tout pas de filor pour Sophie mais
une
Sicilienne avec
E5 est-ce qu'on va voir des r opposés
encore des RCK opposé
ah tout ça ce doit être ultra théori fou
B5 empêche A4 le cavalier vient en B4
prépare la poussée des5 qui
arrive prend des5 donc les Noirs ont jou
le coup libérateur bon les deux joueuses
Blitz tous les coups donc ça doit être
ultra thorique
encore ça peut devenir très concret
parce que si les noirs peuvent juste
reprendre et rester avec ce pion5 au
centre on a une meilleure
structure donc les blancs il faut qu'ils
obtiennent quelque chose en échange de
cette concession centrale on dit comme
je l'ai dit le coup des 5 c'est le coup
de libérateur donc pourquoi est-ce que
je suis pas juste mieux avec les Noirs
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec toi
quand tu me dis que les Blancs
obtiennent une meilleure structure les
Noirs les Noirs obtiennent les Noirs ont
le centre ok mais le coup à 5 est hyper
affaiblissant ouais avec cette cas B5 et
je pense que c'est c'est la réponse à ta
question pourquoi est-ce que les noirs
n'ont pas égalisé ou sont pas juste
mieux mais parce qu'en fait ils ont
affebli leur leur edame alors il y a eu
des avec le coup5 avec ce gros trou en
B5
ouais donc je pense c'est ça et C B
aussi qui est faible
ouais ouais je je sa oui enfin je suis
d'accord avec toi là on préférait jouer
à 6 mais mais euh je sais pas j'aime
bien ce P 5 j'a aime pas ce P F3 quoi
alors après c'est ultra théorique donc
on comprend l'évaluation de la jauge
hein donc il y a eu tous ces échanges
mais là encore si si si les blancs se
retrouvent à jouer genre passivement un
coup comme ça pour sauver le fou ben
d'ailleurs on voit il il y a pas de gain
matériel hein c'est juste
positionnellement que les noirs sont
tout d'un coup tout à fait écrasant
alors on s'attend pas à ce coup mais
d'ailleurs il y a eu un coup fou C4 a
priori le seulp coup c'est pour ça qu'il
y a un point d'exclamation donc les
joueux se connaissent cavalier prend le3
ouais connaissent prend la paire de fou
mais du coup il y a un problème concret
ici on a la dame attaquer il y a la
menace F prend 6 mais on connaît encore
contre-attaque sur le fou il va y avoir
fprend 6 dame prend 6 F prend 6 mauvais
non non c'était juste il s'est mis
orange mais c'était le le se bon juste
pour mettre un peu de couleur 1 3 encore
théorique pardon on a un petit Blitz
dans cette
partie ça va vite les jours se
connaissent bien on est au 18e coup 18 à
3 encore jouer à tempo bon là c'est
encore un coup très logique on peut se
rappeler de longues variantes comme ça
quand tous les coups sont logique hein
depuis cavalier B4 caver B4 je veut
faire des5 ro B1 empêche les magouilles
D5 comme on a dit si si les blancs
euh euh joue passivement les Noirs ont
plus qu'égalisé mais il y a cette
variante qui est vraiment forcée de
parer d'autres les Noirs menace A4
cavalier bouge A3 crée une épine donc A3
pour empêcher A4 suivi de A3 pause on a
toujours ce pion en E5 mais maintenant
qu'il y a plus beaucoup de pièces
mineures enfin plus qu'une seule pièce
mineure c'est beaucoup moins intéressant
donc ce pion contrôle des cases mais il
a plus de pièces pour empêcher
voilà l'avantage d'espace au centre
c'est c'est vraiment bien quand il y a
beaucoup de pièces et ce que tu disait
tout à l'heure la C cases affaiblie à
l'Ile d'ame on peut le regretter on
préfère avoir le pion à7 parce qu'il y a
plus d'attaque de de math on va pas
jouer à 4 à3 ou peut-être un jour B5 B4
mais peut-être quand même lointain et en
attendant ces cases sont faites pour
tout le reste de la
partie peut-être première
ouais première réflexion de Sophie on
voit qu'elle est en train de mettre
comme tu as dit ouis elle met le frein
et peut-être que A3 n'était pas un coup
qu'elle avait qu'elle avait préparé ou
peut-être que si ou peut-être que la
variante s'arrêtait là ou peut-être
qu'elle se remémoire juste ses variantes
tranquillement se réapproprie la
partie alors juste par
curiosité alors tu disais B4 B7 B5
est-ce que ça pourrait être une option
de balancer les pions sur on est sur des
Rocks opposés est-ce que ça ou est-ce
qu'il y a une réfutation
tactiqueelle à B7
B5 je pense juste mon idée c'est de
jouer B5 A4 B4 ouais parce que donc je
pense juste t gagn un pe là-dessus donc
tu disais A4 puis B4 je voilà alors j'ai
un petit problème de prise mais bon
c'est.com là c'est pas moi je crois sur
B4 tout de suite il y aurait A4 et ça
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on veut a pousé
tout option et puis on a rien ouvert
donc c'était pas la bonne idée donc on
peut jouer avec
A4
mais donc sur un coup de cavalier passif
B4 et c'est chaud on sacrifie le pion
mais on va se venger là-dessus ou alors
sur sur prise prise on attaque la tour
ça peut être chaud
mais
visiblement il y
a cavalier là
une prise
làdessus
encore calier prend
peutre
fourchette
des Atta et Atta je juste rafraîchir
parce que j'avais un petit problème de
de prise des
pièces est-ce que ça va mieux si je
rafraîchis la page ok en tout cas A3 a
été
joué bon le pion E5 il va falloir faire
quelque chose pour le protéger à un
moment sûrement j'ai pas envie de jouer
fou
F6
avec avec le le pion encore en F7 mais
j'ai pas non plus envie de jouer F5
parce que F5 FO F6 c'est long et puis le
fou en fait en F6 c'est euh il contrôle
plus aussi toutes les cases importantes
de l'aldom donc je sais pas comment on
va faire pour protéger ce pion
5 jouer juste avec F6 c'est un peu
triste aussi al en tout cas il y a pas
d'intérêt je pense à le jouer
immédiatement
[Musique]
euh on na pas envie de mettre le fond F6
parce que si le cavalier arrive en E4
alors là c'est ça ressemble plus à rien
est-ce que on a le temps de jouer un
coup par exemple comme B6 pour essayer
de contenir le cavalier avec comme idée
dans un second temps pourquoi pas de
jouer
avec peut-être en obligé de jouer F fou
F6 et f4ussi non F6 F4 ouais peut-être
fut F6 et forcé de manière
temporaire sur F4 tu veux prendre là je
pense que je peux prendre ouais sur F4
là ça donne
quoi peut-être tour 8 tour 2 peutêtre
qu'il ass de contrejeu
ouais moi le Fou est plus fort que enfin
potentiellement plus fort avec les tours
chiqu les
pions sur des opposés avec des majorités
le fou pe être plus fort que le cavalier
effectivement bon en tout cas première
réflexion de Sophie est-ce qu'on passe à
les chiquier de Mitra ou est-ce que tu
as oui un rajter ouions à faire ce petit
tour euh ouais un
rater donc
Mitra qui a commencer par 5/ C puis une
défaite une pause un match
nul mais elle est quand même très en
forme depuis le début de la compétition
elle commence plutôt par des4 et là elle
a choisi que les F3 G3 alors souvent
elle fait aussi des D4 et puis des
systèmes avec G3 mais c'est un peu une
surprise quand même elle elle en a joué
he je sais parce que je l'ai je l'ai
préparé au championnat de France Mitra
elle m'a éliminé sur sa route pour son
titre de de championne de France 2020 3
et donc je sais qu'elle joue parfois
qu'elle 3 G3 mais c'est vraiment pas son
premier
système
et C5 ici donc le plus souvent euh on
peut jouer des benonies inversé donc la
benonie c'est pas une très bonne
réputation mais là potentiellement les
blancs vont avoir deux tempis d'avance
un premier parce qu'ils ont les blancs
et pas les noirs et un deuxième parce
que le pion E6 va finir par venir 5
après avoir perdu un
on peut jouer avec C5 aussi euh
potentiellement ça peut être suivi de D4
si les Blancs jouent un coup comme root
même s'il est encore est-ce que la
benénonie avec de temps d'avance est-ce
que c'est bien est-ce que c'est pas bien
mais on peut aussi transposer dans la
variante Rubinstein de la défense tarage
une ouverture sur D4 après prise prise
et D4 on crée le pion isolé enfin on se
rapproche de la création du pion D
désolé ces pions là vont s'échanger tôt
ou tard et le fou en G2 est très bien
placé contre le pion disolé vu qu'il
tape
dessus donc c'est le coup principal
c'est prendre des5 suivi de
D4 des 4 tout de suite ça doit être une
transposition dans la Catalane est-ce
que c'est une bonne
transposition une pure trans je crois
que c'est juste une transposition de la
Catalane mais j'imagine qu'on peut
tu en as joué des Gambi Benko non euh
alors moi j'étais plutôt Benoni plus te
Benoni on peut jouer rock a et sur des
qu 3 Benoni pardon vas-y oui oui juste
j'allais dire il y a liste qui nous
demande pour enfin qui te posa la
question pourquoi est-ce que la
benénonie a mauvaise réputation dans le
chat en fait la benonie quand on a les
noir on a une structure de pion ouais je
te laisse mettre la position en gros
avec les noirs
on consciemment on a une mauvaise
structure de pion on a un pion décise
donc là vous le voyez qui est
extrêmement faible pour avoir en
contrepartie un dynamisme au niveau du
jeu des pièces pour avoir un jeu de
pièces actif donc si les blancs
choisissent un setup ils connaissent
bien ils arrivent à contrecarrer notre
activité des pièces au final si on
évolue si on arrive vers vers une finale
ou si l'activité des PI ah je m'emêle
les pinceaux si on arrive pas à jouer
comme il faut avec nos pièces en fait
les blancs vont faire pression sur le
pion D6 et gagner la partie tout
simplement ouais alors après c'est ça
vas-y vas-y je t'en prie ok jeis dire
c'est ça la difficulté c'est que si on n
pas si on connaitt pas bien la théorie
et qu'on a pas cette fibre avec
l'activité des pièces avec le jeu sur
case noire avec si on n pas prêt à
sacrifier des pions si on n pas prêt à
avoir des positions un peu entre
guillemets bizarre avec un déséquilibre
dynamique dans la position la benénonie
c'est pas fait pour pour pour nous quoi
ouais mais donc aussi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec tout ce que tu
as dit juste une précision enfin une
précision un ajout on parle de
l'ouverture benonie c'est celle-là on
parle aussi de la structure benonie
parce que cette structure de pion on
peut l' voir dans plein d'ouvertures
différent avec les blancs avec les noir
donc là comme on a vu une ouverture RTI
plutôt avec les Blancs qui pourrait
déboucher sur des structures pénonie
mais même parfois dans l'ouverture
espagnole on se retrouve avec ce genre
de structure et donc c'est important de
comprendre les plans les idées au-delà
d'apprendre le coup par cœur de
l'ouverture Benoni qui euh qui n'est pas
du tout la seule possibilité d'obtenir
cette structure mais donc là rien de
tout ça transposition avec des capes
dans la Catalane à moins que on obtienne
quand même une une défense tarrache pas
du tout impossible ce qu'on disait là on
peut imaginer prise prise maintenant et
on est à à nouveau dans le territoire de
la Tarche vous voyez d'ailleurs à quel
point les ouvertures fermées en général
qu'on commence par cavalier F3 ou par
des
qu peuvent transposer les unes dans les
autres quoi là on sait pas encore en
fait quelle ouverture c'est après
peut-être une catalane mais c'est pas
certain ouais vas-y et c'est
certainement tout l'intérêt de l'ordre
des coups que que Mitra a choisi euh en
fait elle se laisse cette flexibilité si
par exemple son adversaire joue un coup
qui potentiellement pour être moins bien
dans dans telle ou telle ouverture elle
se donne la possibilité de
transposer dans cette ligne là donc
c'est une ouverture qui est hyper
flexible mais c'est aussi une ouverture
un début qui nécessite énormément de
connaissance sur bah tu viens en cité
quatre ouvertures différentes ouais
c'est ça c'est un savoir bien plus
horizontal
euh que beaucoup d'ouvertur avec 4 ou
parfois il faut connaître des quelques
lignes mais sur sur 25 30 coups et là il
faut connaître plutôt beaucoup de choses
mais sur pas forcément beaucoup de coups
mais quand même beaucoup de choses bien
différents donc c'est un savoir bien
plus horizontal à noter qu'Inna réfléchi
quand même pas mal parce que après elle
a pas joué cinq coups encore elle a déjà
dépenser un quart d'heure de réflexion
mais c'est son style je suis pas
surprise parce que j'ai beaucoup de joué
beaucoup joué à côté d'elle et combien
de fois elle a fait ça et quitte a
parfois à transposer dans un truc
qu'elle connaît justement quand il y a
un embranchement comme ça elle peut
passer elle a justement ce côté beaucoup
de savoir mais horizontal elle va pas
forcément se rappeler de 20 coups de
thorie sur la ligne à la mode mais elle
peut expliquer pas mal d'ouvertures
différentes et donc elle va se poser
choisir son ouverture choisir son
système qui tu après à à débiter des dé
coups combien de fois je l'ai vu après
TR quatre coups mais mais pourquoi tu
réfléchis 10 minutes c'est hyper
flippant en tant que coéquipière quand
tu vois ta ta qui piar qui passe 10
minutes de réflexion après trois coups
tu es là mais euh dis-moi que tu connais
rassure-moi c'est inquiétant et en fait
il c'est c'est typique
euh et et donc juste j'en profite hein
vu que tu connais l'adversaire de de
Mitra elle a tendance à jouer plutôt
vite plutôt lentement une fois qu'elle a
passé la phase d'ouverture elle a
tendance à se mettre en Z not tendance à
craquer comment elle se non
j'étais alors elle a un peu ce côté
d'ancienne championne alors elle elle
est pas elle est pas vieille mais bon
elle on va dire que ses meilleures
années sont sont derrière elle et puis
elle le sait a parfois mal gérer le le
stress a plus supporter le stress comme
comme à la grande époque et donc je l'ai
vu parfois prendre des matchs nuls dans
des positions où où elle elle-même elle
sait qu'elle est mieux objectivement
mais c'est un peu la la panique quoi
mais cela dit pas du tout à sous-estimer
je l'ai dé j'ai vu
aussi jouer 30 coups avec 30 secondes et
puis finir par gagner la partie enfin
c'est c'est une très bonne chose moi je
l'avais joué une seule fois il y a une
quinzaine d'années et elle m'avait fait
une partie d'antologie je pense j'avais
joué un dragon pas forcément le meilleur
choix d'ouverture vu que elle-même en a
joué pendant des années et elle m'a fait
une partie qui mérite d'être dans tous
les livres sur le dragon qui quoi donc
non elle est capable de très très bien
jouer quand
M
juste un petit point qui pourrait être
intéressant pour resituer un peu le
match donc la France actuellement 13e
avec 12 points euh 3e avec 12 points la
l'Ukraine est 10e donc 5e au départage
mais mais 10e 5e mais 10e m départage
avec 10 points c'estàdire qu'une
victoire de l'Ukraine donc c'est deux
points euh peut-être
même avec une victoire ben l'Ukraine je
pense n'obtiendrait pas le podium mais
voilà donc il y a peut-être moins de
pression sur le dos des ukrainiennes que
sur le dos des Françaises ouais alors je
suis entièrement d'accord avec toi mais
après est-ce que c'est bien ou pas bien
c'est difficile de savoir il y a moins
il y a moins de pression mais il y a
moins de motivation aussi
donc c'est on parlait de pression et de
gestion du stress voilà ah oui oui en
terme de stress le stress du côté des
Françaises ouais après en terme de de le
jour de gloire est arrivé
ça ça c'est pour nous euh on passe à
popo
oui oui
oui donc popo la joueuse la plus en
forme de cette équipe de France tu nous
l'as dit 2721 c'est bien ça non je REM
de monter ici ouais ou ça doit jouer à
pas grand chose
7 de
perf malheureusement pas le nbre de
gromère comme tu l'as dit
mais un tournoi magnifique on va essayer
de le conclure par une nouvelle victoire
ça serait extraordinaire un peu le même
début mais donc là on a vu inagaponenko
jouer C5 ici Pauline a préféré jouer
fou7 et donc là oui dis-moi si mes
souvenirs sont bons
habituellement sur alors peut-être que
je dis n'importe quoi mais sur D4
Pauline a jouerait pas la Nimzo par
hasard
ouais elle joue plutôt de la Nimzo sur 4
d'accord mais je crois qu'elle a quand
même des connaissances assez poussé sur
différentes lignes ouais bah là là
justement
c'est sur les joueuses de
Nimzo enfin doivent pouvoir jouer avec
des 5 quand même quand les blancs jouent
pas pas des4 parce que on peut jouer B6
tu me diras des et tout mais Paine elle
a joué
beaucoup
iciç elle joue pas que Lao aussi mais
donc
effectivement des5
ici sur des 4 on peut pas faire un
répertoire
que que Nimzo Nimzo
après ok on est là
B3 alors il y a toujours cette question
de est-ce que D4 est pertinent ou pas
transposé dans dans ces bénonies
ou Benko slash Benko je crois que j'ai
déjà joué ça avec les Blancs ici C5 et
B4
ici parce que donc comment on dis oui
dis-moi j'ai l'impression alors je sais
pas juste au niveau intuitif j'ai l'IM
que le F il est pas super bien placé
ouis d'ù l'idée de jouer qu qui bloque
son ouais son action d' l'idée de jouer
des qu ici
mais après c'est vrai que si on compare
couleur inversée avec la la la benonie
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure le coup
B3 comme tu l'as dit c'est pas forcément
le plus utile parce que le F B2 et si si
les noir arrive à bloquer il est pas
bien placé mais en même temps avec les
Noirs comparé au blancs d'habitude on a
un temps de moins mais qu'on a les noirs
et on a joué a 6i alors que le plus
souvent on essaie de jouer avec E5 donc
mais des4 intéressant mais en tout cas
la joué B6 après seulement 25 secondes
de réflexion donc elle doit conna très
bien et puis puis ce temps de moins au
final il est un peu compensé par le B3
B6 B3 B4 des des blancs ouais donc euh
en tout cas c'est
c'est B6 are choix de pourquoi pas
puision prend
des5 toujours la grosse question comment
est-ce qu'on recapture sur pion prend on
peut voir des qu et justement ça ça
ressemble même c'est peut-être une
transposition directe dans une des
lignes de la Tarche dont on parlait tout
à l'heure dans la partie de de Mitra
avec une possibilité de création de pion
pendant après mais non Pauline a choisit
qu' les prendre des5 D4 fou B7 et on
peut avoir cette fameuse structure
symétrique par exemple après prise prise
euh enfin pas totalement symétrique mais
on va dire AB EFGH contre AB FGH ou
c'est juste le placement des pièces qui
fait la différence il y a pas eu la
prise encore il cavalier
D2 cavalier D7 E4 maintenant donc
finalement pas forcément de structure
symétrique le cavalier venu
là j'ai du mal à
savoir de réflexion après4
donc le cavalier attaqué il peut aller
là il peut aller là il peut aller
là ici ça peut être tant parce que il y
a ça
derrière
potentiellement cavalier D3 ensuite et
aussi avoir une une danse des cavaliers
par exemple
si B si on arrive pas aller en D3 on
peut t revenir en C6 et l'autre cavalier
va en F6 ça peut être de ouais ouais
mais en fait c'est c'est concret là là
on menace FO 6 quoi et cavalier de
TR ça ça et cavalier
C4
peut-être salut in salut à tous et
toutes ouais c'est dur évaluer ça ouais
donc elle a beaucoup réfléchi 10 minutes
dis-moi
oui dis c'est dur de se dire je vais me
clouer mon cavalier comme ça
ouais le cavalier C4 ou devant la tour
non c'est dur mais en fait elle a joué
au 4 très vite donc elle doit connaître
et là Pauline a réfléchi qu'elle est
elle a réfléchi forcément qu'elle les B4
du coup parce que c'est très tentant on
voit cette case magnifique le fou qui
peut venir là c'est c'est ultra tentant
quoi sur un coup comme à 3 on y va ah
oui bien sûr bien sûr un cavalier
Octopus c'est pas moi c'est le
cavalierctopous c'est
la en référence à gar la partie de gar
contre
Anatolie bon bref cavalier F6 la je
n'avait visiblement pas de préférence
entre cavalier B4 ou cavalier
F6 met la pression sur ce pion et on
s'apprête à revenir en D5 en cas de5 on
rebondit et les Blancs ne peuvent pas
jouer 4 pour faire matchul et donc dame
2 a été jouée elle continue à blitzer à
jou Cova donc ça c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle
elle est dans sa prépa toujours il y a
un problème pour les Noirs c'est cette
dame peut-être un plan comme ça mais
c'est un peu long peut-être un plan
comme ça mais c'est un peu lent en tout
cas cette dame risque de voir les tours
arriver sur les colonnes dessc et se
sentir un peu mal à l'aise donc je sais
pas comment est-ce qu'elle va régler ce
ce problème notre popo nationale ah il y
a eu un coup elle a pris il on des qu et
on donc après la recapture on aura
effectivement notre structure AB EFGH
contre AB EFGH mais avec quand même pas
mal de
déséquilibre et on est quand même alors
après par exemple cavalier prend des4
c'est le plus naturel ouais le plus
naturel ben le problème c'est qu'on ne
peut pas chasser le cavalier avec un
coup comme E5 parce que tout d'un coup
ben la case F5 devient devient faible la
case
D5 devient faible si par exemple on
décide de de jouer cavalier E3 cavalier
D5 et euh ouais donc le coup euh e 6 ce
5 est beaucoup trop affaiblissant
question est-ce devent compliqué de
laisser le cavalier en D4 en fait est
trop fort le
Octopus tout à fait non elle a J qui
allit prendre les qu est-ce que qui la C
5 il y a des idé de fois 6 ou alors elle
va juste faire qu' C4 et c'est pas
grave j'ai l'impression qu' C4 c'est pas
grave en fait ouais ok donc du coup il
faut régler ce problème de la
dame il faut régler ce problème de la
dame
parce que c'est ça va venir vite tour C8
metton tour
D1 l'ordi n'aime pas il aime pas parce
que maintenant après un coup comme E5 on
peut jouer tour C2 je pense on laisse la
Tour Noire rentrer dans le camp des
blancs elle est un peu seule c'est une
vraie menace c'est une vraie
menace c'est une vraie
menace ok bah c'est plutôt des une bonne
nouvelle ce ce truc parce que tour Fd1
c'est pour moi le coup le plus naturel
du monde ben après elle a pas jou tour
C8 he mais
ouis c'est ça a l'air quand même bien
plus facile à jouer pour les blancs
surtout si jokova est encore dans sa
prépa et donc là pas alors rien de grave
pour l'instant mais presque une
demi-heure de moins 25 minutes de moins
la pendule pour Pauline et des problèmes
à résoudre
peut-être un est-ce qu'on a le temps de
faire un truc comme ça aussi enfin j'ai
vraiment envie de la moi idéalement
j'aimerais faire petit rock avec la tour
et la dame là
tu
discrètement je tente le petit rock on
met la dame en a c'est c'est c'est sa
cas à pour la dame on met la pression
là-dessus et il y a plus d'histoire de
tour en face
mais ça risque d'être vu si on fait
petit rock
ici tour C8 ça paraî ça paraît bien
finalement tour C8 avec l'idée E5 mais
il faut voir ce5 c'est concret quand
même
ou mais je pense que oui c'est
complètement accessible à Pauline et
puis toi qui voulais faire petit rock ça
peut aussi donner envie de ouais
mais
on Al dit déteste
oui il aime pas parce que sur E5 on perd
un
pion en fait quand bouge la tour F il y
a plus de fou prend G2 fou prend F prend
F1 alors attends tu veux dire que par
exemple là si tu
joues5 F pr G2 prison
F7 tnac
et bouffe tout et à la fin on est
contente parce qu'on a tourc de ah ouais
c'est marrant com je la au ralenti
peut-être je la au ralenti par toi tu as
tu as tout calculer facile
mais moi aussi évidemment mais c'est
pour les spectateurs ris donc on propose
tour sville depuis tout à l'heure E5
c'est concret est-ce que c'est vraiment
grave si on joue qu' D5
ouais pas forcément mais l'ordi aime pas
donc on a un peu ce backup si les
tactiques marchent pas de pouvoir jouer
cal des5 mais on va essayer de faire
marcher des tactiques ça tombe bien
d'après l'ordi ça marche prise en G2 on
gagne une pièce sur pr G2 qui D5 c'est
clairement une version améliorée on
échangé notre fou B7 contre le Fou du
fianeto Roi et du coup le roi blanc est
durablement faible et maintenant ce plan
est vraiment fort donc les blancs
veulent faire marcher F6
elle on a plus le choix si on récupère
le pion on perd une pièce donc il faut
prendre
là pareil si les blancs prennent on
prend et on a qualité pion de plus donc
les blanc n'ont pas le choix il faut
tenter ça on n pas le choix prise les
blancs reprennent peu importe comment et
ont l'avantage matériel de pièces cont
tour et pion donc ça va pas donc il faut
prendre la dame prise prise c'est forcé
les blancs cap sur le cavalier on
l'avantage le matériel mais pour
seulement un coup parce qu'après tour C2
on regagne une pièce quelle
variante ouais faut bien voir tour C2 à
la fin qui permet elle a joué tour C et
tourté
jouer là il faut que popo voit ton E5
des familles mais tuur la bliter c'est
marrant pardon je t'ai coupé mais
ouais c'est assez marrant alors soit est
dans sa prépa soit elle est en roue
libre je sais pas parce qu'elle a pas
fait non plus un
tournoi je un peu elle a pas fait un
tournoi monstrueux non
plus coup
Natalia donc voilà avec des nuls contre
des 2100 des
2200 voilà donc c'est pas non plus un
grand tournoi donc soit elle est en roue
libre elle en a marre soit soit elle
connaît elle est bien préparée ou sinon
elle a juste envie de jouer des coups
naturels ouais ou alors elle connaissait
jusqu il y a peu et puis tour ça me
paraissait tellement naturel que elle se
dit ok je joue avec la main ça va ça
peut pas être mauvais en fait si c'est
mauvais parce qu'il y a torcéo qui
marche après ça donc là pourquoi
pourquoi TD1 n'est pas aussi bon qu'il
n'est paraî il y a E5 tout à l'heure on
disait5 très mauvais le cavalier bondit
en F5 et ça serait très mauvais pour les
Noirs s'il avait pas tour C2 qui pose un
problème
concret tour se coup pour protéger le
fou et on tape sur l're pièce
cloué c'est pas évident quand même de de
comprendre tout ça
mais ok Pauline peut jouer au 5
Pauline peut jouer au 5 et
ouais alors juste on pourrait être un
peu on pourrait avoir un peu peur et se
dire oh là là il reste plus que 1h2 à la
pendule pour poing Guichard alors que
son adversaire a 1h31 c'est 1h30 pour
jouer 40 coups donc là si on fait un peu
le ratio en général on se dit il faut
que j'ai joué mes 20 coups dans les 45
premières minutes donc là Pauline elle
en a joué 14 si elle arrive à 45 minutes
à la pendule elle a joué ses 20 coups
elle est ok niveau timing donc là en
fait ça gestion du temps est tout à fait
correcte voilà elle est pas en retard
par rapport à par rapport à une gestion
habituelle du temps c'est juste un
adversaire qui joue extrêmement vite
ouais et ce qui risque de se produire
c'est que quand son adversaire va devoir
reprendre la réflexion ben certainement
que ça va s'écouler par bloc de 10 15
minutes après il a il y a un avantage à
à jouer t d1 à tempo c'est que ça c'est
très difficile psychologiquement d'avoir
l'adversaire qui joue tout à tempo parce
que tu sais pas à quel point il y a
c'est peut-être du bluff comme là a
priori c'est peut-être du bluff ou à
quel point c'est juste elle déroule sa
prépa elle connaît tu joue en fait pas
contre Natalia jokova tu joues contre
stock fish 16 3500 ho et et donc c'est
dur psychologiquement quand tu là mais
qu'est-ce qui m'arrive je voulais juste
jouer une partie tranquille et je me
prends 15 coups de
prépa euh c'est dur c'est dur il y a une
question dans le chat mais j'ai pas
compris alors peut-être toi tu tu as
compris nana de Goblin show pense que je
pense que les drapeaux c'est là on est
sur une sur une compétition
internationale avec avec retransmission
des parties donc je pense pas que ce
soit les mêmes drapeaux que tu peux
choisir ou que tu peux mettre
sur sur ton pseudo de tess.com voilà on
est sur des choses différentes c'est
vraiment sur une compéti internationale
retransmise donc les vrais drapeaux ok
alors on a fait un premier tour
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on fasse nana
euh ben on va aller voir est-ce qu'on
peut faire un deuxième tour ascendant
rapide allez faisons un tour remonte à
Mitra Sophie faisons un tour remblant
rapter et après on va voir les gars ça
me va donc sachant que dis-moi je vaais
dire un tout petit peu plus tard on est
encore un peu tôt faudra qu'on jette un
coup d'œil des fois sur les parties de
nos des
adversaires des adversaires du combat à
distance à distance qui une fois qu'on
aura bien bien gagn le match
déjà on Séta qué ici a prise en C4 donc
là c'est plutôt la vraie
catalane le fou qui vient contrer le fou
en des
blancs et Mitra réfléchit
ici on peut gagner un pion mais a priori
pas forcément pour longtemps pas
forcément s'y accrocher à à se poncer
mais pour l'instant les noirs peuvent
pas
le est-ce qu'il peut faire comme les
blancs jouer dame à 5 et dame prend C5
euh mais il y a B4 HM B4 ok donc ça ne
marche pas B4 donc euh on est ici il y a
pas eu encore pris en C5
mais c'est un
coup les deux joueuses je sais pas à
quel point c'est théorique encore j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même une
grande ligne non on n'est pas si je fais
openings ouais prise en C5 c'est le coup
on va voir je triche j'ai mis la théorie
de chess.
comom cavalier de7 et le grand coup
menace de rturer le pion fou E3 on s'y
accroche fou D5 attaque la dame dame à 4
ah non pas de nul hein h pas de nul bon
on peut jouer dame C2 dame C2 FO 4 pas
de nul on a dit dame C ah ça ça me dit
des truc quand même cette manœuvre assez
typique on veut jouer cavalier C3 regard
un tempo
sur sur le F 4 sur le F très intéressant
comme manœuvre de ouais intéressant pour
éviter le le perpète en tout cas on est
là elle a pas encore pris on peut aussi
faire d'autres coups c'est pas forcé
euh Sophie avec les Noirs ça
sicilien qu'est-ce que ça
[Musique]
donne alors on s'était quitté sur A3
tour C8 a été joué
A4 on en parlait c'est toute l'idée
d'avoir joué à 3 les Noirs ne peuvent
pas jouer à 3 eux-mêmes tour à 5 un coup
toujours plaisant à jouer ce coup de
tour comme ça qui pas sur la colonne
ouverte mais je défends latéralement
peut-être je vais doubler un côté
esthétique à coup et on en est
là alors il AIB
tactique que Sophie doit être en train
de calculer je pense que ça ça peut être
fort potentiellement selon ce que je
voulais
blan ça
ça et un pion pour la
qualité donc là on men
concrètement tour C5 d' B2 HM donc faut
parer faudra faire attention
à attends est-ce qu'on menace vraiment t
C5 oui parce que qui prend c c oui le
fou pe oui alors je euh si je fais jouer
un coup idiot au blanc genre ça enfin je
sais pas si c'est idio mais là-dessus il
y a pas de sacrifice de dame parce que
c'est pas
bat
euh donc ouais non c'est c'est c'est
c'est marrant de cavalier A2 qui laisse
faire tour pr c de est-ce que est-ce que
roi prend et forcé
forcé si tu faut pas prendre c'est un
pion Mo ouais donc on est obligé de
prendre
donc pr de c'est très tentant et Sophie
elle est à la fut ce genre de de
tactique
euh très tentant Nord dit commence
dis-moi tour D3 ça peut être intéressant
l'idée c'est que sur tour C5 on peut
jouer et tour tour C3 et
couvrir il y a un petit échec encore
mais pas assez ce n'est qu'un échec
ouais d'un échec personne n'est jamais
mort c'est un proverbe russe non c'est
vrai c'est
vraiara d'un écheque personne n'est
jamais mort non mais dit ça quand les
échaces sont pas mortales on dirait
plutôt en français
mais pas toujours en tout cas
euh donc peut-être tour B5 au lieu de
tour C5 pour faire pression sur le pion
B2 tour B1 pour protéger le pion B2 il y
a aussi des coups DC1 et là comment
est-ce qu'on peut continuer notre
attaque donc c'est peut-être plus fort
que plus tentant que force
ce ouais on a toujours un pion pour la
qualité mais HM
ouais comme tu l'avais dit avant que je
te coupe on a l'impression que tout est
sous
contrôle après la position des blancs je
veux dire le roi C2 est lié à la défense
de la tour B1 la tour B1 elle est liée à
la défense du pion B2 donc euh on peut
jouer un coup comme
H6 éviter éviter les mats peut-être
avoir de fou G5 un jour ouais ça peut
être une idée
oui à voir est-ce que euh dis-moi tu
voulais rajouter un truc là-dessus ou ou
je regardais aussi des idées avec fou G6
ou F6 E4 et rajouter une pression à
nouveau sur le pion B2 par ex ou si
ouais un peu comme
ça
c'est une
idée bon en tout cas c'est une position
très compliquée mais les coups là que
nous venons de voir avec tour D3 et tour
B1 sont plutôt naturels pour les blancs
donc j'ai enfin je pense que c'est plus
au noir de prouver que leur sacrifice de
qualité marche h et et là-dessus tu
joues F5 pas non là-dessus je peux jouer
peut-être tour C5 et tour prend C3
puisqu a le pion là c'est oui tour C5 et
dame B3 là cette fois-ci je pense ça
doit marcher
OK et donc la question
c'est pas seulement est-ce que T pé de
marche est-ce que il y a un autre coup
parce que en fait si ça si ça marche pas
tant que ça mais que c'est le meilleur
coup quand même on va le jouer on va le
jouer
alors les blancs ce qu'ils veulent c'est
jouer cavalier
C3 il ils ont redirigé leur cavalier
pour aller sur la case C3 cavalier C1
cavalier a 2 cavalier C3 est-ce que on
peut profiter du fait ben qu'on
est est-ce qu'on peut empêcher cavalier
C3 ou
pas on a jamais sacrifice de qualité
possible
bon ça je pense que c'est pas mal mais
j'avais peur de juste prise ah mais je
me fais mat tu t'es pas maté en deux non
en
TR la meageuse la Meuse non je fais pas
matin de coups moi je me fais ma trois
coups moi en plus c'est même pas vrai
c'est matin
ouais mais du coup c'est peut-être un
coup aussi tour C5
ouais tour C5 même tour prend C2 en fait
c'est des coups qui sont hyper
compliqués à jouer parce que parce que
tu as la pression en fait tu peux pas te
dire je gambelle ma partie comme ça sur
un coup en est ça pour jouer un truc
comme ça c'est c'est dur par j'ai
l'impression que ça stabilise quand même
ouais
mais tu vois
là ça non non on naime pas
non parce que c'est c'est trop
affaiblissant je pense beaucoup trop
affaiblissant ouais une fois que le roi
est là je me
dis il y a il y a moins de sacrifice ou
de rupture quoi après c'est c'est c'est
bizarre mais oui dis-moi attends moi
j'ai l' que la structure de P noir
devient tout d'un coup un peu plus saine
que la structure de PION blanche malgré
le pion en A4 très bizarre ouais en
final on peut regretter d'avoir enfin
avec les Blancs d'avoir le P noir
en4 je suis d'accord mais après c'est
aussi est-ce
que si on a peur de ça bon on on va pas
le jouer on peut clairement avoir peur
ok donc une position très complexe parce
que ça fait déjà deux idées de sacrifice
qui sont pas claires et il en a
peut-être d'autres quoi c'est pas pas
forcé non
plus donc à voir Gross prcision et mais
le temps de réflexion toujours
malheureusement en faveur de la jouise
ukrainienne comme dans la partie de
popo un petit tour chez DD
ouais chez
Démé on s'était quitté dans cette fil d'
à ce moment VO là H3
H6 c'est un des nombreux plans ici on
peut jouer dame C7 on peut jouer B6 on
peut jouer H6 pour faire souvent faire
passer le cavalier raté par
là 3 à 5 dame
D3 la prise en D4
maintenant c'est pas bête de jouer ce
plan où les Noirs vont viser le pion E4
quand les blancs ont joué H3 si le pion
blanc était encore un
H2 ce plan des noirs de jouer avec C C5
fou F8 pour avoir toutes les pièces qui
attaquent sur le pion 4 est beaucoup
moins fort parce que les blancs peuvent
le consolider par F3 mais le combo H3 F3
est trop affaiblissant et donc là c'est
une vraie question qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire face à ça avec le pion4 qui est
vraiment sous sous pression je c'est pas
totalement un possible que ça
soit ma partie contre
Mathieu où
euh j'avais joué un cavalier C5 il
m'avait mis une dame là et puis il avait
joué cavalier F5 j'avais pris et je
m'étais faite déchirer
euh bah c'était dur hein il je me
rappelle
j'avais c'était la prépa cornette quoi
donc au 15e coup il avait genre 1h35 moi
j'avais 40 minutes j'avais ma poubelle
je me suis défendu comme j'ai pu mais
c'est c'était pas un combat armes égal
du tout ça ça ressemble vraiment
mais ok là c'est à l'ex championne du
monde de jouer avec les pièces noires
bon on s'attend à à ça ou ça peut-être
plutôt fou F8 j'aime bien le cavalier il
peut de toute façon il va venir à gain
temps mais pourquoi se priver de la case
5 CIS d'ailleurs dans la partie don je
vais plutôt jouer avec cavalier 5 lg6 à
un moment mais ça ressemblait vraiment
vraiment à
ça c'est intéressant ce système euh à
noter
parfois
non non je me demandais quelle C5 est-ce
que dame C4 parfois c'est un coup
aussi
on n pas envie de J tour F F auss si ça
donne la paire de
fou donc je seraai plutôt team FO F8
avec les noir mais non
c'est bon on verra ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
a
décidé en tout cas premier coup de
réflexion c'est prise en des4 donc de la
part des Noirs
ouais oui elle a réfléchi pour prendre
un des
donc pour l'instant un match un peu plus
équilibré hein c'est bon évidemment
c'est que le début mais rien n'est clair
les parties où on a les Noirs il y a cet
avantage de la pendule pour les
Ukrainiennes qui est assez déplaisant
mais la position va
encore alors nana que fait-on on fait un
mini tour chez les chez les gars un mini
tour Express ok sachant que on a déjà
une partie qui est terminée ah alors les
joueurs euh ben Étienne tu commences par
le TR ok non ben commençons par Étienne
non tu peux commencer par celle-ci il y
a pas de
souci tout façon on va y arriver donc
les Français jouent contre les les
Hongrois franç gris pour le retour de
marquan avec les
Noirs marquant qui avait été qui on a
commencé avec un un beau 3 sur qu et
pour les rend 7 et 8 qui a été mis de de
côté en cette période de
remontada je pense pour laisser les
joueurs
d'expérience jouer le tout pour le tout
ouais mais peut-être peut-être qu' qu'il
fallait plus la fou de la jeunesse que
que l'expérience B c'est facile de
refaire les matchs à
postériori quatre Fang quadruple
fianquetto de la manière la plus rapide
qu' soit je pense pas qu'on puisse faire
quatre fois en fianquetto qui soit pas
en prise plus rapidement que
là toutes ces possibilités de prise donc
qui va avoir des pions pendant quelqu'un
personne est-ce que on va voir ces qu
pions disparaître purement est-ce qu'on
va voir une nouvelle structure pour
l'instant rien n'est
clair pu en pendant ça serait par
exemple en cas de un coup comme ça prise
si on reprend on reprend on reprend
c'est cela qu'on appelle les pions
pendant bon là évidemment il y a une
qualité en prise euh pas forcément
d'ailleurs ouais c'est juste pour
illustrer la structure de pion et que tu
montres ouais ouais c'était ça oui mais
en plus non mais je suis même pas
certaine que là ça soit vraiment
prenable he si je pense que ça passe
parce que tu peux fermer peut-être avec
euh ouais non je voulais faire c si mais
il a me prendre
TR bon bizarre quand même euh mais ok
whatever c'était juste pour illustrer on
en est là dans la partie il y a pas eu
ce changement de structure c'est un
marquant de jouet la je nous dit que
c'est un peu plus
équilibré la structure originale et
symétrique bon on sait pas
trop quoi dire donc on passe moins de
temps pour nos joueurs non pas qu'on les
aime moins mais qu'il ne joue plus pour
ouais le podium il n'y a plus d'en
jeu notre tech
frress le pilier de cette équipe de
France environ 60 sélections je sais pas
combien mais c'est délirant ce nombre de
sélection P sais que tuis dire 60 ans
environ 60 ans une sélection par an en
moyenne depuis sa naissance
il a
joué une petite berline avec des
[Musique]
TR et ça
réfléchit ce qui est bien c'est que
c'est tellement un joueur de 45 avec les
deux couleurs depuis longtemps qui
connaî vraiment énormément de subtilité
dans toutes ses positions ça ressemble
c'est espagnole une berlinoise mais ça
ressemble aussi beaucoup l'italienne
mais de toute façon il a tout jouer avec
les deux couleurs qu'on peut être assez
confiante sur ses connaissance mais je
suis assez surprise parce que tu vois on
est au au 11e coup alors moi j'ai du mal
avec toutes ces petites nuances de
position et euh et c'est vrai qu'il a
déjà utilisé 20 minutes à la pendule
donc tu dis si les coup sont enfin
est-ce qu'il y a encore des surprises et
des ouais mais en fait oui oui ça y en a
plus le temps
hyper analys c'est c'est c'est marrant
parce que je parlais de Laurent un élève
juste avant je donnais un cours juste
avant le stream on parlait de
l'italienne et il me disait mais je
comprends pas c'est subtilité c'est 1 2
3 c'estes subtilité d'ordre de coup et
tout c'est un élève à genre 1500 ho
elle lui disait non mais j'en ai parlé
avec Laurent qui joue ça depuis toujours
et il comprends pas non plus enfin
souvent il comprend ça mieux mieux que
personne mais il souvent tu le voit même
dans les positions connues c'est au 7e
coup d'une Italienne et il va passer 10
minutes de réflexion tu là mais je
comprends pas c'est c'est pas c'est pas
toute ta vie cette position et pourquoi
tu réfléchis et en fait il y a toujours
des petites subtilités c'est euh
justement c'est énormément d'histoire
d'ordre de coup est-ce que là c'était H3
tout de suite est-ce que c'était H3
avant est-ce que c'était fou B3 tout de
suite fou B3 avant c'est c'est horrible
c'est vraiment un
labyrinthe bon là le cavalier F1 c'est
pour aller ici
est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on pense de ce
changement de de structure ah j'aianaly
sur le petit échiquier j'is en train de
me dire qu'est-ce qu'on pense de
cavalier c'est pour aller ici et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on pense de ce changement
de structure est-ce que ça favorise
forcément les blanc parce qu'on reprend
vers le centre est-ce que ça favorise
les noir parce queion est arrière sur la
colonne ouverte est-ce que on veut le
faire tout de suite est-ce qu'on veut le
faire après qu'est-ce que tuen pense des
pr je pense que
alors c'est absolument rien dire j'
tendance à dire qu'il y a pas d'urgence
en soi parce qu'après si les blancs
veulent prendre en D4 on peut reprendre
avec une pièce et garder le le pion
arrié en D3 donc en soit il y a pas
d'urgence à se jeter immédiatement dire
si on joue un coup je sais pas si c'est
un coup mais on joue un coup comme ça à
chaque fois qu'on peut reprendre avec
une pièce on est content estce que il y
a ça
ouais j'ai l'impression qu' il y a eu un
coup qui est joué fou6
ok bon moi je suis toujours confiance
vas-y dis-moi oui tu fais confiance à
Laurent bien sûr on fait confiance à
Laurent mais là par exemple sur fouprend
6 si les blancs décident de prendre en
les6 les Noirs reprennent avec la tour
ouais et quand cavalier G3 on n'a pas
peur de la
case F5
ouais alors quand quand le Caval
s'éloigne aussi du centre euh tous ses
plans de jouer avec contre le pion
arriéré ils font peur aussi quoi on peut
pas juste jouer pour le mat comme ça
alors que le centre peut s'ouvrir avec
des pr
C3
mais je trouve enfin je connais très peu
c'est je joue pas4 et je joue pas5 mais
j'en ai quand même vu parce que les gens
jouent tellement ça tout le temps je
connais quasiment aucun exemple où la
tour est déjà en E8 et on fait quand
même F6 il y a des exemples où la tour
est en F8 les Noirs jouent fut E6 les
blancs prennent on reprend du du pion ça
oui mais la tour est déjà là enfin et
encore là elle a pas perdu un temps là
si on reprend on a perdu un temps à mal
placer la tour qui serait mieux placé
ici c'est c'est très très rare très très
rare ouais c'est complètement cohérent
ce que tu dis OK et ben c'est
complètement logique oua et ben tu non
il reste quand même un échiquier avant
une partie celle de de Baky donc s
terminé visiblement
Roulio avec les Noirs je les mets sur le
petit échquier également voà si je casse
pas tout Rio
rouio
cette
antirunfeld anmétrique création d'un
pion faible
ok moi je suis pas une spécialiste je
sais qu'il y a énormément nul rapide
dans cette variante
que beaucoup de gens ont joué à à Maxime
comme il jou que la grunf jusqu'à y a
peu mais là c'est on est quand même une
position 10m rique avec ses pions
pendant justement on en parlait tout à
l'heure donc c'est les deux pions qui
n'ont plus personne à côté d'eux enin
eux ils sont côte à côte mais ils ont
plus personne de l'autre côté et ils
sont sur deux colonnes ouvertes ou seé
ouvertes donc ils sont forts parce que
ils contrôlent les cas centrale ils sont
faibles parce que ils peuvent pas être
défendus par quelqu'un d'autre que leur
collègues juste à côté leur voisin et
ils sont sur des colonnes
semi-ouvertes du coup c'est une
structure déséquilibrée est
intéressante un petit commentaire
nana ça t'inspire ça tinpirepire
absolument rieni dans ce que tu dis il y
a pas mal de parties qui se terminerait
par par l'annu ouais alors c'était
plutôt avant ici ouais il y a dans cette
position symétrique je sais que Maxim il
a plein de parties où c'est nul rapide
sans sans aucun espoir t liquide mais
maintenant qu'on en est là
euh ça me paraît pas du tout évident que
ça soit nul rapide c'est je pense les
trois résultats sont possies la position
est très
déséquilibrée après on n'est jamais à
l'AB d'une liquidation hein c'est des
super grands maîtres mais ok quand
qu'nait un peu le caractère de Jules on
on se dit qu'il est pas trop du type à
jouer pour la liquidation rapide et h il
aime bien il aime bien il aime les
échecs et il aime bien jouer enfin
chaque partie est une chance de jouer de
de gagner de prendre des points de de se
battre de se confronter donc ouais c'est
vra que c'est pas son caractère de de
s'arrêter
ouais bon on
verra ouais oui oui mais mais on verra
ce qu'il en est et donc tu nous ai une
partie déjà terminée Baki qui doit
encore s'en
vouloir de son g raté
hier qui ah oui il a pas joué beaucoup
effectivement
es f 3 kg4 F
34 c'est une nulle qu'on a déjà vu et
revue eten bakro dégoûté de son gain
raté
qui décide de ne pas jouer cette
dernière
partieon après est-ce que c'est après
j'imagine que ce genre de décision avec
les Blancs euh ils ont dû en discuter
avec le
capitaineandon parce que sinon euh si tu
fais nul il y a pas de souci quoi c'est
pas grave si si quelqu'un avait envie de
jouer et que tu dis non non c'est bon
laisse-moi les blancin et puis que tu
fais nul rapide on peut t'en vouloir ok
nana est-ce qu'on rourne chez les filles
est-ce que tu veux faire ta pause tout
de suite c'est oui oui prenons prenons
une pause
allez petite pause et on revient dans
quelques minutes pour commenter cette
dernière ronde du championnat d'Europe
avec on le rappelle
une médaille potentielle à la clé pour
nos joueuses de quelle couleur c'est
tout l'enjeu de cette ronde à tout de
suite
[Musique]
et nous revoilà en compagnie de Natasa
benmesba pour suivre cette dernière
ronde du championnat d'Europe donc eten
bakro a fait match nul mais on va
retourner chez nos joueus qui joue pour
le podium pour toutes les places du
podium potentiellement pour n'importe
quelle place
plutôt on commence par qui par popo 4
par DD comme tu veux ouais Pauline tu es
allons-y Pauling Guichard qui a les
Noirs dans cette
partie alors laissez-moi remettre la
position c'est bon on s'était quitté par
la tour CV venait d'être joué tour D1 on
expliquait que le coup E5 était possible
tactiquement parce que stratégiquement
ça a l'air affreux de donner cette case
mais il y avait le coup tour C de qui
trouver du contrejeu dame C7 l'ordi
n'aime pas mais cavalier C4 l'ordi
n'aime pas alors essay de comprendre
ces ses coups d'ordinateur on avait
expliqué le coup E5 plus dangereux quand
la tour avait quitté la case F1 parce
que il y avait pas la variante fou prend
G2
prend F6 fou prend F1 ici qui man
donc ça a l'air d'être5 mais pourquoi ce
qui est dur à voir c'est pourquoi c'est
si grave
ça paraît pas
évident en fait si tu arrives à garder
le pion en E5 bah tu as une grosse bah
tuas un caillou dans la chaussure tu as
une grosse épine dans le pied ce pion E5
est quand même assez
dévastateur il contrôle la case DC il
prend l'espace alors je pense tout
réside sur le fait par exemple après
cavalier C4 qui protège le pion5 est-ce
qu'on arrive à garder le pion5 est- on
joue un coup
juste même positionnel quoi j'ai pas
compris pourquoi c'était c'était si
grave et
ok l'option cavalier B5 cavalier
D6
ça c'est rel ça ça a l'air fort quand
même si par exemple tu joues A6 au lieu
de dame C7 qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire avec les les blancs
ouais al
a non m on a même des coups comme ouais
tour C1 on a même des coups aussi comme
cavalier F5 peut-être qui peuvent son
vis
ouais avec des pièces blanches qui
dominent complètement les pièces
noires et ben heureusement ça n'a pas
été joué pas vu pas pris FO
6 clou le cavalier C4 oui dis-moi tu as
vu c'est ce qu'on disait hein Natalia
zukova qui a blitzé tous ses coups
d'ouverture et premier coup de réflexion
cavalier C4 elle trouve pas le bon coup
ouais le5 voilà donc bon elle a pris
quand même un avantage assez important
au temp face à Pauline à la pendule
penduleors que Pauline accélère il lui
reste
ouais fallir qu'elle accélère ouais 20
coup en minutes ça va être ça peut être
un peu chaud très dur pour les blancs
vite en fait moi j'ai envie de donner ce
fou pour garder un bon contrôle des des
cases noires avec je sais pas bon
peut-être peut-être qu'il faudra jouer à
6 quand même B5 ça peut être dérangeant
mais un truc comme ça
si si les Blancs n'ont rien tactiquement
j'ai l'impression que ma fou prend5 ça
fait cher quand même à C prend à 7
cavalier prend à 7 tout de suite
peut-être il y a le pion à 4 derrière
qui tombe ouais mais c'était moins ce
que je
voulais donc peut-être plutôt à 6 et si
les
blancs laissent faire fou C5 au blo ça
peut être une mauvaise structure quand
même
h l'impression que c'est plus intuitif
après peut-être c'est qu'elle les prend
ces quat mais
ok en tout cas on en est là alors c'est
le temps qui est inquiétant comme tu dis
mais maintenant la position on sent que
ça doit aller en gros dans cette PAE les
blancs les noirs doivent voir est-ce
qu'il y a un réel je vais dire une
bêtise je retire ce que j'allais dire
non je me posais la question est- qu'on
pouvait prendre E5 mais en fait il est
juste cloué le cavalier en E5 donc
Pauline a joué fou prend C4 ouais
ça4 c'était ce à quoi on s'attendait et
donc il a pas encore eu la recapture
mais il va y avoir c'est bon c'est joué
et ici que jouton
elle a joué à 6 on leur dit nime pas
mais c'était le coup qu'on suggérait
aussi pour empêcher les cavaliers
B5 et donc c'est vraiment au blanc de
montrer que il y a quelque chose en
échange de la mauvaise structure c'est
pion isolé en A4 et en
C4 le live bar se met à jour
roital non il se met pas à jour le live
un bug
ça dépend des fois il en fait un peu des
siennes il est censé il est censé mais
c'est un live board
fon c'est plus un board qu'un liveard ou
not
live not live
ok encore un petit mot sur cette partie
de popo ou non je suis je suis je suis
d'accord qu'on qu'on a jeté un un coup
d'œil sur les les autres les autres
parties un dead
board comme un Death un deathbard comme
death not ah c'est bien le manga ouais
ouais c'est trop
bien celui qui m'en a
parlé la première fois de dasn c'était
Maxime va chez La Grave il m'a dit
j'adoris c'est vraiment intelligent et
tout je pense que ça te plait je dis
mais tu es sûr par que je su manga je
suis pas trop manga là
ouis si si si c'est vraiment bien puis
ouis j'ai beaucoup aimé et tu avais tu
avais le manga en bouquin tu as eu la
l'animé après bon le film je trouvais
qu'il était pourri non j'ai par É ouiss
que que l'animé quoi ouais l'animé était
fou ouais on aimait bien ok alors la
partie de Mitra on s'est quitté ici fa
Princess 5 qui a eu cavalier C3 non
enfin CIT quiit même avant des Prin 5
cavalier BD7 on avait dit que F 3 un
coup possible pour qu'on le pion encore
un petit peu mais on allait finir par
ledre finalementra tout de suite Dame
des
bon Dame des 3 je pense qu'elle avait
peur de fou prend C3 et F prend F2
ou donc si on joue un coup
bête D4
mais en D3 la
dame pas certaine quand
même parce que ça ça va bouger ça ça va
bouger ça ça va venir ici rendez V
développement des pièces noires a l'air
un peu plus simple en
fait l'air plus logique
ouais il peut y avoir aussi des
problèmes sur F2 genre rock si on joue
tour D1 est-ce que il y a pas déjà des
trucs sur F2 cavalier G4 qui force un
coup qu'on veut pas jouer comme 3 G4 ou
ou dame B6 avec la même idée hein F
prend F2 dame B6 et obligé de faire il a
pas 4 ouais et là tour D8 et on a gagné
ah ouais non ça c'est horrible en terme
de
développement en terme de développement
ça pas du tout ouais DD3 j'ai du mal à
me
l'expliquer j'aurais préféré venir en
B3 qui t rebougé la dame bon déjà je
pense que les Noirs ont confortablement
égalisé
mais sa qu'on aurait préféré avec avoir
le fou en E3 et la dame cachée en C1
dans la variante que tu montrais où où
on s'accrochait au pion et on manœuvrait
de sorte à à cacher la dame pour ensuite
pouvoir développer le cavalier en C3 et
c'est VI qu' on voit qu'il a les pièces
sont beaucoup plus harmonieuses et on a
surtout ben plus de tempo de de
développement on a déjà fini no dé
ouais et puis là c'est pas simple hein
ce ce fouet bon peut-être en F4 mais il
faut être sûr queil y a jamais de 5 un
jour bon ok on est là on a cette
position c'est à Ina de réfléchir mais
l'ordinateur donne petit avantage noir
petit quand même assez conséquent et on
comprend
malheureusement Sophie qu'est-ce que ça
donne chez Sophie sa sicilienne on
parlait de potentiel sacrifice ou là ben
je vois il y a une tour en C
de non je fait ce qu'il fallait pas
faire si je mets le
dasboard
également donc on était ici tour à 5 ça
on disait ah oui non elle a quand même
fait un truc bizarre non parce qu'on
disait tour C5 cavalier C3 et ici
peut-être un truc comme t prend C3 ou
pas mais elle est passée par B5 il y a
eu cavaler C3 elle est venue en C5 donc
en fait on a la même position avec un
temps de moins que très bizarre que
celle qu'on regardait mais tu as raison
ouais c'est ouais c'est la même
je sais pas peut-être peut-être il av un
autre coup sur tour C5 qui lui plaisait
pas mais que cavalier C3 mais peut-être
qu'elle préférrait que le cavalier soit
en C3 plutôt qu'en B4 mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est bizarre d'accepter de
rentrer dans cette position avec un
tempo en moins c'est j'avais proposé
cette idée C3 C B4 mais on disait que
c'était pas non plus convaincant
convaincant
quoi bon en tout cas c'est la partie et
là un coup
responsable prise en A4 force t C2
ouais c'est c'est fou
de c'est con faut que ce soit du du
concret c'est vrai
oui alors je pense que l'idée c'est quoi
c'est sur dame
prend5end 5
si F6 non F6
où est-ce qu'on met la
tour peêes juste tour B5
non et cette finale serait finale avec
un pion de plus ouais plus euh de
plus mais il y a
des il y a des thèmes quand même
euh
ça c'est un cou ou c'est totalement
idio bon mon idée c'est que si tu manges
ah Mo je voulais gagner la
dame je gagn la dame
mais a priori bon si c'est mat le mat
prime B c'est pas c'est pas si facile
mais
rol Jol j'ai j'ai fait je sais pas
combien d'échecs en C de on en Touc Touc
Touc Touc Touc Touc Touc bon allez tout
était forcé on avait tout prévu euh donc
dame G6 c'est un coup que c'est
compliqué cette
position
VO dame
là dame 4
peut-être donc t prend C de jouet il y a
pas eu encore d'ame PR5 mais c'est le
coup auquel on s'attend et une autre
possibilité c'est de prendre en
G2
menace l'échange a l'air forcé
pour l'instant il y a égalité de
matériel ça c'est de plus pour les
blancs attaque ça mais oui dis-moi on
apprécie l'activité des pièces noires en
fait ou ce fou F6 qui est monstrueux une
tour sur la deuxième la deuxème rang
potentiellement une deè bientôt le
cavalier défend mais il peut se faire
attaquer il y a des thèmes de si on joue
B5 et le C bouge tu prend B2 ça va faire
des petits
dégâts donc oui après tour B6 tour prend
H2 tour prend B7 on est un peu bon les
Blancs ont un pion de plus mais c'est la
course la course P H5 peut aller très
très vite surtout que le cavalier il est
de l'autre côté des chiqu il est en A4
oui il aura du mal à se sacrifier et en
plus il aura même du mal à jouer tout
court parce que si on bouge les pions la
faiblesse la 7e rangée enfin la deè
rangée est quand même présente moi je
peux faire ça ça ça par
exemple non mais c'est c'est un peu
téléphoné mais c'est nous on pousse les
pions et du coup on se fait pas matter
parce que il y a toujours des cases de
fite et les blancs poussent leur pion
mais du coup ils sont matés parce que il
y a la 7e
rangée
donc pas simple enfin pas simple du coup
tant mieux ce tour pr c de réflexion
dame pr 5 vient d'être joué après 7
minutes de réflexion et donc ici sopie
on espère pour
de je trouve ça hyper hyper compliqué
comme coup à jouer cavalier prend à 4 et
d'autoriser une tour à rentrer sur la
deuxième rangée ah il faut pas avoir
peur ah oui ah oui il faut être fa avoir
confiance en ses compétences de
calcul de calculatrice
ouais parce que donc on avait aussi
proposé prise en 5 d'AM G6 bon c'est des
varant qui n'étaient pas convaincante
mais qu'il faut quand même avoir prévu
de de loin et donc ce tour prend G2
bon la finale on est contente quoi
est-ce que il y a possibilité d'éiter
cette finale en sachant qu'il a cet
échec potentiel et comme on a vu avec
Laam G6 ça peut faire des dégâts aussi
dur imagine autre
chose bon et qu'on obtenu après prend6
puis on prend6 t prend6
F6 ça on est
contente vraiment on est très très
cont est pas difficile c'est de faire ça
donc est-ce que l'ordi défend peut-être
mais en tout cas avec les noirs on a des
prochains coups assez automatiques et
sur on peut pas sauver le spion parce
que il y a B5 et là c'est
horrible et là c'est
horrible donc bah tant mieux j'ai envie
de te dire tant mieux que alors juste ça
oui ça on se fait pas mat non tuas
encore un peu de marge au pire tu peut
jouer H6 ouais au pire on va
déjà on sauve et puis ça c'est la
finales de tour sont toujours nul ouais
peut-être pas quand il y a double tour
et que il y a un roi qui peut se faire
maté donc on voit cette 7è rangée
absolue oui
dis-moi partir du principe que les
finales de tour sont t nul pour les
autres pas pour soi
ouais les autres arrivent toujours à
faire nul mais nous ouais ouais ouais
c'est toujours plus compliqué ouais et
puis bon même quand elles sont Nules
elles sont perdables
ah ok donc dame
prend5 Sophie réfléchit encore on veut
voir ce tour prend
G2 est-ce que
ouais est-ce que B5 tout de suite ah
mais B5
d pr B5
ouis
B5 si la dame prend ici ça c'est la même
variante c'était ce que je voulais
avoir même si l' dit que ça ça va aussi
non ben c'est vraiment d' prang de mais
qu'elle le joue pas je suis j'ai envie
de le voir j'ai envie de le voir
oui ah oui donc ce toursen ne marche pas
si la Tour Blanche avait été en D de ou
en en des TR on va dire et parfois il il
y a ce thème de tour déviation là ça
marche très bien on reprend même sur
échec on prend la don euh mais là pas du
tout j'ai j'avais pensé aussi je l'ai
pas mentionné parce que ben ça marche
pas
mais ici reprend mais j'aurais pu le
mentionner
ou donc non c'est c'est bien d'y penser
de toute façon il faut y penser c'est un
échec et potentiellement benah ça gagne
là il y a une variante où ça perd du
coup on le joue pas mais on y pense on y
y pense toujours il y a pas de mal à
penser à des variantes qui marchent pas
he c'est c'est même le ça fait partie du
intégrante du jeu si on calculait que
les bonnes variantes ça serait pas
rigolo on calcule plein de variantes il
y en a beaucoup qui March pas on les
élimine on les joue pas parfois ça nous
donne des idées pour les faire marcher
parfois on voit un coup qui marche pas
mais on veut faire marcher et puis on y
arrive c'est c'est comme ça qu'on
réfléchit en fait oui ça te permet
d'avoir une compréhension plus globale
de la position
et ce qu'il faut pas oublier que par
exemple si j'envisage une variante au
coup 16 j'ai une idée que ça ne marche
pas ça ne veut pas dire que cette idée
ne marchera pas au coup 19 ou 18 ou 23
ou 24 donc en fait tout ce qu'on pense
dans une position pendant sa partie
pendant tout ce toutes les pensées qu'on
a tout ce qu'on envisage les coups ce
qui marche pas en fait ça peut toujours
servir à n'importe quel moment dans la
partie et faut pas juste ça ne marche
pas à l'instanté donc j'ff non ça ne
marche pas mais je le garde derrière la
tête parce que là ben pour cette raison
ça ne marche pas mais tout d'un coup
trois coups plus tard ben je suis en
train de m'emer les pinceaux TR coup
plus tard bah cette cette ce cette ce
qui m'empêchait de faire marcher la
combinaison ben n'est plus là donc
peut-être que maintenant ça marche voilà
il y a plein de choses comme ça
qui je pense que vous avez compris moi
j'ai compris et je pense que les gens
aussi alors je vois un coup été joué t
pr de bonne nouvelles et euh alors je je
vois qu'il y a quelqu'un qui repose la
question Marie Sebag ne joue plus en
équipe de France pour interrogation euh
bah pas cette année euh après Marie elle
joue beaucoup beaucoup moins qu'à son
l'époque où elle était pure joueuse
professionnelle on l'a déjà dit hier
elle est psychologue elle a fini ses
études de psychologie il y a quelques
années elle a ouvert son son cabinet de
psychologue et B donc ayant un métier
évidemment les échecs sont délaissés et
du coup euh c'est aussi l'occasion de
créer bah une nouvelle dynamique en
équipe de France et et voilà mais donc
après ça veut pas dire que Marie ne va
plus jamais rejoindre l'équipe de France
si finalement elle décide que son
cabinet de psychologie elle en a marre
et qu'elle veut rejo au échec de malur
professionnel elle est grand maître si
elle sera entraîne et tout il y a peu de
raison qu'elle ait pas sa place en
équipe de France
mais pas euh pas à boudva au Montenegro
en
2023 ok petit tour au premierchiqué
ouais allons voir démonter alors juste
pour information dans le match Bulgarie
geéorgie h il y a eu un match nul à
l'chqu numéro 2 entre la Grand Maître
Georgienne btiashevil contre le maître
international salimova
ok donc ouais ça on peut on peut le
rappeler tu tu nous rappelles les donc
la France joue contre l'Ukraine à enfin
la table numéro 3 et tu nous rappelles
les deux premiers
matchs alors donc on se rappelle on se
rappelle donc la Bulgarie est première
et seule en tête un point devant
l'équipe d'azerbaïjan juste pour le
rappel suivi de la France un point
derrière donc là la Bulgarie est en
train de jouer contre la Géorgie table
numéro une donc nous ce qu'on souhaite
c'est vraiment chat noir pour espérer
que la France puisse ben gagner la
compétition donc on a dit que entre les
mains des Françaises donc c'està dire
qu'il faut qu'il y ait différentes
conditions qui
soient fa que différentes conditions
soient réalisées et donc il faut que les
Bulgares perdent il faut que
l'Azerbaidjan gagne pas et que les
Françaises gagnent donc ça fait
énormément de
conditions et donc là on suit de loin le
match Bulgarie Georgie donc il y a sur
les quatre parties l'échiquier numéro 2
a fait match nul et si on regarde le 4e
échiquier donc entre Melia Salomé pour
la Georgie et
krasteva pour la Bulgarie a priori la
joueuse Georgienne est
mieux ok on suit de loin ce match il y a
le match Serbie aerbaïjan table numéro 2
bon là c'est à peu près égal sauf au 4è
échiquier où la joueuse azéie a déjà
pris un petit avantage donc on suit de
loin ça marche ça marche alors cette fil
d'or on s'était quitté ici on avait
expliqué F8 cavalier D7 en C5 C7 en E5
possible cavalier E5 a été joué dame 2
ça a pas beaucoup changé mais attention
quand même à ce
cavalier5 est-ce que un moment les
blancs vont pas pouvoir jouer F4 alors
F4 ici il faudra faire attention à des
dames B6 mais c'est pas dit que ça soit
toujours toujours bon ce d B6
réponse F4 doncon le cavalier sur une
belle case centrale il peut réfugier en
G6 si vraiment il y a besoin mais
ce F4 peut faire mal aussi est-ce que tu
as vu le le temps ouais on nous le dit
rockyal ou chez Nina mal temp ouais la
championne du monde
2012 ben effectivement donc bonne
nouvelle on prend elle a mis 28 minutes
44 secondes à jouer ce coup cavalier
e5ah tant mieux réfléchis
réfléchis quoi- qu'elle réfléchit
incroable c'est assez incroyable parce
que finalement c'est elle qui a décidé
de de l'ouverture d'une certaine manière
c'est elle qui a choisi de jouer la
filidor la défense filidor elle a
réfléchi 10 minutes pour jouer pr des qu
28 minutes pour jouer cavalier E5 et là
elle prend également pas mal de temps
pour pour jouer son coup euh
c'est assez
surprenant cou F jouer donc la question
c'est ah non le temps c'est il y a eu un
problème de retransmission le temps est
beaucoup mieux ah oui d'accord d'accord
ok mais combien ah oui ok c'est par
qu'il y a le quart d'heure de délai du
coup ça fait bugger les pendules je
pense c'est la FIDE qui a mal géré son
truc ça la promise c'est pas t ch ce n
pas de ma faute mais donc ça veut dire
que en vrai c'est dire que au prochain
coup
hinen risque de de réfléchir 15 minutes
encore et de se retrouver à 15 minutes à
la pendule non non non non non je crois
que c'est je sais pas mais que quand il
y a un délai parfois ça bug parfois ça
bug
d'accord d'ailleurs même quand il y a
pas de délis mais surtout quand donc la
question fou F8 vient d'être jouée
est-ce que on peut jouer F4 avec les
Blancs parfois attention parce que le
pion E4 on avait expliqué qu'il y avait
un plan de l'attaquer donc il pourra
plus jamais êre protéger par F3 mais en
attendant c'est quand même tentant de
mettre ces pions à l'attaque un truc
comme ça bon le le cavalier revenu sur
sa case mais il y a des possibilités
d'attaque à l'rooi aussi je je sais pas
après peut-être c'est trop tôt peut-être
qu'il faut le préparer par juste pardon
si j'arrive des coups comme
ça
mais pas
simple faudra que je regarde ma partie
contre Matthieu c'était vraiment un truc
similaire pense que tu l'as sur sur ch
base ouais c'est une partie Top 12 donc
non mais je veux pas ouvrir là mais je
regarderai peut-être à la prochaine si
vraiment c'est similaire je ferai la
attend je regarde par curiosité t je
déchèque je ne peux pas laisser une
question en suspens
ok bah du coup je vais essayer de de
meubler donc c'est vrai que ce coup F4
avoir les deux pions les plus avancés
côte à côte c'est souvent une bonne idée
parce que les pions une fois qu' sont
côte à côte ils contrôlent toutes les
cases devant eux il repousse les pièces
adverses à voir donc si ce pion est pas
trop faible à voir si on peut pas juste
prendre son temps et jouer F 3 consolidé
pas simple alors imaginons qu'il a les
G6 quand même attaque le pion
ici est-ce que c'est une vraie attaque
c'est même pas
certain il y a un thème que je veux vous
montrer c'est tour D1 coup de
développement CER prend 4 a l'air de
gagner un pion mais comme dans des
italienne il y a des thèmes sur F7 qu'
est pr F7 pr F7 fou prend F7 échec on
prend F7 dame F3 échec regagne le
matériel avec
intérêt et les noirs sont foutus donc
cal G6 ne menace pas forcément de
prendre pas tout de suite en tout
cas y ouais juste pour répondre à ta
question donc la partie donc 9 tour 1 et
tu avais joué cavalier B6 et non
prise
Cali
B6 j
cavalier non non c'est pas ça c'est pas
H3
pris en D4 c pr D4 cavalier C5 et dame
F3
cétait ça il
connaissait connaissa très bien très
bien j'avais pas joué des couogi après
qu' une variante mais
alors c'est dur de jouer contre corn
bien préparé
ouis j'en ai perdu des parties
ok en tout
cas
ou laa bien jà ce que j'ai trop de
parties dans la base et que dans les
compétitions où les gens se préparent
c'était vraiment trop dur quoi on part
vraiment avec un trop gros désavantage
là par exemple anainina elle l'a joué
mais parce qu'elle l'a pas dit à son
adversaire avant je vais jouer une
filidor sinon ça aura peut-être pas été
la même et puis même là c'est pas
forcément
lu sen donc pendant queil cherchais je
montrais cette variante juste les blanc
se développe cavalier G6 on se dit ben
il y a une pression là-dessus mais en
fait c'est une fausse pression parce que
tour D1 on peut pas prendre il y a le
typique foup F7 suivi de dame F3 échec
regagne la tour abandon oui ça donc
c'est ouais c'est un moyen direct de
protéger le P 4 donc on peut je jouer F3
et demander au noirs quels sont leurs
idée comment
poursuivre cette partie avec ce
désavantage d'espace quand même nous
notre prochain coup c'est tour desant
peut-être F4 quand on sera prête
peut-être un petit rchein d'abord on
sait jamais
c'est c'est dur on on retourne on fait 1
2 3 4 maintenant
ou tu veux faire quoi allez carrément
moi je te suis on fait on fait la ha
quoi on on va on vient
euh donc Sophie Tourp G2 a été joué a
priori ah et c'est tout bon bah du coup
ça va aller vite ok
ouais je vais même pas la mettre sur le
petitch de jouet mais son adversaire
n'a est toujours en train de réfléchir
benah ouais c'est grosse réflexion ici
parce
que cette finale elle est vraiment pas
pas agréable pour les blancs comme on
l'a dit grâce au fou grâce à la 7e
rangée grâce au pion h potentiellement
passé c'est vraiment un net avantage
noir un alors
Mitra est-ce que elle se dépatouille
avec sa dame des TR pas très bien placée
non il a pas eu trop de coup il a eu
juste sur
Rock al le cou Mitra en train de
réfléchir ouis petit coup d'œil à popo
et puis après on ira peut-être jeter un
œil chez les garçons
ouis
alors B ça réfléchit c'est le tout le
monde réfléchit ouais tout le monde
réfléchit donc ass 6 jouer alors
j'espère c'est pas un problème de de
connexion enfin de de retransmission
plutôt
mais non a priori tout le monde
réfléchit
ok faut dire que c'est des positions
assez
critiques donc chez les joueurs qui ne
jouent plus pour le podium mais quand
même pour les places d'honneur on a dit
Etienne bakro a fait nul avec les pièces
blanches
rapidement marquant lui il a les Noirs
le jeune
Corse champion du monde junior champion
du monde junior a seulement 16
ans tu sais qui est le plus jeune
champion du monde junior lui c'est le
deuxème plus jeune champion du monde
junior de histoire est-ce que tu sais
est-ce que le CH le avait été champion
du monde je crois à 16 ans aussi à 15
ans ais même ouais 15 ans J le les deux
plus jeunes c'est les deux les deux
Français ouais c'est bien d'avoir ce
genre de 15 15 an 16 ans ouais mais
c'est fou d'ailleurs à 16 ans on ne pas
être le plus jeune de l'histoire quoi
parce que c'est quand même champion du
monde junior c'est moins de 20 ans alors
certains ont dit oui aujourd'hui c'est
moins prestigieux qu'avant parce que les
meilleurs jeunes à 20 ans ils font les
tournois bah c'est c'est l'élite c'est
Alireza c'est amdou satf
et c'est c'est pas totalement faux mais
tout de même c'est c'est le championnat
du monde des moins de 20 ans ça reste
prestigieux et du coup il y a quand même
de très fort grand maître et de le
remporter à 16 ans seulement c'est
hallucinant après la victoire de de l'
tier ça montre aussi à quel point il est
extraordinaire il était 4 ans plus jeune
que des joueurs comme evvanchou comme
Galf qui était là qui était là-bas et
qui ont terminé derrière
lui il y avait nan ouais il y avait nan
pas avec l'tier avec avec
[Rires]
marquant alors donc ce marquant on
s'était séparé par là prise prise il ces
petits échanges ok donc on a déjà parlé
dans des structures similaires de ce5
quand le C en F6 ça fait une énorme
différence c'est que là le CAL D7 n'a
pas accè à la case D5 qui affaiibli
certes mais les pièces noires ont du mal
à y
aller sinon peut-être qu'un jour
cavalier4 j'aime pas trop jouer et G6 et
E6 ça fait B durablement les cases pour
l'instant le fou défend ses cases mais
c'est vra que le fou il si le pon reste
en le 5 il sera un peu passif il aura du
mal à gigoter parce que il y a ses
cas bon cela dit est-ce que il y a a pas
forcément le feu au
lac qu'est-ce qui se passe si je joue
ça pas garder ta pression sur le P D4 et
sur la colonne D ouais
peut-être j'ai envie de me déclouer
quand même j'ai le droit ou pas non
Caval 4 c'est pas simple he si je me
décloue de là j'aime pas j'aime pas
cavali
4 il av 4 qui prend euh ah le 5 je
pense ça c'est quoi c'est le
ploile et oui
ah oui mais j'ai oublié tu me l'as pas
rappelé aujourd'hui tu me l'as appris
hier mais il faut faire des rappels
après sinon j'oubl tu viens de me dire
que tu veux te déclouer je pensais que
c'était à
qui il
a qui nous dit pourquoi pas cavalier B8
qui nous propose cavalier B8 au lieu de
dame E7 cavalier B8 c'est un
coup et qu'est-ce qui se passe si on
prend
C5 ce qu'il faut regarder en
premier une variante Mar c'est ça pour
attaquer là-dessus mais il y a ça là je
sais pas ce que c'est mais c'est quoi
attaque à la
découverte ouais attaque la découverte
tous les coups on vous apprend tous les
coups
ou donc prise en
C5 problème parce qu'on a pas envie
structurellement reprendre comme ça
c'est vraiment pas envie maintenant les
blancs vont se
déclouer jouer le cavalier en C4 voir
en4 quand même
et peut-être même alors j'ai beaucoup de
mal à proposer de bouger le pion G et le
pion F mais vu qu'il y a plus le le fou
ici ça peut être utile hein F4 un jour
pour vraiment solidifier le pion E5 et
du coup en murer le fou
F8 ça peut être utile
ouais une préférence pour position
blanche quand même he
ouais préférence confirmée
par un ami dans le dans le chat dont je
vais pas lire le le pseudo en fait
j'étais en train de le lire et puis je
suis h
non non non euh on va pas le lire ce
pseudo on va plutôt voir notre te fress
qui allait oh non oh god ah non c'est
moi ça
va ça va c'est moi qui joue aux dames à
mes he perdu non je rigole non c'est pas
vu sur sur le stream ah je crois que ça
s'est vu
auss ah si ça s vu il y a un petit
décalage
oups
euh donc on est
ici on s'était quitté par
là on av expliqué sur vous pr si si on
prenez de la
tour il a manœuvré il protège quand même
bien son pion des tro qui peut être en
prise à tout moment après dépenser tr il
fallait le
protéger bon c'est une italienne qui
ressemble à une italienne hein c'est il
y a
pas à quel moment qui va craquer parce
que cette position quand même une
particularité c'est que il y a encore
les 32 unités tous les pions toutes les
pièces sur les chquis on est déjà au 16e
coup c'est pas tous les jours donc qui
va initier le premier échange qui va
craquer en premier est-ce que c'est des
Noirs qui vont prendre en C3 en B3
est-ce que c'est les blancs il vont
prendre le
6 pas
clair c'est que maintenant que toutes
les pièces sont plutôt bien placées il
va falloir
oui il va falloir soit pousser des pions
soit échanger des pièces on peut plus
trop là c'était toute une phase d' des
pièces à partir d'ici on va dire dernier
coup de
pion c'était du jeu de manœuvre chaque
coup améliore
légèrement la position d'une pièce mais
maintenant les pièces noires on l' au
maximum les pièces blanches on l' au
maximum donc chaque coup de
pièce détriorera la
position et du coup il faut soit faire
une capture soit trouver une percée de
pion donc peut-être il y a un coup c'est
de jouer A5 menace A4
à3 parce que pour l'instant à chaque
fois qu'on reprend C TR les Blancs ont B
prend C3 et du coup on a échangé un pion
central contre un pion B et les Blancs
ont un bon contrôle de toutes les cases
importantes mais si les noirs peuvent
échanger leur pion a contre le pion B
ensuite faire des prend C3 c'est pas
tout la même si par exemple on imagine
je sais pas un
coup juste pour montrer ça on pourrait
prendre le 6 peut-être mais pousser de à
3 attention là c'est vraiment la
catastrophe
catastrophe un truc comme
ça où on se retrouve avec la structure
qu'on voulait éviter le pion D3 toujours
arrièé mais il y a plus le pion en C3 à
côté pour contrôler les cases qui sont
vraiment faibles c'est sur lesqueles les
pièces noires vont pouvoir s'installer
donc à 5 il y a cette menace
concrète Laurent doit adorer ce genre de
position
je sais
pas j'aimerais bien voir sa tête quand
même là cette c'est vraiment le genre de
position si tu sont pas à l'aise tu as
envie de tuas envie de tout Gumble en
fait hein tu as juste envie
deécire quelque chose c'est hyper dur
c'est hyper dur
si c'est pas ton caractère c'est hyper
difficile après tu disais que Ben que
Laurent est joué depuis h bah depuis
toujours les Espagnols ce genre de
position donc d'une certaine façon il
doit aimer il doit se sentir il doit
avoir
l'habitude
donc et puis son adversaire est plutôt
jeune je crois Adam kzak je crois qu'
pied je suis pas
sûre c'est ton meilleur ami d'accord ok
ben voilà je crois que c'est mon
coéquipier de club ex je vais
regarder ex en Provence et ben peut-être
alors dans l' reillette on souffe que la
Bulgarie serait en train de perdre
eu contre la la geéorgie bah ce qui
serait plutôt une bonne nouvelle si si
après avoir checké ton ton coéquipier tu
peux tu peux nous confirmer infirmer ça
aussi
ouais donc c'est bien mon coéquipier
ok donc oui il est il est jeune il est
cool il est jeune et il est cool et
sinon oui c'est bien ça ce qu'on disait
c'est sur l'chiquet numéro 4 du match
Georgie euh Bulgarie Bulgarie entre
Melia Salomé et bellos lava crasteva
avec les Noirs les Blancs ont un
avantage ils ont donc
doncavantage positionnel avec des pièces
beaucoup plus actives euh une attaque
sur le
roi bon ça va être dur les noirs doivent
tenir bon comme on a dit comme on a
répété plusieurs fois hier ben être
mieux avoir un avantage ça veut pas dire
être gagnant encore faut-il gagner sa
partie mais euh ouais la Georgie a pris
une petite
option ok
alors c'est qui est une très bonne
nouvelle rappelons-le si on gagne notre
match si si les les joueuses gagnent
leur match euh pour l'instant je mets
Jules Moussard avec les
Noirs
donc on est ici on c quité il y a peu de
coup on là il a joué du
H5 pas certaine de comprendre le
pourquoi de ce coup mais très bien
H3 puis H4 c'estes concepts aussi ça
c'est des échecs de de 2600
voilà que pensez de cette position avec
ces pion pendant bon il y a une remarque
quand même qu'on peut faire ça je peux
le faire à mon niveau c'est que les
couts un peu étranges de repli de Jul
peut-être dit mais le en E5 pourquoi tu
le mets en D7 le fou en G7 pourquoi tu
le mets en F8 c'est pour contrôler cette
case très importante on veut éviter un
cavalier C5 qui nous aurait fixé et C
ces pions là qui sait peut-être un jour
les avancer mais avant tout empêcher le
cavalier de venir en
C5 il y a aussi une idée je pense
derrière fou F8 en plus du contrôle de
la CE C5 c'est pourquoi pas proposer
échang des dames en en B4 ah wou tu
diras ce que tu en penses peut-être
vouloir jouer dame B4 et le fait d'avoir
déjà le F F on a ce contrôle de de la
case C5 comme tu viens de de le dire
donc ouais c'est du High
concept du 26 concept ouais chess
concept peut-être peut-être parce que
aussi il y a un problème en fait concret
sur le pion 2 c'est-à-dire un coup là à
la à la Rubinstein je chercheris le nom
ça serait F 3 pour renforcer à nouveau
le cont ôle de de la case et un jour s'y
installer mais là ton dame B4 TR très
bon parce que très concrètement ici ça
attaque la tour et sur tour D1 bah on
menace plus les coups de fou C5 ou quoi
parce que il y a un problème
sur sur le le
pion2 et est-ce qu'on peut envisager un
coup par exemple comme je pense pas non
j'allais dire tout reprend 3 dans cette
position mais après on a un problème sur
la tour C parfois non mais ouais ça
March pas ouais c'est c'est sacrifice
voilà c'est plus alekin que rinstein
mais mais ouais alors on nous dit il y a
des médailles par chiquier normalement
oui au moins une d je ne sais pas mais
au moins une ça c'est c'est le
standard après c'est pas c'est pas les
médailles qu'on veut mais on a a priori
paulingicha et Mitra et pour qu' doivent
jouer pour une médaille en cas de
victoire c'est un peu près
certain mais mais ce qu'on veut c'est la
la victoire c'est la médaille d'or par
équipe
quoi c'est la médaille d'or par
équipe alors on a vu Jul du coup by on
sait il a fait ma chulle rapide on a vu
nos trois joueurs encore en LCE on
retourne chez Demé
oui
ou évidemment tu nous tiens au courant
s'il y a des nouveaux résultats dans les
autres
matchs de première
table
dis-moi mais tuavais commencé une phrase
non
non dismoi moi non non je te disais il y
a pas de souci je te tiendrai au courant
s'il y a du nouveau sur sur les autres
échiquers c'est que on est un peu dans
on est dans laattente et position ouais
on est dans
laattente Bou milieu de jeu manœuvre
entre on approche petit à petit du not
mais il reste encore pas mal de coup à
jouer donc c'est non mais on va faire un
petit tour Pée la tension une petite
pause et on va revenir ça sera ça sera
vraiment excitant mais là c'est très
tendu he là aussi il y a eu juste un
pion
échangé du coup de paraî d'autres F4 on
l'avait proposé on avait aussi parlé de
fou 3 tout de suite D7 cavalier G6
envisager
euh avec l'idée F5 le cavalier revient
mais dame F3 le cavalier est finalement
passé par C5 moi c'était plutôt ce que
je voulais faire par là en fait un jouer
fou F8 et qu'av les C5 donc peut-être
qu'elle voulait provoquer F4 pour pas
qu' a F3 mais bon F3 et H3 fin c'est pas
F perte de tempo hein au final elle a
perdu de
de5 qui C5 trè blanc alors que dans la
ouais avec F F8 jouer initialement ben
si on joue F4 dame F3 là ça aurait été
trè au noir
ouais ouais alors juste moi je suis
d'accord évidemment mais les blancs
n'auraient pas jouer F4 c'est un truc
qui est pas forcément si simple à
comprendre quand on regarde même
là un truc comme F4 ici on se dit mais
F4 c'est c'est intéressant en fait c'est
c'est mauvais est-ce qui pas évident
parce que prise prise on se dit mais
attends j'ai j'ai joué quatre coups de
développement les noir que deux sur C C6
je peux jeouer fou B5 ou quoi et j'ai
ces pions qui sont forts
ou fort ils sont faibles aussi le pion4
il peut plus jamais être protégé par un
pion il est sur une colonne ouverte et
un cavalier peut venir un jour en C5
donc F4 est pas bon c'est pas joué ici
et là ça fait un peu penser à ça certes
elle a perdu de tempi mais je pense en
connaissance de cause pour que le pion 4
puisse plus jamais être protégé par un
pion cela dit et je suis entièrement
d'accord avec toi c'est quand même
optimiste comme comme concept parce que
les Blancs ont un juste bon
développement facile et
puis ça peut être un peu ça peut devenir
cher ça mais par exemple on peut pas
jouer fou 3 voilà non pas immédiatement
après bon le fou peut-être est bien
placé en C1 juste pour rebondir pour sur
ce que tu disais juste avant sur le fait
de l'exemple que tu donnais avec F4 en
début d'ouverture mais en fait c'est un
peu le concept de pas mal d'ouverture de
défense où les Noirs disent au blanc
vas-y occupe le centre je voilà il y a
les ouvertures un peu habituelles ou
avec E4 E5 ou ou D4 D5 on met
immédiatement un P au centre donc on
occupe physiquement immédiatement le
centre et à toutes les autres ouvertures
toutes les autres défenses où en fait on
attaque le centre par les côtés ou on
laisse les blancs s'installer pour au
centre pour dans un second temps
l'attaque qui avec les pièces avec les
pions et on dit le challenge c'est de
dire au blanc ben écoute tu as pris de
la place maintenant va falloir que tu
montres que tu arrives bien à occuper à
bien défendre toute cette place toute
cet espace ton centre ouais ouais ouais
c'est mais c'est un concept assez assez
moderne hein de de contrôler le centre
mais pas de l'occuper voilà ex par
exemple laquine un exemple assez assez
parlant de assez parlant où on laisse un
contrôle total du centre au blanc pour
dans un second temps l'attaquer lui dire
ben écoute tu as pris de la tu as de
l'espace tuoccupes le centre mais est-ce
que tu vas réussir à le protéger h
OK et ben donc pas grand chose à dire
ici on peut s'attendre à bon si on peut
pas jouer fou 3 parce que le pu est en
prise on a le droit de jouer F de c'est
pas tu as raison à le fou il est bien
mais c'est juste moi c'est cette tour
que j'aime pas j'ai envie de la mettre
en D1 quand même donc peut-être fout des
deux tour des un et puis back back to se
one c'est ça ça peut être en visage l'
ça a l'air pas mal ouais ça l' pas mal
et on voit la
puissance du X 2 dans cette position h
oui c'est d'ailleurs faut être à la fu
chaque fois les sacrifices et tout pour
l'instant ils sont très loin mais ronose
Rose le FO 2 est là parfois ça sera dame
G3 et puis tout un coup on peut pas
jouer G6 parce queil y a prise et cetera
le le fou il il est il est ici parfois
bon bref il est là ce fou il a un coup
qui a était joué roiage 2 c'est un bon
coup aussi un coup d'attente utile
eu et c'est vraiment au noir de montrer
des idées le roi il s'échappe de cette
diagonale qui est affaibli dame B6 ça
faisait parti des idées dame B6
maintenant que leur est parti c'est
quand même beaucoup moins pertinent mais
peut-être que aurait été un coup sur sur
fou justement attaque le pion il y a
peut-être des histoires sur cette
diagonale le roi est pas confortable ici
le pion B2 il est pas vraiment en prise
ouais pas pour l'instant ouais alors
juste pour montrer ouis tu pour
illustrer ouais c'est un pion empoisonné
ouais bien bien en par que sur dame à 3
il y a la puissance du ah je je voulais
jouer n'importe quoi F prend F7 etche
est découverte et on récupère la
dame h
ok ben ouais on a tu as eu raison de de
montrer cette varante mais bon le pion
un moment il va quand même falloir euh
le gérer mais donc le crois H2 a été
joué tout de suite peut-être d'ame B6
quand même mais
bon pas sûr parce que là il y a
peut-être même ah non fou 3 on peut pas
on peut toujours pas parce que là il y
aurait dame prend B2 quand même mais
peut-être F on peut jouer fou D2
peut-être fou d de ouais tout simplement
vu qu'il y a pas de
découverte attends et sur cavalier prend
à 4 juste par
curiosité ah mais on peut prendre et tu
reprends à 4 ou
protège que c'est tactique que c'est
tactique ce
jeu
ok donc 2 plutôt une bonne position
toujours l'avantage à la pendule c'est
assez cool
Sophie on était contente de son tour PR2
ah les dames sont encore sur les chqu
alors allons voir ça qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour que les Blancs arrivent à
refuser l'échange de ces
dames on était ici dame B5 laisse faire
échec FO
fite tger c'est de H
ok
c'est elle veut avoir les tours protégés
c'est vrai que c'est un peu dommage de
plus pouvoir mettre quelqu'un d'autre ni
la dame ni de l'autre tour en ces deux
mais euh elle avait sûrement peur de
problèm sur la 8e
rangée bon si on fait le bilan cette
position
ouais c'est un peu mou du
genou mais bon c'est un coup mais si on
fait cette position un P de plus pour
les blancs mais un roi beaucoup plus
faible durablement faible le roi noir
une fois qu'on aura joué un cou comm
h6 il aura plus trop de souci enfin je
touche du bois mais
euh mais ça
va H4 a été joué
ok en fait oui le pion le pion des
blancs en plus il c'est le pion a ou le
pion B on va dire mais le problème c'est
que c'est hyper compliqué de d'avancer
la majorité des pions devant le roi
blanc parce que là on les blancs se
mettraient dans des difficultés dans des
dans des réseaux de math les pions H4 4
F3 sont très très faibles donc si les
Noirs arrivent à aller manger un des
deux pions c'est beaucoup plus simple de
pousser par exemple le pion h pour aller
à dame que pousser le pion a ou le pion
B des blancs donc un de moins mais les
Noirs ont de fortes compensation et
s'ils arrivent à manger un des de pant
pourquoi pas espérer plus je pense ouais
puis ce qu'on veut non c'est pas là
c'est avec les damesqu on veut pas juste
pousser les pions ce qu'on veut c'est
peut-être manger les pions adverses mais
aussi si c'est le roi et not sur H5 dès
que la tour quitte la colonne E on a cet
échec en E6 qui a qui peut être assez
sympa
donc donc une bonne position très
compliquée de RO opposé typique avec le
déquilibre matériel le cavalier A4 il
est pas foligion non plus il a du mal à
revenir en jeu à mett
ça B6 il a un gros tour prend B2 non
oui avec un mat
10 je sais pas si c'est en
PR3 d B2 mat j'ai toujours pas vu le mat
le fou
[Musique]
oui on va faire transiter ou dame B3 et
tour C2 ah
et euh on a une tour de moins mais ça va
ouais on menace dame B2 et dame à de mat
donc ça va être compliqué de parer voir
trois menaces oui allez good luck euh
ok donc pas du tout une mauvaise
position pour Sophie la pendule c'est
totalement
équilibrée donc ça nous va il faut
j'arrête de faire ça
Mitra on nimait pas trop son histoire de
d des3 où est-ce que ça en
est on s qué
ici4 B6 la revient 2 C
G4 qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
H3 un
sacrifice
ça se calcule donc elle vaer prend
F2
F5 ah
ouais
peut-être tu d'autres
coup non F5 très bien je regardé
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait faire avec les
blancs est-ce que je peux prendre un F5
première question
ou est-ce que c'est beaucoup trop risqué
tu peux c'est un coup c'est d'autant
plus un coup que je peux pas reprendre
de la tour ilame
point6 vous dire faut prendre2 forcé
intermédiaire et
ça c'est marrant cette position parce
que oui
vas-y j'allais dire j'imagine que le
seul souci des blancs ben c'est d'avoir
toujours le roi au centre de Les
chiquier ouais mais s'ils arrivent à ben
oui comme tu le montres s'ils arrivent à
développer leurdam et à assurer une
position un peu safe au roi ben c'est
deux pièces contre une tour donc ça veut
dire que ça peut être du kitouou j'ai
l'impression
ouais
ouais ouais je suis d'accord avec toi là
le matériel c'est faut cavalier cont
tour et pion globalement c'est égal mais
si les pièces sont bien coordonnées ça
favorise F les cavalier pour l'instant
les pièces blanches sont passive le roi
est toujours dans des courants d'air ça
peut être désagréable un truc comme ça
G5 R 4 F F4 ou
quoi mais mais c'est chaud donc c G4
après bon H3 c'était vraiment juste pour
voir quelle était l'idée c'est pas forcé
on a le droit de se développer peut-être
est-ce qu'on a vraiment le
droit pas Simp F de 2 il y a prise F3
c'est en prise F F4 est-ce qu'on va pas
se prendre dans le
h al si tu joues au5 tu as plus F5 et la
pression sur euh et là on revient F2
ouais tu reviens tu Mees peut-être après
jouer à3 fou
G5 c'est modern chess ouais ouais c'est
dur à jouer D5 maintenant tu c D5 qui
peut devenir hyper fort c'est vrai c'est
vrai pousser le 5 si si c'est vraiment
très fort c'est très très fort de jouer
alors qu'on est mal développé de jouer
fou F4 F5 fou à la maison à toi c'est
que c'est vraiment très très
fa alors on nous dit de voir popo allons
voir popo ça bouge de partout popo ouais
notre buteuse tout double notre butuse
ça casse est-ce qu' va
marquer au meilleur Momente ça
casseud sur le 4è hyper hyper chaud
alors on sé qué par là
H3
H5 pas F4 bien E5
H4
oh
c'estf ouais alors je pense que après H5
c'est elle a prévu en fait h l'ORD naime
pas mais les joueus ont prévu en
calculer ça après F4 j'imagine qu' F4
elle a pas joué si elle a joué très vite
oh si jou très vite donc il y a il y a
une partie
de est-ce que quelqu'un qui a des
connaissances dans le chat peut me dire
il y a une partie de carpof où il a joué
un système hisson où il a justement
sacrifié avec H4 contre mal pas sûr du
tout mais c'est on a déjà vu ça le
euh le roi qui est quand même sur la
même diagonale que la dame mais bon si
on fait le bilan qu'est-ce que ça donne
on va reprendre non pas trop le choix on
a une pièce de moins contre seulement
deux pions
mais les pièces blanches sont des
coordonnées il y a cavalier pr F4 qui
est dans l'air et tous les pions blancs
sont
faibles après c'est quand même une
pièce c'est quand même une
pièce une pièce mais si on arrive à
récupérer un pion puis un pion puis un
pion là ça fait quoi ça fait 1 2 3 4 5 6
ça fait deux pions déjà pour la pièce et
2 et
demiis même ces pions ils sont fa même
en final c'est c'est l'avantage mais wou
quel concept c'est c'est prendre ses
responsabilités que de jouer H5 ici
parce que alors peut-être qu'elle avait
peur de F4 5 quand même dans tous les
cas mais je suis pas sûr que
c'était si àrain que ça mais donc elle a
joué H5 après là quand même non même pas
une si grande réflexion si quand même 9
minutes donc elle a bien réfléchi pour
jouer
H5 et ensuite c'est Paine oui dis-moi
Pauline c'est le genre de c'est la
joueuse qui va va rester sur les
chiquers à se tenir la tête et à
réfléchir c'estàdire que ah oui
le quand son adversaire a réfléchi 15 ou
20 minutes pauline est déjà en train de
réfléchir est en train de réfléchir sur
elle est pas en train de de se balader
en sifflotant et en prenant un café elle
est en train de réfléchir elle est
complètement focus sur sa position donc
je vois qu'au 19e coup ben son
adversaire a pris du temps pour
réfléchir donc je pense que Pauline
avait déjà était déjà en train
d'envisager ce genre de de oui oui oui
là moi je peux je peux vous dire elle
avec ses boules quiessent elle a pas
bougé de les chic
elle fait limite peur quand tu la
regardes là mais c'est c'est c'est toi
notre ami là parce que tu fais un peu
peur quand même même à nous mais non non
allez on ne peut plus focus bah de toute
façon tu peux pas marquer autant de
points
alors pas envie de la poisser mais tu
peux pas marquer autant de points si tu
te donnes pas à fond c'est c'est un
excellent niveau en face tout du long la
compétition tu arrives pas à battre
autant de jouuses comme ça
d'affilé si si tu es pas à à plus de 100
%. donc on a cette position ultra
complexe F PR6 vient d'être joué bon
courage alors il y a quand même un
problème à avoir une pièce en moins
c'est que l'adversaire peut la rendre
est-ce que ça c'est pas un
coup
je sais pas si on était obligé de
prendre tout de suite il y a tour D1
aussi intermédiaire pere t prends D1 et
dam prend C4 ça paraît
euh slowdown mais tu as raison is sur le
concept de rendre ta pièce dans de
bonnes
conditions donc là pas puis on
prend non parce qu'après dame prend et
ça a l'air trop il f prend F6 et puis on
peut pas on peut même plus jouer ça
maintenant qu'on achangé la dame ou
maintenant qu'on a changé la
tour mais donc là tu nous dis
ok je comprends pas tout échange on
échange prend F6
j'imagine donc en fait j'ai deux pièces
attaqué je peux pas jouer
ça tu vas juste prendre en fait ou je
pense suffisamment de pion ça fait
beaucoup de pion et pu je partout ok ça
me va donc PR6 c'est
naturelend le
fou le cavalier attaqu le pion
aussi que c'est
compliqué que c'est comp cqu donc c'est
juste une possibilité on est ici caler
prend E6 vous voyez les
complications potentiel
waouh et puis après on n'est pas obligé
de rendre la pièce avec les
Blancs je sais
pas est-ce
que3 c'est un coup j'ai trop peur de
proposer un coup dans C l'impression que
chaque coup peêtre une ga Terri tu sais
d F3 pr F4 peut-être et malgré l'échange
de dame on est contente
ou on est contente les trop
peut-être maintenant c'est TR
pion est-ce qu'on menace de prendre en
D4 CELI de
cavalier2 un pion C4 qui va finir par
tomber
encore
ouais et ben dur dur pour les deux
joueuses avec comme tu l'as dit plus de
stress évidemment chez les Françaises
qui jouent pour quelque chose que pour
les Ukrainiennes qui a priori alors
peut-être victoire 4-0 ça ça peut leur
faire une médaille mais je c'est même
pas certain en fait qu'elle joue pour
une
[Musique]
on
retourne on peut revenir dans la partie
de à la partie de Mitra partie de
Mitra alors l'ordi n'aime pas mauvaise
nouvelle il y a pas eu de sacrifice
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu en fait on sétait
quitté ici d G4
cavalier de de ah mais là c'est des coup
d'entil
développement qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
H3
concrètement H3 admettons cavalier prend
F2 t pr F2 bah ça a l'air d'être une
meilleure version non pour les Noirs je
veux
dire qu'est-ce qu'on
regardait alors tout à l'heure on avait
le cavaliier en F3 et donc on a
regardait puis on prend F5 et là c'est
que le cavalier en D2 peut aller en B3
ça peut
être la petite différence peut-être que
c'est l'idée de de Mitra au final jouer
cavalier F3 C D2 C
B3 ég 00 d'après l'ordi allez nul on
prend on en parle plus
ouais je sais pas alors cavalier5 ça
mettra de jouer on peut jouer CAV B3
tout de suite parce que H3 c'est
peut-être un peu superflu si les Noirs
veulent sacrifier pe le faire comme ça
mais du coup on va avoir un temps de
plus ah mais en fait pas forcément parce
que ici il y a les Noirs vont pas
prendre mais jouer
F5 sur F5 peutêre qu'on peut jouer H3
maintenant ça transpose exactement dans
ce qu'on euh pas exactement non si ça
transpose non ça si enfin tu prends ici
non
oui tu as raison pardon et ça transpose
exactement dans cette finale que l'ordi
é value à
0 0 0 c'est bon il a fait un petit euh
petit
yoyo
qu est prend 6 jouer on nous dit
donc a
priori chez popo il va falloir trouver
ta série de coup on va y revenir
peut-être en attendant que Mitra se
décide H3 cavalier B3 un autre coup
peut-être qu'on veut pas voir un autre
coup quand même
mais pendant que mitras décide avant de
retourner chez popo où ça va être les
prochains coup va être vraiment cruciaux
cruciaux un petit coup chez
Sophie qui a les Noirs dans cette
sicilienne rock opposé
ultra
tendu un pion de moins mais un roi
peut-être plus en
sécurité on séit quitté là dame F6 H5
dame
F4 attaque le
cavalier ça j'ai
vu alors comment est-ce qu'on peut le
défendre ce cavalier est-ce qu'on peut
jouer cavalier B3 cette fois-ci est-ce
que ça peut être l'occasion de je B3
B3 c'est TR je ne j'ai vu qu' avait un
clou quand même ah B d'accord non je
comprenais que je
raconte calier
B on c pas cette fois-ci il y a pas il y
a pas d'autres échac
ah c'est pas de chance j'avais pas
prévu
ça je vois pas ah
siage de ouais pass de l'autre côté ah
la chance c'est incroyable j'ai te
reprend B2 dans le désert et en fait ça
B ah c'est c'est
génial parce que là-dessus il y a M mais
là-dessus il y a pas d'échec par là
c'est l'échec par
là enfin dans le désert c'était le coup
qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure sur qu' B6
et te reprend B2 mais ok donc allez joue
qui avait les B s'il te
plaît please ça serait beau après il
faut voir F prend un 3 d'amage 2 on peut
aussi ne pas le voir
ouis ouis oui ça
peut ça peut échapper est-ce qu'on peut
revenir juste chez popo viteit ouais
bien sûr popo a joué après cavalier
prend le 6 Pauline a joué dame prend C4
c'est le coup qu'on disait ça ouais
oui non l'échange en d'abord oui très
important donc on a montré cette
variante donc on ira voir aussi des Moné
mais qu est pr 6 on parle de cette idée
les blancs une pièce de plus contre de
pions et ben on rend le matériel dans de
bonnes conditions prise paire dame prend
E6 le matériel est égal maintenant mais
c'est les blancs qui ont tout le jeu
toute l'attaque FPR F6 va
suivre sur dame F7 tout à l'heure il y
avait dame pr c parce qu'on avait changé
les
tours ici c'est ça et on peut pas
échanger les dames on perd ça donc
Pauline dans les cordes mais joue les
seuls coups t prend ça on peut toujours
pas prendre cette fois-ci c'est encore
plus Simp prise fou prend F6 au prochain
sur un coup droit ou dame F7 dame prend
C8 mais dame prend
C4 quelle
tension quelle
tension faut vraiment être en mode
machine mais c'est c'est génial parce
que ce genre de partie si finalement
c'estes
résultats bah tu as les trois résultats
possibles he comme on dit et ce qui fait
que ça donne encore la possibilité ça
donne la possibilité aux françaises de
pourquoi pas de de pointer quoi faut que
les Blancs jouent très précisément que
les blanc soi précis parce qu'on peut le
voir par exemple sur un coup comme
cavalier D4 pourquoi pas cavalier D4
avec
là mais on perd la pièce on peut même
prendre et prendre en B2 ouais c'est
très bizarre qu du coup
ouais donc en fait ou dame prend s qu
forcé ouais d pr qu forcé oui mais c'est
on parlait de qu'elle des qu là et puis
on expliquait que quelle les PR4 trois
pions pour la pièce le clouage les pions
faibles et
oui oui et puis nous on voit que c'est
égal même plus 030 pour les blancs pour
être précise mais les joueuses le savent
pas avec les blanc on peut se dire mais
attends j'ai je je suis vraiment mal là
mais c'est attends c'éit je crois que
c'était du bleu son sacrifice de pièces
j'étais contente d'avoir sacrifié là
pourquoi pourquoi a pas repris c'est
c'est pas faire toi moi quand je t'ai
sacrifie tu m'as sacrifé une pièce je
l'ai prise je te sacrifie une pièce tu
la prends pas c'est pas cool
euh allez un petit cou chez
ddé un petit coup bon je pas de réponse
tu m'entends toujours n i dit oui ah
pardon j'ai t'entendu c'est moi qui
t'entends pas
il y a eu un problème dit oui oui je te
suis euh je te
suis
alors je vois un coup bleu on est ici
tout recet
ah dame 8 et le ption 4 on en parlait de
sa
faiblesse c'est c'est marrant hein je
pour illustrer fou des deux dame 8 et
aussi étrange qu'il n pas
on peut pas protéger le P
4 non donc c'est tout ce concept des
noirs on disait que ça paraissait trop
optimiste moi aussi parce que on est
influencé par la jauge mais on disait
aussi que c'était pas si bête parce que
maintenant que le pion donc c'était à
partir d'ici jeou cavaler E5 pour
inciter
F4 et faire en sorte que le pion4 puisse
plus être protégé par un pion et tour 7
dame 8 très jolie idée mais visiblement
cavalier
B3 pour échanger ce cavalier qui servait
à rien dans la défense du P 4 contre un
attaquant du coup
cavalier calier cétait pas ce qu'on
voulait mais c'est pas impossible de
voir ça
non donc en tout cas on est
ici
cavalier
refus de l'échange pour garder cette
idée et puis dès que le Calet bouge on
revient en
C5 très original comme concept t 7 d'ame
8 l' l'ORD aime bien les
blancs qu' mais il y a des idées avec no
on peut comprendre ou les blans ont cet
avantage d'espace je pense que c'est
pour ça que l'ordi préfère la position
des blancs après ben on est au 17e coup
il reste 24 minutes pour démonter 14
pour son adversaire donc pour jouer 23
coups alors à noter un point c'est que
le pion A5 est en prise enfin en prise
il est il est protégé par la dame mais
il est plus protégé par la tour
contrairement à quand on avait ça donc
là dame 8 on peut pas jouer fou de il y
a dame 8 gagne le P P centrale et donc
la partie mais si on joue cavalier B3
comme çaétait joué dans la partie
cavalier A6 fou des de maintenant sur
dame 8 est-ce que je peux pas prendre le
pion
A5 faire attention à des coups par
exemple comme cavalier B4 ou cavalier C5
pression à nouveau sur parce que je
voulais faire ça en fait mais tu jou k
prend D6 prend
de est-ce que ça va je ne sais pas
peut-être prendre là prendre là et il y
aura quand même des pions pour la
qualité mais c'est chaud il y a aussi F7
qui peut être oh là là trop compliqué
pour moi oui ça l'air non mais du coup
c'est c'est possible
he façon alors après dam ça menasse
toujours pas mais le problème c'est
qu'on n pas envie de rester avec
avec ce fou à de cavalier B3 et donc là
si on joue des4 c'est perdant à nouveau
qui C5
ok ben je sais pas c'est très original
limite ça me donne envie de rejouer la
fil deou j'espère que dem va vraiment
gagner comme ça ça fait une victoire
française et en plus ça m'vite de
rejouer cette ouverture atroce qui m'a
valu tellement de poubelles
[Musique]
h que fait-on ma chère nana
est-ce qu'on ferait pas une petite pause
pourevenir pour lesn
euh si je suis complètement d'accord
pour pour un petit break OK et ben ça me
va je vais vous mettre les quatre
parties si
j'arrive
[Musique]
et nous revoilà pour suivre la fin de
cette dernière ronde du championnat
d'Europe on rappelle l'enjeu pour la
France un podium peut-être la plus belle
démarche sur ce podium peut-être la
deuxè peut-être la 3e on est
actuellement 3e la compétition derrière
la Bulgarie et l'Azerbaïjan nous
affrontons l'Ukraine et
toutes les parties sont en train de se
jouer aucune partie n'est finie on
sétait quitté au premier
échiqu par là on avait expliqué bien
tous les enjeux de la position avec j'ai
pu le livebard pour une certaine
raison je le remets ici avec le
pion
E4 vraiment le point clé de cette
position pion 4 que veulent viser les
pièces noires le C qui pourrait revenir
en C5 si lui bougeit fou 3 cavalier
B4 petit échange les Noirs ont gagné la
paire de fou mais les Blancs ont des
pièce bien centralisée ah mais attends
c'est
pas qu'est-ce qui se passe non non non
rien j'avais peur on peut juste jouer ça
et et to bien qu'est-ce que tu as vu et
sur dame 8 on va jouer fou F2 ou un truc
comme ça et on protège
bienme non pasou B6 prend B3 et
C5 et le F peut sentir un petit peu seul
en
B6 pas l'air très
inquiok on en est là c'est bon on voit
vraiment pas d'
C
et bon elle a réussi à égaliser ce filet
là il y a peut-être une combinaison
intéressante alors je triche un tout
petit peu cavalier
prend4 il y a des thème de clouage dans
tous les sens entre ou fou D5 par
exemple faut regarder cavalier F6 je
pense il faut évaluer cette position
prise pas oui prise for
ouais prise forcée prise forcée et c'est
ça qu'il faut évaluer ouais peut-être
dame G4 échec plus précis
ouais exactement
ok moi ça me va avec les Blancs donner
un pion alors si c'est pour casser tout
ça le le pion dérange pas trop DIN ouais
et puis très très fort nonon il peut y
avoir un échange fa faut prendre B3 mais
parce que le fou des5 ok mais le
cavalier s'il arrive ici il sera pas
moins
fort il sera pas moins fort Dang ouais
c'est peut-être la fausse bonne idée
donc on est ici tur tu prend 4 brillant
mais si c'est pour se retrouver à jouer
en fait avec cert un pion de plus cert
la paire de fou mais un roi comme
ça il a le roi
dstructuré
peut-être peut-être que ça il faut
savoir se restreindre et ne pas ne pas
jouer cette
idée aussi créative et intéressante par
Estelle je sais pas tu préférais mon
leur dit mais 00 mais tu préférais les
blancs aussi ou ou pas pense qu'il
faudrait que tu tournes les fiquier pour
pouvoir avoir une idée de
ouais du potentiel de la position des
Noirs aussi
ouais peut-être une petite préférence
tempor ouais j'ai trop j'ai trop peur de
me faire maté après c'est vrai ou pas
cavad oui dis-moi pardon non non je
disais que le pion de central quoi mais
vas-y vas-y vas-y oui il est central oui
c'est vra non je voulais dire mais en
fait si on n pas qu' pr 4 est-ce qu'on a
un meilleur coup ou est-ce qu'on a un
autre coup pour les Noirs donc t Ren a
été joué donc c'est la question à
laquelle va
répondre la championne du monde 2012
Anna ou Cheina ouais commence à se
mettre en difficulté elle est en 5
minutes à pendule donc là on rentre on
rentre vraiment dans le not est-ce que
ça c'est un
coup bon j'en
a mais je pense qu' minima tu peux jouer
E5
min5 donc F prend B3 parce que si tu
joue par exemple qui D7 il y a cavalier
D2 il faut prendre B3 pr
F6 bon à nouveau tu reprend le
3 on prend C
de quel chose comme ça safice de qualité
mais ouais sacrifice de qualité ouais
alors la paire de fou et le pion en
dessin qu'on aime bien avec les Noirs
mais le roi durablement faible un petit
peu moins mais c'est super compliqué
ouais ben bon courage on comprend que
anina se met en ce qui est quand même
une bonne alors après la pendu nous
avait fait le coup une fois de nous
faire croire à une grosse réflexion à
danana shinina puis en fait pas du tout
c'était juste une histoire de délai ou
je sais pas quoi
euh allons voir alors j'ai vu à la pause
qu' tu avais un bug chez popo euh pas un
bug de chass.com un bug de la
retransmission donc retransmission ouis
European chass union alors
Mitra on en est là ouais jamais sur les
petitchiqué c'est une finale qui
s'annonce compliquée quand
même le on a l'égalité matérielle qui
est maintenue mais la paire de fou
cavalier Octopus on en revient à
l'Octopus un un des trois les tours plus
actives il y a pour l'instant on a on a
encore laqualité matérielle mais c'est
vraiment la seule chose qu'on a pour
nous un truc quand même
qui qui me rassure un un tout petit peu
c'est que je sais à quel point Mitra est
une battante et pour avoir joué pas mal
de parties cette saison juste à côté
Dina au moins plus d'une
dizaine c'est pas forcément la plus
sanguinaire quoi
elle est très forte évidemment elle le
montre très souvent mais elle manque de
elle peut manquer en tout cas de
combativité c'est c'est c'est plus la
tueuse qu'elle a pu être et parfois elle
se contente du moindre mal mais mais
objectivement la position blanche est
perdante ça c'est ça ne fait aucun doute
après on va espérer
qu'elle k se contente d' d'un moyen
d'assurer un gros avantage sans risque
sans risque sans risque et puis du coup
qu'elle perde de son avantage à jamais
vouloir prendre le moindre risque et
puis qu' un moment MRA puisse revenir
dans la partie parce que elle elle va
rien lâcher en tout
cas surtout qu'on arrive aussi dans dans
alors je répète pour chaque partie mais
on arrive vraiment dans le Z not 20
coups à jouer en 10 minutes c'est vrai
que c'est pas forcément le meilleur
moment pour décider de faire des grands
changements dans les positions dans les
structures de pion et c'est vrai que ben
comme tu dis hein si Ina décide ben de
temporiser temporiser temporiser ben
petit à petit son avantage peux lu filer
entre les doigts
ouais ouais puis c'est bon je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'on peut
jouer le fou F4 est mal placé donc j'ai
pas envie de faire5 on avait proposé
tout à l'heure mais F4 il fait pas
grand-chose en fait donc pourquoi
l'enchasser peut-être juste un coup
comme tour des V et puis c'est un coup
qu'on peut jouer à tempo aussi
d'ailleurs tour de V à toi c'est
peut-être pas le plus précis mais comme
ça je me réserve du temps pour quand ça
compte vraiment et ça change pas
fondamentalement au fait que vu la
différence d'activité entre les pièces
la position noire doit être gagnante
après il aé matériel donc l'avantage
n'est pas encore durable et
tangible euh on en vient à la
partie
qui bugit tout à l'heure est-ce que ça a
été réparé du côté de la European
European chess union du mal à parler je
pense que la partie bug toujours parce
que on va essayer de comprendre ouais ça
bug je pense ça être compliqué à
comprendre ouais ça va êre compliqué
parce que donc ça c'était bon et ici
évidemment Pauline n'a pas jou tour C 7
spoiler elle pas C7 euh
elle a pris on s'attend à ce queil y a
eu prise en
F6 prise en F6
F5 prise en6 prise en G6 je pense que
c'est ça et donc à l'inverse de la
position qui est donnée donc là c'est
très au noir et non TR au blanc ou ça
c'est la même position mais euh
l'avantage du trait peut avoir son
importance
surtout que ici tour D7 ça serait grave
mais ici on peut jouer ro G7 alors
matériellement on a que deux pions mais
lui il est un peu
faiblard ça peut faire trois et
rappelons deux choses tour fou contre
tour c'est match nul et aussi fou pion h
contre roi avec le pion h de la mauvaise
couleur ou le fou la mauvaise couleur
comme on veut c'est match nul aussi donc
peut-être non les coups qu'est-ce qu'il
y a eu fou 4
1 donc on a ça j'imagine que maintenant
c'est la bonne position alors c'est pas
du tout le bon le bon nombre de coups je
pense qu' y a de coup de plus mais
j'imagine c'est la bonne position que en
fait ilur G7 et ici fou B7 paraît assez
logique et donc c'est la position à du
live et donc par exemple avec très très
avec trop noir ouais du coup c'est bon
par exemple on peut prendre prendre
prendre et moi ça me fait un peu peur
parce que tu vois il y a quand même le
pion H qui est potentiellement enfin qui
a un pion passé quoi il reste un pion H
qui a un pion passé donc si si on
échange les tours c'est nul mais les
tours sont encore là
ouais c'est une grosse vraiment une très
grosse différence après on a encore
beaucoup de pions aussi on les a pas
tous perdus
encore et Yosa on n'est peut-être pas
forcé de laisser le pion le pion A6 euh
ouais ouais bienû sur fou B7 on peut
peut-être d'abord prendre le pion à 4 h
est-ce que c'est possible ça ah c'est
tout à fait possible c'est même sûrement
très malin
ouais ah il y a une petite tactique
écheac à la tour vient protéger le pion
on peut regretter de pas l'avoir pris
parce que
après ça ça ça peut être
difficile mais c'est chaud c'est
chaud t H4 si f là prend voilà il y a
plus qu'un
[Musique]
pion mais peut-être qu'il est fort ok
donc grosse réflexion on est ici ne
regardez pas le louper là c'est c'est
juste c'est pas Natalia jukova qui a
fait un loupé c'est les
organisateurs
c'est les organisateurs il y a le
choix alors bon prendre en G6 ah c'est
tentant mais après si on veut pefiner
aussi on peut jouer un truc comme ça
avec l'idée peut-être de jouer F4 et
parce que souvent le perdition 3 mais là
on prend des risques on a toujours pas
mangé
lui mais il y a un monde aussi où les
blancs n'arrivent jamais à capturer le p
p G3 qui peut être fort parce qu'il
soutient la tour qui peut venir
là en fait je serais terrifié avec les
deux
couleursci avec les deux je sa c'est
horrible à quel point je suis pas
combative avec les deux je Seris en mode
bon comment assurer la
nul
mais non c'est tendu c'est tendu l'ORD
égalend mais c'est i perdable avec les
deux couleurs faites-moi confiance
donnez-moi une bonne adversaire en face
et je la perd avec les Blancs je la perd
avec les Noirs la la partie
revanche non c'est c'est complexe mais
bon comme on l'a dit il y a même des
CAAC où ça se passe mal où ça finit par
tour fou contre tour ou fou pion h
contre 3 et mat
Chel
alors on repasse chez
DD oui oui oui après je sais pas trop ce
que ça donne les gars est-ce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on les a pas allez un petit
tour chez chez les garçons même si l'enu
dire qu'on les a pas oublié
moindre tout à
fait là alors si en plus il y
a.com qui
R marquan a une dame de moins a ce c'est
quoi C on y croit
non
h malheureusement je crois qu'on y
croit
et
ça c'est une histoire qui a l'air tout à
fait crédible malheureusement quand on
la regarde
euh ouais C7 c'est joli quand même ce
dame C2 et l'option est inarrêtable
on c'est le problème des final de dame
on peut pas avoir une dame bloqué si
c'était de tour on met la tour en C8 et
les blancs doivent encore bien
travailler avant de la déloger mais donc
là finale de dame la menace c'est ça ça
et puis la dame est facilement
délogeable du coup il a tenté une menace
deche perpétuel mais il y en a
pas d'ailleurs c'était même une menace
de
mat
mais mais qui malheureusement euh il
sa'est pas il a pas fait de mylick d d
gagne d
des7 il a peu le mylic donc défaite de
marquan
euh nul rappelons-le d'Étienne bac
Laurent qu'est-ce que ça donne t fress
toujours sur anglaise il y a
eu un moment cet échange don on a
beaucoup
parlé un jeu de manœuvre cavalier H4
alors après sûrement tech fress aussi
euh mais il a vu la défaite de marquant
donc il doit prendre ses responsabilités
pour essayer de gagner par que même
quand bien même il y a plus de podium en
jeu on va essayer de bien figurer et ça
nous laisse
Rouot Roulio qui a les Noirs je vais
mettre sur le petit échiqu
aussi hop
hop on c'était qu on avait parlé de ce
dam B4 tu l'avais trouvé ce ti dame B4
A5 c'était peut-être pas les coups les
plus précis ah fou C5 B alors on en
parlait de donc ce qu'il faut surtout ah
en fait ce qu'il faut éviter ça je sais
pas ce qu'il faut éviter c'est de se
faire contrôler le pion C6 et avoir la C
C5 FEM mais ici si on peut manger un
pion c'est peut-être pas si évité plus
ouais mais alors B il a eu tour B8 ici
euh quelle est l'idée surprise on gagne
une pièce c'est ça
oui ça c'est c'est une
enfilade allez put cadeau c'est cadeau
c'est l'enfilade c'est pour moi
euh donc tour B8 on a la dame attaquée
on a le pion attaqué on a le fou à
surveiller il y a pas 1000 coups dame PR
est pas possible dame a 6 et fou prend
C5 fou prend
B4 ça c'est un coup
faut prendre 4 c'est un
coup qu'est-ce que ça donne
ça ça Ress quand même à une qualité
ouais qu'est-ce qui se passe
après B on est ici je ne sais pas on
peut jouer d 7 et puis accepter de jouer
avec un P de
MO sa c'est pas
vraiment b4end b4ement
c ça
c'est le clouage le
clage4 surprise prise en
B3 il y a pas
ça ah c'est joli regarde regarde regarde
ça
wou ça c'estz
R et
là-dessus ah puzzle rush à
nouveau
wouh Nice et ben ça sert
très sympa
ouais alors bon donc Jul pas mal donc
Jul pas mal ça reste dangereux ouais
fraise mais attention Jul 2 minutes à la
pendule he intéressant ouais tu as
raison après Jul bon en blit ça va il
est pas mauvais mais bon c'est vrai que
Biss c'est den aussi c'est différent
mais bon 25 ah oui c'est vrai qu'ils ont
joué que 25 coups ouais ou là là ça va
être un grand
Zn un grand et long
Zn
ok bon donc les mecs peuvent tout à fait
gagner ce match Menz d'un point il reste
deux parties mais de parties avec des
chances on retourne chez les Mané
oui repartons chez les Françaises donc
rappelons pendant que je cherche tu tu
nous rappelles l'enjeu pour celles et
ceux qui viendrait
d'arriver alors si on reprend le
classement donc les dans la compétition
féminine la Bulgarie
est première actuellement donc avec 14
points l'Azerbaïjan 2e avec 13 points et
les Françaises 3e avec 12 points suis la
serbi ensuite une langue floppée
d'équipe à 10 points
donc il reste encore des chances pour
que les françaises soient championnes
mais ça dépend plus de ça ne dépend plus
d'elle quoi ça dépend de du résultat de
la Bulgarie du des résultats de
l'Azerbaïjan donc les Françaises si
elles veulent gagner la compétition
elles doivent absolument gagner et
ensuite il faut que les circonstances
soient favorables c'est-à-dire qu'il
faudrait que la Georgie gagne contre la
Bulgarie que la Bulgarie perde contre la
geéorgie là euh mais en fait ça l'air
assez chaud en fait match Bulgarie
geéorgie échqu numéro 1 antonetta
stéepanova face à Bena
Bella
côéagevili ça se dirige vers un point
pour la Bulgarie échqu numéro 2 match
nul ensuite 3e échiquier euh
jacquevili contre la
joueuse bulgare je connais pas trop le
nom euh pécheva l'avantage est pour la
Georgienne et sur le dernier échiquier
Mia Salomé a pris l'avantage contre la
joueuse bulgare donc pour le moment on
s'orienterait bien sûr avec du
conditionnel vers un 21 pour la Géorgie
mais bon il y a encore beaucoup de
résult pas gagné le match pour avantager
les Français alors désolé juste parce
que j'imaginais que tu voulais nous dire
le la partie de la serie mais on n dit
Mitra finito dans le chat et j'ai quand
même envie d'aller voir ce que ça veut
dire
euh si ça te va
oui si on peut oui ben c'est que l'autre
a pris le pion euh est-ce que c'est
vraiment ok c'était euh
elle est où elle est là
a Mitra un pion de moi ouais et toujours
les les
pièces la pièce noire très bien placé
ouais ah puis il y a
ça aïe aïe aïe donc ok al je remets la
position de démenté et donc c'est vrai
pour que il y ait les matchs extérieurs
enfin les matchs non Fran non français
soient important pour nous il faut
d'abord gagné ce match parce que sinon
euh il y a des casù on fini 3è quand
enfin dans même en perdant mais du coup
si si on veut finir mieux que 3e il faut
il faut gagner euh le match et donc
allons voir D il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses oui dis-moi ouais c'est qu'il ne
faut pas que alors dans le match des des
joueuses il y a la Serbie qui est
derrière avec 11 points il ne faut pas
que la Serbie gagne si la France ne
gagne pas ouais bien sûr et puis après
on peut même se faire
rattraper non non c'est tous les matchs
sont importants ouais tous les matchs
sont important tous les matchs son
importants et toutes les parties sont
importantes parce que perdre c'est grave
perdre 2 et demi 1 et demi c'est moins
grave que de perdre sur un autre score
donc il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
ici euh on avait vu plus loins cette
position tour1 il y a eu l'échange en
euh B3 dame8 on en parlait pour mettre
la pression sur le pion4 fou
F2 et F5 un coup responsable donne la
case 5 mais permet de casser la
structure et regardez ce fou F8 c'est
pas le meilleur des fou il a un
potentiel s'il a des 5 jour mais en
attendant c'est pas le meilleur des fou
et là G4 menace mat
concr donc F7 seul coup pour pouvoir
jouer sur tour G3 tour
G8 cavalier 2 se dirige vers la case
H5
tranquillement après le seul problème de
cavalier E2 c'est qu'il lâche le
contrôle de la case
des5 tu veux jouer
des5 ça se regarde puce que le pion E
est
cloué je pense que ça se
regarde ouais
ouais il y a des je sais pas le le le
côté Hine là ça me fait un peu peur ça
ça cavalier F4 t prend E4 j'imagine qu'
clou
et c'est si on avait la tour en plus en
attaque il y aurait des thèmes mais là
ça ça a l'air un peu léger donc des CIN
très bonne réaction au centre et c'est
chaud très tendu cette partie alors il y
a un petit
thème tactique Yosa bon il il faut que
tu mettes un peu du tien popo j'is
t'appeler popo ouais j'ai vu
c'est un truc comme ça je fais cavalier
H5 tour G8 et je fais dame fr
G7 bon si je l'ai vu à des kilomètres a
priori l'ancienne championne du monde
devrait pas trop se le
prendre mais pour montrer qu'il y a des
possibilités du coup mais C c'est c'est
c'est dur là c'est dur donc peut-être
cavalier F4
ici mais c'est la tour est fait défaut
hein parce que là on attaque avec nos
meilleures pièces c'est bien mais les
Noirs ont quand même toutes leurs pièces
en en défense et donc
on ça devrait pas marcher si on narrive
pas à inclure cette tour à qui est
totalement en jeu alors juste pour info
ouis sur cavalier E2 tour G8 a été
gunéou ouais voilà c'est j'ai vu aussi
donc tour G8 a été joué donc finalement
cavalier G3 F C G3 fou F8 on peut jouer
cavalier H5 surprise
fourchette de toutes les pièces noires
et en plus qui qui qui refourchette
après euh donc cavalier H5 qu'est-ce
qu'on
joue par roi H8 parce que parce que
c'est pas
mieux non ça ne Mar ça ne part pas la
menace ça ne part pas la
menace
euh
donc P pas fou G7 je vous la fais pas
adame prend fou7 évite peut-être tout
ça ouais et en fait ouais ce qui est
embêtant c'est que finalement le
cavalier en H5 qui si toutes les menaces
sont paré ben on se demande ben
qu'est-ce qu'il fait en H5 il était en
C3 où il protégeit le pion E4 où il
avait un contrôle sur la case des5 et
maintenant il est en H5 ù ben il a fait
une menace en un coup et puis c'est tout
ouais et aussi B le fou G qui était venu
c'est le seul coup pour pas se faire
mater il est il est très mauvais ici
mais donc là en7 il est moins mauvais
parce que en 4 D5 tout d'un coup la
position noire peut se libérer et donc
là c'est un peu ce qui se
passe n'a pas été joué on est ici donc
c'est un peu ce qui se passe
ou donc tu serais peut-être te on bouge
la dame ici comme ça on a un certain
contrôle sur
D5
tu mettas en F3 ou sur une autre
case H4 pour attaquer là mais ça fait un
peu justement les pièces je ce que tu
disa sur le cavalier on peut le dire
aussi pour cette
dameas la possibilité H5 aussi comme ça
la dame peut revenir
en2 mais il a D5 h ok dame F3 c'était
pour contrôler des5 c'était ça ouais et
puis ça protège la T donc enfin sur D F3
D5 je peux prendre
normalement je pense que je pense que
le que démonté va jouer cavalier H5
parce que si tu joues pas cavalier H5 ça
veut dire
que et tr derniers coup que tu as joué
ben en fait oui c'est ça ou ça ne sert à
rien donc elle va jouer cavalier H5 mais
c'est vrai qu'après faette
tu h
pas simple c'est c'est fou à quel point
là là j'ai je trouve instructive cette
variante où j'ai fait n'importe quoi là
avec les blancs mais juste pour montrer
que le F G7 qui paraissait si mauvais
ici et qui tout d'un coup se se retrouve
en D6 sur une diagonale et c'est terminé
fin de partie quoi c'est tour de passe
pass d'amélioration des
pièces c'est assez instructif
ok un un petit tour chez Sophie ça fait
longtemps qu'on l'a pas vu
oui oui oui bien sûr on voir
Sophie c'est sicilienne ultra
complexe avec un pion de moins a
priori mais
pas forcément une moins bonne
position on avait vu par
là B3 pour protéger le
cavalier
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
si on
prend pas
sûr le slipion court vite quoi c'est ça
maintenant
B4 B4 a peut-être un problème sur C
oui bon ben je sais pas en tout cas là
peut-être ramener ton le cavalier en jeu
je disais peut-être c'est le moment de
ramener le cavalier en jeu enfin après
c'est vrai que pour une foisas pas TR
qui mat par miracle ou pas
ouais oui et puis en plus c'est
désagréable parce que ici il y a ça et
ailleurs il y a ça
OK en tout cas il dame C7 de jouer après
c'est normal de garder les dames ici oui
ici aussi on garde les dames parce que
le roi blanc a priori est plus faible
dame B5 l'ordinateur n'aime
[Musique]
pas
ah non faut encore comprendre
pourquoi
j'imagine que l'ordinateur veut profiter
de la faiblesse de la
8e que
c'est c'est prise en B8 et il y a pas de
magouille pas man trop de
pièces et si tu échanges par exemple
tout reprends des8 tout reprends
des8 après d prend4 il y a juste d C5 je
pense doit doit
gagner une menace désagréable et H6 ça
n'empêche pas le mat ça le retarde à
peine
ok m 5 tours de
vite peut faire
mal il faut jouer un
coup sont les règles tour des
jouer t donc en fait on peut faut garder
le statut coup entre la dame et de la
dame B5 et de la tour B8 est-ce qu'on a
vraiment le choix H6 ouais ESS en H6
pour voir ce que ça donne ça c'est pas
ça c'est pas la la bonne idée avec Dame
G7 qui va arriver ou en plus de mat en
ah oua ça c'est pas la bonne idée donc
on va plutôt faire la case de fuite là
où on peut vraiment fuir euh c'est le
petit conseil du
jour mais mais c'est grave d'avoir
laissé les blanc pénétr sur la ah ça se
profile mal
malun coup ça se profite mat
ouaissis
ouais
Mitra ça va pas forcément nous consoler
la partie de
Mitra de MO il manque du
monde il manque du monde à
l'appel
ouais
ouais ça c'est normalement c'est trop
gagnant pour que une maître
internationale ne gagne pas aïe aïe
aïe ça tout gagne la finale de fou la
finale de tour on peut garder les pièces
et puis une fois qu'on aura centralisé
le rois pousser non là oui ou oui
normalement il faut pas un miracle il
faut plusieurs miracles pour ne pas
perdre cette partie Pauline est-ce que
l'échiquier est euh
remis est-ce que non
raté est-ce que les chiier est remis
sous réserve que c'est la bonne
position l'ordinateur aime pas du tout
la position de Pauline est-ce qu'on peut
voir les coups par curiosité ouais pour
essayer de comprendre si c'est parce que
donc on rappelle il y a eu un bug donc
on pense que c'est peut-être la bonne
position est-ce que les coups sont
crédibles ah c'est
c'est possible qu'elle a raté genre
l'idée fou C6 fou E8 et tout et que c
elle a pas de spion
r G7
ok ça a l'air dangereux là maintenant
pour les Noirs HM c'est l' hyper
dangereux ro qui s'approche ouais le roi
qui peut même essayer d'utiliser les
pions noirs comme comme parapluie je
sais pas si le concept du parapluie
c'est on utilise des pièces pion
adverses pour nous protéger contre les
échecs bon là j'y arrive pas j'arrive
pas à parapluter mais B je fa jouer un
coup
idot
ouais bon ici il y a deux mais je fais
jouer un coup idiot et tout d'un coup on
est assez contente d'avoir ce pion 15
qui évite les les échecs et
cetera mais
bon on en est là alors
l'ordi a l'air de confirmer le gain
blanc théorique en
pratique
pas encore
facile parce que on va pas laisser
pénétrer le roi comme ça un moment qui
donné les pion si les tour sch c'est nul
tout de
suite
si c'est le fou de la mauvaise
couleur on c finale
ro que je
mon blanche contre c'est
nul
mais avec les tours sur les chiquier ça
gagne on peut pas faire juste forteresse
ro H8 tour sur la 8e ça finit toujours
par gagner pour les blanc ça peut
demander un peu de technique mais ça
gagne
ok ch je suis en train de regarder
toutes les v d'ensemble sur toutes les
parties h euh quand tu regardes juste
les jaoges toutes les jauges préfèrent
les parties des des ukrainiennes tous
les échiquiers et même à l'instant
Mitra vient de perdre sa
partie donc ça paraît hyper compliqué
pour les Françaises tout d'un
coup donc 1-0 pour l'Ukraine
ouais Mitra qui avait si bien commencé 5
sur 5 on fire la championne de France a
eu un coup d'arrêt alors évidemment sur
de tournois elle gagne quand même plein
de points c'est quand même un très bon
résultat euh ce 5 et5i sur 8 du coup
mais c'est toujours frustrant aussi si
tu fais 0,5 sur sur 3 et qu'ensuite tu
fais 5/ 5 c'est c'est génial quand tu
commences par 5/ 5 et que tu finis par
05/ 3
euh le score est bien bien plus amère
surtout si c'est une défaite importante
et donc comme on le disait
euh perdre c'est grave déjà parce que
ben ça il y a si on perd il y a plus que
la médaille de bronze qui sera
accessible mais perd sur un gros score
c'est encore plus grave parce que là la
médaille de bronze nous échapperait à
coup sûr donc chaque partie
compte chaque partie compte et euh après
on risque de connaître le résultat final
que à la fin de toutes les parties de
tous les match mais euh en tout
cas je sais pas comment marche le
départeur mais alors juste je vois le
TB2 il est à
176 pour les Françaises et toutes les
autres équipes la meilleure équipe che
les équipes qui sont à 10 points et 11
points il est à
147,5 me dit que le gap est peut-être
énorme non je sais pas trop comment
c'est calculé en fait
mais mais enfin c'est tu mettre un peu
de suspense c'est ça ah non non non non
non non je pense qu'il y a je pense que
per 4-0 c'est très très grave quand bien
même la Serbie perd son match si la
France perd 4-0 c'est très très grave
après peut-être je me trompe mais s'il y
a des des arbitres dans dans le chat
venez nous dire mais je crois vraiment
que perdre de ennemi ou si la Serbie
perd ça peut quasiment nous garantir une
médaille si on si on commence parce que
il y a beaucoup d'équipes qui peuvent
être execo avec nous en cas de défaite
et du coup dans l'eau il y en a qui vont
faire des gros scores donc entre faire
un très petit score et les autres qui
font des gros scores peut se faire
doubler je
pense
euh pens qu'elles peuvent prendre 20
points d'un coup les
équipes voir 30 points d'un coup je sais
pas c'était ce que ce que me disait un
peu dans un un
groupe
euh dans un groupe Andrea et et mail
choisi Andrea navrotes et ma choisi mais
je sais pas est-ce qu'elles sont
vraiment au fait ou est-ce que c'est du
bluff aussi de leur part je je sais pas
en tout cas on en est là
euh bon peut-être que le 40e est atteint
ici allons voir peut-être
Démé qui était encore assez loin de
son0e si je ne
m'abuse
et partiè RAM oh là là
ouais démonté c'est le 37e coup donc il
reste encore trois coups à jouer
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avant
d'attendre le
40e on c'était quitté par là
elle a joué le cavalier H5 don parler le
pion vient des5
et ce fou qui se replace ce fou qui est
ça TC TC TC peut-être là
ensuite et finalement qui devient
monstrueux hein ce fou ah bah ouais
ouais il est magnifique c'est et on voit
toutes les faiblesses du roi du roi
blanc
qui tout d'un coup clignote on voit les
cas noir c'est
ouais et voilà faut jouer
immédiatement
ah c'est horrible ce qui se
passe c'est horrible ce qui se
passe on aimerait bien pouvoir mettre le
cavalier en D3 mais le problème c'est
qu'une fois que le cavalier D3 saute ben
on a toutes les cases noires qui sont HM
qui sont accessibles ouais juste pour
montrer la joueuse ukrainienne
ouais là il va y avoir de la tactique
même tu reprends F5 ça l' ah non tu
reprends F5 non non c'est sur Chac même
non mais en fait ce qui est horrible
c'est que même passer son tour ça se
trouve est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie de
de prendre ce cette tour et le fou qui
qui qui faisait pitié ici il m' disait
qu'il avait du potentiel ben je pensais
pas qu'il en avait autant je pensait pas
qu'il en avait autant ah là là alors on
nous dit sachant qu'une partie gagnée
correspond 3,76 points de départage par
4 et qu'on met ça au carré ah oui
d'accord c'est n'importe quoi je bien
fait de j'ai bien fait de commencer à
dire Arnac reox alors happy stream nous
dit de ce que j'ai lu c'est le score du
match fois TB1 de l'adversaire donc je
comprends pas ce que ça veut
dire uniquement pour et les ça ne Cait
pas exactement
ok
ok toujours pas
compris alors du coup bon vu que vu que
le match est clairement en train de mal
se passer on est maintenant pour la
Bulgarie et pour les aléries on change
radicalement de cand si si si on fait le
J de la
victoire de la médaille
d'or autant que leurs adversaires ne
puissent pas nous
rattraper on me dit ex on me dit que
alors c'est très Shadow Frey 2 tout ça
mais on souhaite la la défaite des
autres on me dit que ma a gaffé donc ça
serait pas mal c'était la la jouuse
Georgienne qui était gagnante si si elle
a vraiment gaâffé c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle maintenant on veut que les
bulcar gagn on veut que les a
gagne qu'il enfin qu'elles assurent euh
les deux premières place et que la trème
bah du coup il y ait moins d'équipe qui
puisse nous la nous la
ravir c'est c'est très bizarre parce que
je vois que Mia a
gagné ah n'imp.com il est écrit que Mia
a gagné donc peut-être c'était des
analyses je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
peut-être att tomber
autant
ah F dernier
coup non mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
ah non mais c'est encore ça totalement
bugé fou ga abandon tu sais c'est
peut-être du bluff mais ça serait
dommage d'abandonner alors que fou est
en prise on peut cri au
Scand vous êtes sûr que vous avez pas
vendu le match parce que il y a un fou
qui en prise quand
même dire non non non non du tout non
mais c'est certainement une erreur de
retransmission c'est possible que la
joueuse don après juste cavalier C7 oui
oui on a le drit en fait ça marche mais
non peut-être qu' juste tomber autant
non
le mais après c'est bizarre pourquoi on
abandonne ici
aussi sit mal dans sa peau non mais ça
certainement que le cavalier n'est pas
en C7 le cavalier ne doit pas être en C7
elle a dû jouer fou 8 sans cavalier en
C7 j'imagine que son adversaire d jouer
un
autre je ou bet ou j'en sais rien mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que
ça
bon
h
mystère un
AVC Sophie a perdu sa tour hein
what
gence ah l'horreur
une tour en un tu penses ouais ouais
elle a pas senti le danger sur la
8è et après dame C5
ouais
bon dommage ah bah c'est plus que
dommage parce
que
ouais je sais pas est-ce qu'on peut
quand même fin mais il faut absolument
marquer en fait des points donc là ok le
match va être perdu mais 4-0 comme on
disait c'est pas du
tout horrible ce match qui paraissait
tout à fait gagnable encore peu
maintenant on se demande si on va pas
prendre 40 ce
qui difficile d'imaginer un pire
scénario
euh donc juste sur le match si on
regarde les autres matchs tu disais les
matchs clés si on regarde le match
Bulgarie geéorgie
h donc pour le moment il y a 11 avec une
dernière partie où la Georgienne et un
peu mieux et mieux donc avantage
Georgie le match Azerbaïdjan Serbie
euh on est possiblement
je crois que ça risque de tirer vers une
victoire de l'Azerbaïjan donc bonne
nouvelle donc possiblement Azerbaïdjan
champion d'Europe en cas de défaite de
la Bulgarie et victoire de
l'Azerbaïjan c'est
ça
ouais azerbjan pe champion
d'Europe donc ça dire que la Géorgie
aurait
gagné gagnerait
conditionnel gagnerait donc la Serbie ne
prendrait pas de point donc ça fait nos
affaires alors aè flopper d'équipes
dans l'au l'Allemagne ou ce genre
d'équipe la Georgie qui gagnerait donc
elle serait à 12 points comme la France
143 de départage
là ça me fait mal à la
tête ça fait mal à la tête Allemagne
Suisse
pour le moment c'est rien n'est dit hein
parce que je vois qu'Élisabeth pet c'est
mieux contre Alexandra costenou les
autreschiquet pour le moment sont c'est
égalité mais il y a une victoire au trè
échiqué de la Suisse la suissaesse donc
pour le moment la Suisse mène 1-0 face à
l'Allemagne donc chaud non je pense que
alors j'en sais rien mais j'ai envie de
parier au hasard et dire que la France
sera sur le podium sans rien comprendre
à ce qui se passe et sans rien
comprendre des partag ouais j'ai envie
de me dire ça quoi non mais il faut pas
perdre 4-0 déjà c'est c'est vraiment
trop difficile faudrait un miracle quoi
je pense 4-0 ça coûte tellement
cher mais après je suis pas spécialiste
he il
enfin on nous a dit dans dans le chat
c'est du burger donc c'est la somme des
Scor des adversaires mais c'est pondéré
par score du match donc en fait quand tu
fais de 2 10 2 x 10 et quand on fait euh
2 et demi ça fait 2,5 x 10 point de
départage donc marquer gros tu quand tu
marques 40 c'est tu prends 40 et cetera
donc c'est c'està dire que là les les
Ukrainiennes ell prennent 40 points non
ça veut dire qu'and ben leure
despartages va être va faire plaisir
quoi
ir faire plus 40 non c'est pas possible
de faire plus 40 je sais pas comment je
suis pas spécialiste mais en tout cas
elles vont gagner beaucoup de points
c'est sûr
al ça serait 4 x 12 dans ce CASL
et la graisse ça donne
quoi la
Grèce
euh la Grèce on est sur une petite
option pour la Grèce quand
même ce qui est pas forcément bien
nontion pour gr après ce dernier match
était quand même difficile he face à
l'Ukraine c'était ah mais là c'est
horrible de de passer de la tête à faire
un tournoi aussi beau repartir
bredouille le retour pasre douloureux
surtout que là où c'est c'est vraiment
ce qui est difficile c'est
que le match contre
l'Azerbaïjan elles étaient complètement
enôle les Françaises finalement mat nul
la Bulgarie elles étaient pas mal aussi
les Françaises et donc il y aura de quoi
se mordre les doigts mais je répète par
rapport à ce que je disais hier c'est
une équipe qui est en construction donc
toutes ces petites choses là ça
les joueuses vont apprendre et je pense
pas qu'and les reprendre ce niveau de
jeu qu'elles ont présenté pendant cette
compétition elles vont le représenter à
nouveau parce que ben c'est des joueuses
qui sont en pleine progression qui sont
hyper fortes qui s'entendent bien donc
il y a vraiment un groupe il y a
vraiment une émulation et apprendre à
gérer
ben le stress les phases difficiles la
défaite ça en fait ça se travaille ça
s'apprend et la seule chose qu'on peut
vraiment espérer c'est que sur les
prochaines compétitions ben
qu'elle qu'elle gagne en confiance et
qu'elle nous représente à nouveau ce
niveau de jeu et cette fois-ci en allant
vraiment jusqu'au bout et je pense qu'on
ouais il y a de quoi être fier et et
vraiment on peut on peut y
croire pas juste sur cette compétition
mais sur Ben par rapport à l'avenir en
fait l'avenir de l'équipe de France
féminine d'échec oui non mais ce c'est
sûrement que même de toute façon le 4-0
est pas là et puis il y a encore de
parties qui jouent même quand bien même
sur l'ensemble de la compétition elle
gagnerait des des points ho je pense
c'est à peu près certain vu les parcours
incroyables de de polineemitra Mme
malgré potentiellement une mauvaise faim
euh mais mais ça peut mettre un un coup
ça rend vraiment
le au niveau du Moral les derniers
résultats compte bien plus que que les
premiers quand
quand pourquoi tu es toujours défétiste
B non mais c'est V toujours non non faut
pondérer vers là ENF si a 40 c'est c'est
dur pour le moral c'est juste un match
mais c'est juste un match
c'este REM rien en question sur sur le
parour le long terme ça remet absolument
rien en question donc c'est dur mais
après le c'est c'est pas c'est pas
écrit donc cela dit pour répondre à à ta
question ouais c'est les Ukrainiennes
ell prendrait 48
points si elle nous Batt qu'on a 12 FO
prend zé point on prend quelques points
quand même ben je pense zéro hein zéro
et genre si on a fait un point ou un
truc comme ça on prend on aurait pris 10
10 ou 12 points ouais ouais mais on fait
un point contre elle qui ont 10 non du
coup et du coup on prend 10 points
okreur
ce ah bah ouais ouais non mais après on
avait fait des gros scores aussi hein
c'est pour ça qu'on avait un très bon
départage il y avait tr et demi 3 et
demi et cetera mais c'est un départage
qui fait que chaque partie du tournoi
compte ça ça a son intérêt aussi c'est
vrai quand tu gagnes les matchs 4-0 et
qu'après tu perds 2 et demi 1 et demi tu
te dis mais attends j'ai j'ai marqué
quand même 6 points et demi c'est c'est
c'est pas si mal mais enfin 5 point et
demi c'est pas si mal mais bon bref gg a
raison en fait il nous dit démonter peut
encore faire nul et c'est vrai et puis
même Pauline leur dit il affiche un gain
plus de et quelqu mais comme on l'a dit
c'est c'est pas simple à gagner avec ce
fou de la mauvaise couleur avec tourfou
avec plus qu'un pion avec encore trois
pions noirs donc ici le 41e est atteint
et c'est clairement pas fini eu
ouais et c'est vrai que démter le
cavalier contre cavalier dam contre dam
il reste encore des des petites
tactiques des très concrètement il y a
une menace quoi
oui ça serait bien que son adversaire
s'endort mais tombe et
[Musique]
voilà est-ce que non je dire n'importe
quoi c'est c'est fatiguant aussi ces
commentaires
[Musique]
euh qu'est-ce qu'on joue là-dessus en
fait
avoir des idées un peu folles de ramener
le roi vers l'il d'â genre ro G1 ro F1
comme ça après on pousse G4 on va se
cacher de l'autre côté de les chiquers
enfin un truc dans le genre quoi ouais
alors le problème c'est qu'on passe par
si on arrive en A2 téléportation
not mais on va peut-être avoir du mal à
aller jusqu'au bout non le le chemin
paraît
long il est parti à la p
on joue ça et on sent tellement forte
mais c'est il vaut tu si la position est
un peu plus fer mais s'il y avait un
pion là un pion là ok peut-être ça
serait brillant là ça me paraît Optimist
alors après il y a quand même une idée
de jouer ro G1 c'est pour que dame D6 ne
menasse pas mat mais on va s'arrêter
quand même pas loin on va peut-être pas
aller jusqu'en de
quoioui après ro g est-ce qu'on ouais
peut-être que dans un second temps
pouvoir jouer G4 dame H4 dame F2 et
essayer de tout garder sous contrôle et
juste voilà proté contrôler la C C4
essayer de dire au au noir ben
maintenant essayer de passer ça peut
être l'idée des une idée de défense des
des
blancs et c'est un peu surprenant
qu'elle ait pas jouer tour G7 est-ce que
il y a plus avoir des propositions
Nules je pense qu'on a passé le 40e donc
euh et
non parce que c'est ça peut être un truc
tu vois de tuas la proposition de nul là
tu dis mais attends j'assure le gain du
match et puis après tu commences à
réfléchir attends mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle me propose nul euh est-ce que si
on gagne sur un gros score et puis parce
que les Ukrainiennes sont en train de
faire les mêmes calculs que nous
peut-être parce que sinon tour G7 a
vraiment l'air très
logique pense que les Ukrainiennes
connaissent le système de départage elle
a pris en de3 mais il a pris en F7
donc ouais donc elle prend perpè alors
c'est
ça c'est un
perpète non c'est ça il y a tour mat ah
c'est important le c'est mat du couloir
ya c'est un nouveau thème
tactique on pas traillé et là c'est pas
mat parce que y
a ah mais c'est chaud ça hyper compliqué
attend c'est hyper compliqué mais
génial
échec éche fait échec si on fait
G3 tour
F8 tour
F8 donc on va plutôt faire 5
bim5 bon à l' forcé parce qu'on a ça en
prise ça en
prise
5 menace mat G3 ne part pas la menace
[Rires]
de juste ouais juste pour montrer que
c'est vraiment une menace de mat de vrai
mat bon là j'ai par en G6 comme une
idiote mais c'était le pion la joueuse a
raté ce coup qui est quand même assez
incroyable dis-moi
nana j'avou j'ai triché mais peutreon PE
peut-être 2 secondes au chat si là il y
a un super coup de défense pour les
blancs donc la menace d'ailleurs
cavalier prend s 7 jouet donc 43e on est
prend C 7 jouet donc on est là c'est la
partie et donc dame D6 on avait dit
échec d'abord échec d'abord ouais échec
ensuite E5 t prend5 meass mat il y a pas
d'échec ce coup de défense ce coup de
défense cavalier B5
oufissime et là-dessus ah
c'estch tour prend de E2 cavalier prend
D6 je pense c'est un éch elle a raté
cavalier B5 et dame D8 on peut prendre
et on a une qualité de moins mais en
fait on préfère largement les blanc ici
avec le couple qui dame du M dans l'air
non bah l'ordi dit ég 00 mais je sais
pas c'est chaud non je ser terrifié h
méga chaud ah là là alors est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres coup qui les prend
C7 est-ce qu'on peut jouer t prend 4 on
prend on prend F6
ouais et là je pense qu'on a le perpè on
a minimum le PERP c'est même ouais B on
a pas de oui bon ok PERP de toute façon
on prend donc prend C7
ouaisist B5 carrément trouvable par
façon là il y a il y a plus le choix est
ici si l'autre fait échec elle va
trouver H2 c'est coup si l'utre fait
échec elle va trouver5 on espère G3 ça
peut être G3 G3 tour F8 oui après tu si
tu vois pas qu' B5 ici tu es obligé de
voir qu' B5 mais ici tu es plus qu'à de
coups
après après pas oubl démonter a 28
minutes à pendu donc dire quand Mme temp
de réfléchir et parfois tu peux te faire
bluffer si
l'adversaire est totalement confiante
mais ça voudrait dire que anina aussi a
loupé le C B5 et mais si normalement tu
sens si l'adversaire commence à
réfléchir 15 minutes alors que tu crois
que tu es ma de bon tu commences à dire
peutêtre que je suis pas ma en fait du
coup tu comprends pourquoi donc bah
c'est chaud c'est chaud ici il y a un
vrai choix
ouais nouvelle qui démonter arrive à à
faire nul et si Pauline arrive à tenir
la nul ça changerait mais alors ce
serait ben on va voir tout de
suite Natalia jokova avec sa pièce de
plus mais vraiment pas simple raté
vraiment pas simple à convertir cette
pièce j'ai déjà vu pour être franche une
partie il a fini par gagner mais
Anatolie weicer
euh le champion du RS du Russie
et ouais pardon je suis merci je suis
décalqué mais donc anathalie Weisser qui
a pas réussi à gagner t si qui avait
gagné mais au bout de de 2h 2h de finale
et puis tourn pendant 2h 2h tourfou pion
h compte tris tours donc ça gagne hein
cette finale
euh tourfou pion cont
Tourou mais en fait faut pas que le pion
a dépassé la
4e si ouais le P reste en
H3 c'est
euh H4 c'est nul s'il avance en H5 c'est
gagnant s'il avance en H5 c'est nul non
je crois pas que ça soit celle-là si si
et si elle mange tous les pions c'est
celle-ci ouais non si elle mange tous
les pions et que le pion est même en H
ça ça ça gagne c'est euh je cro les
tours
qualité mais en fait je sais parce que
je l'ai eu je l'ai défendu au Cap d'
contre Manon oui oui c'est les qualités
ouis tu as raison ou par mais cela dit
c'est quand même pas bien d'avoir le
pion hchi c'est bien plus facile quand
le pion et en H3 mais donc même cette
finale quand on mange tous les pions
c'est pas si fa facile alors attends il
y a
eu deux répétitions non je regardais sur
le petit échiquier je fais n'importe
quoi on va plutôt regarder sur le Grand
Échiquier eu deux répétitions enfin pas
trois hein là elle peut changer quand
même à priori on va tour à de échec tour
à de et pu le truc c'est qu'elle a pas
qu'un cas non enfin ah attends F3
peut-être possible elle peut jouer
partout he par que toute façon tu as
tout ouis mais' perd jamais le R
ouais Z
ouais donc elle elle fait ça juste pour
gagner un peu de ouais
ou du coup c'est marrant de de le de
mettre le point d'interrogation pas là
mais de le mettre ici alors que c'est la
même position que ah peut-être qu'il
considérait que là on peut pas jouer R3
ah sinon peêtre qu'il considéit que le
gap de perte de points
de plus 25 à + 15 c'est
trop peut-être que c'est ça ouais bon pe
importe ouais enfin en tout cas c'est la
la même position et pas la même punition
h et popo qui
réfléchit bon alors après elle comprend
que son adversaire va pas lui laisser la
nulle tout de suite
hein
mais etci on peut retrouver tour quand
même parce que le roi il est mal placé
en fait pendant que j'y
réfléchis comment on joue pour le gain
après
tourin c'est pas c'est pas pas mal un du
tout en fait pourquoi elle fait pas tour
à 2 en fait si on joue G3 là c'est
vraiment nul là on appelle l'arbitre ce
sera la trème répétition ouais tuappell
l'arbitre et tu joues Touras de 3 ok
donc elle change mais maintenant tour 1
et donc l'idée des noir c'est de faire
A2
échec et le truc c'est que tant qu'on
avait le roi en
F2 A2 ah mais le fou des5 et il y a pas
t rchat en
contrôle ça c'est
important parce que avec le roi3 tour si
on joue par
exemple2 c'est nul si on
joue après jou par exemple tour A8 échec
et ro F2 mais c'est plus exactement le
roi n'est plus ou mais ouais c'est quand
même bien tu as raison si on veut
changer avoir le roi m2 on fait échaque
d' boire mais du coup ça améliore quand
même la position des noir mais donc
c'est juste pour montrer si on fait roi2
A2 fou D5 c'est pas la même là on a
cette astuce non bah si ah non il y a F
pr mais ça ça ça gagne ça mais tu as
même tour pr qui est possible non ah si
par que le F cont la case ah j'en faux
plus je suis fatiguée
euh oui non mais peut-être que tu peux
jouer euh est-ce que tu peux jouer F5 ou
quelque chose comme ça
non pe TR F5 quoi
ouais mais c'est pas simple du tout
parce que là
euh ce genre de de position
ouais mais tu vois en après ton non là
il y a échec n'importe quoi parce que là
il faut éviter échec et fou bouge et oui
t rchin pas bête tour H1 menace tour
prend H3 et menace tour H2 aussi
peut-être donc ouis tour à 3 tour H 2 le
roi est obligé de redescendre et tu peux
ramener ton roi
ouais donc roi E3 il faut avoir
ok super super donc ça 3 ouais l'espoir
revie donc on rappelle le score quand
même
2-0
mais on fait le deuil de la médaille
d'or on veut maintenant garantir la
médaille de bronze quitte à perdre ce
match il faut le perdre absolument sur
le plus petit des SCOR on a pour
l'instant un bien meilleur départage que
les équipes concurrentes qui pourraient
nous passer
devant mais une défaite 4-0 serait
horrible pour ce départage et bénéfique
au départage des ukrainiennes notamment
et donc chaque partie
compte alors est-ce que tu veux qu'on
aille jeter un petit coup d'œil rapide
sur les parties des gars avant peut-être
de prendre
ouais on peut regarder
rouio donc rappelons marquant défaites
Étienne Bacro match nul Jul il a une
meilleure structure de pion il va jouer
pour le gain dans cette
position pas forcément facile le pion a
il est faible il est désolé mais il est
passé aussi on se l'a
dit on peut tout à fait imaginer une
victoire de Jules quand même ici oui oui
oui et
Laurent avec les blancs dans son
italienne magnifique Laurent
bravo comment comment est-ce qu'il a
fait
pourir aant de
je alors magicien donc on s'était quitté
par là il a mis ses cavaliers bien
placés à l' rooit il y a eu des échanges
ouverture
ressem petite faute d'après l'ordi mais
pas très grave car de points
d'exclamation mais tactique
fraess c'est compliqué en plus parce que
prise
prise phase qui calcule comme quand il
avait 20 ans mais c'est magnifique oh
mais mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
mais regarde il y a des points
d'exclamation de
partout encore mais
arrête F4 il il y a des FR a des pièces
en frise de partout et et FR enchaîne le
point
d'exclamation quelle partie bah ça
commence quelle d'artifice à mal ouais
il a un P de moins mais alors il y a des
petites
menaces
TR F pr F6 je pense sur sur Tourp
ouais je sais pas si ça marche est-ce
qu'on peut jouer ah mais il y a pas
échec il y a pas Échec oh il y a pas
échec je me suis fait avoir
ouais non après on peut prendre prendre
et
ça la qualité plus ça ressemble à une
belle qualité de plus quand même
c'est marrant là où un truc comme ça où
toutes les pièces noires défendre mais
alors du coup elle joue plus beaucoup
non ça ça ça doit
gagner ça doit gagner on peut tellement
pas jouer
euh ok et ben donc une victoire
française potentielle chez chez les
mec ok est-ce qu'on se fait petite pause
ou dis-moi nana vas-y juste pour info
Pauline a bien joué tour Pauline a joué
tour à ok donc l'espoir et donc pour
suivre ces deux dernières parties de nos
joueuses françaises les deux dernières
parties de nos joueurs français
également on se retrouve après une
petite pause à tout de
suite
[Musique]
et euh nous revoilà pour suivre la fin
de ces parties alors fress est en train
de gagner sa partie mais ce qui nous
intéresse c'est avant tout le match des
euh joueuses françaises qui peut-être
peuvent terminer encore sur le podium
euh mais pour ça il faudrait perdre ce
match on on a fait le deuil mais euh sur
la sur le plus petit score possible
euh démonter c'était perdant puis
c'était peut-être nul peut-être à
nouveau perdant d'après l'ordi
évidemment elles elles n'ont pas la
jauge ici on avait
expliqué cette tactique incroyable qui
nous avait surprise même passionné E5
qui a l'air de perdre tout de suite
après tour prend le5 menace mat mais il
y a cavalier
B5 facile à rater mais ça aurait été
renversant parce que en plus se prendre
ça en sec not il y a même des
possibilités de gain alors dit que c'est
ég 00 après ça mais bon t un coup c'est
une partie complexe
avec des chances ça se termine par un
parpète certes mais tout peut arriver
mais à démter n'y a pas cru simplement
rater ce cavaler B5 à jouer G3 à tempo t
F8 et maintenant c'est
problématique donc dame G6 ne marche
pas parce que on peut prendre en C7 et
sur dame prend6 ro G8 et sur dame G6 la
dame revient donc tour F8 dé Moné
réfléchis
h ah c'est horriblement frustrant
d'avoir joué
ouais de mais après c'est toujours
facile si elle savait que c'était matul
à ce moment-là elle trouve C assez
rapidement je pense
là avoir la jaule ça aide pardon oui
très très difficile d'évaluer
E5 surtout et si tu vois pas cavalier B5
même après k B5 te dire j'ai 15 pions en
moins une attaque ouais h dame D8 en
plus dame D8 seul coup qui tient bon
après logique he protège le pion F6
ouais tour prend le5 puision prend
le5 ouais hyper dur d'évaluer ça de se
dire ok c'est h mais bon ça sens qu'il y
a probablement des perpètes quand même
la machin qu'en plus attaque la
tour ça c'est sympa quand même en fait
si on peut tout à fait gagner cette
position fort immédiatement ouais on
peut tout à fait gagner cette position
même mais bon ok c'est du c'est dans le
passé
euh on demande est-ce qu'elle a raté
tour F8 elle a surtout raté qu'elle les
B5
ça on est on est ici il y a un échec il
y a que de coup
Lego si on voit pas cavaler B5 E5 c'est
mat en de ici on est mat s'il y a pas c
B5 donc si on le voit pas on joue G3 par
par dépit peut-être mais on joue G3
[Musique]
donc alors il y a une
possibilité c'est ça ça ça avec l'idée
que surprise le pion est c'est
étrangement fort quand
même mais bon même ça l'ORD dit dit que
ça gagne pour les
noirs à noter qu'on a aussi le rooit
toujours dans des dans des mat
potentiels
ah c'est
dommage un petit coup d'il chez popo
ou notre meilleure buteuse est-ce que
c'est elle va être la seule
à à éviter la
catastrophe
alors on sétait quitté
ici roi des
deux tour à 2 3 tour 1 fou
des5 donc on avait expliqué qu'il y
avait des histoires de répétition c'est
plus le cas du tout le fou a changé de
case mais il était venu en4 pour une
bonne raison
c'était pour contrôler la poussée F5 ici
il peut y avoir des échecs mais on a du
mal à croire vu que la tour peut pas
tout faire
non c'est chaud ça c'est vraiment une
étude on bouge le
roi
ah j'ai perdu
desd j'ai perdu
nana sa connexion a
sauté c'est problématique alors vous me
voyez en double ce qui m'arrange pas
vous me voyez en
simple
alors de de nata non elle essaie de
revenir elle dit donc bref F 5 on a très
envie de jouer F5 F5 jouer donc on
oublie toutes les histoires de
répétition de coup on a une pièce de
moins pour cette pièce on a deux pions
ces pions avance rappelons toujours pour
celles et ceux qui viendraient de nous
rejoindre Natacha redémarre son ordi on
souhaite le
revoir au plus vite
euh le revoir tout court mais donc si on
échange les tours c'est match nul peu
importe qu'on perde tous les pions donc
on veut échanger les tours c'est une
chose qu'on veut sinon à un moment ces
pions nos pions peuvent devenir fort
donc un moyen d'échanger les tours ça
peut être un moment de jouer à
deux en cas de prise il peut avoir un
problème de clouage du Fou et en cas de
prise de la tour on saute sur l'occasion
donc pas si simple quand même
pour pour les blancs et évidemment
possibilité de match nul ça ça risque
d'être un peu plus long c'est si on
arrive à prendre le pion
H3 mais c'est tellement compliqué alors
fou 6 il y a pas
tourchin il y a pas tourchin parce que
fou prend F5 défend le pion qu'est-ce
qu'on peut jouer ici
ouais tu
arrive tu arrives au moment où Natacha
démarre son ordi si tu as des problèmes
de connexion moi je tiens à préciser
pour pour ceux qui étaient là hier que
Orange est passé ce matin et c'est bon
j'ai la fibre chez moi
yaho donc faut essayer me paraître un
coup
intéressant tour F1 protège le pion t pr
à3 on a plus que un pion pour la
pièce c'est tendu dans E4 men
ça alors si on gagne le pion en force ça
c'est pas mal donc comme j'ai dit
l'échange c'est nul tout de suite qu'on
perd cette option là on s'en fiche c'est
une forteresse ultra
connue si les blancs veulent pas
échanger il faut faire
échec alors est-ce que j'ai retrouvé
nana
alors mince je t'ai retrouvé mais tu es
toute petite
nana désolé so pas désolé attends je te
repartage
l'écran j'ai ton partage d'écran c'est
bon c'est bon alors juste tout
petite grandis un peu
nana est attend je vais faire grandir fa
ai jouer c'est là elle joue bien en
plus alors ça reste nul probablement
mais je crois que je t'ai alors
ok on est pas mal ici je te
renomme mon truc préféré
hop h ah si c'est bon
euh je pense qu'on n pas trop mal
ok parfait dites-moi si c'est
bon
euh mais qu'est-ce que c'est cette
question ciel
bleu non il y a pas de première madame
grichou là non non non pas de carnet
rose n est revenu on peut plus parler de
pot non j'ai raté j'ai raté le meilleur
moment non non non non j'ai pas j'ai
rien dit
choisi nous disait que si on perd des 40
c'est 203
203 donc c'est dire que Pauline doit
faire match nul ça fait match nul on est
3e c'est ça
euh c'est ce qu'elle a l'air de dire
après elle elle m'avait écrit j'ai pas
j'ai pas vu dans le chat elle m'avait
écrit pour dire 3 et demi 05 sur les
scores ça a l'air de marcher mais 40 ça
va
[Musique]
ok donc il faut absolument que l'une de
nos joueuses tienne la nul donc F6 j'ai
expliquer attaque le ption on peut pas
jouer tour rchin F PR5 protège et il y a
l'annule d'ordinateur c'est incroyable
très difficile à
voir nous l' montrer ouais ouais je l'ai
montré coup au chat quand alors c'est le
seul coup pour faire nul le direct
quandta
pasend3 E4 on se dit mais c'est pas
grave on bouge le roi et en fait
T et sur échec c'est pas grave on bouge
le
roi et après il faut encore faut encore
défendreette position dis-moi dis-moi
pardon je disis après
ro5 t prend H3 tour A7 il y a pas de
thème
on arrive à s'en sortir d'après l'ordi
oui c'est un peu chaud c'est vrai tu as
les pions parapluies comme on le disait
tout à
l'heure on
[Musique]
préférait d'ailleurs si on préfère avoir
les pions sans les pions ça serait
perdant
mais pourquoi ça c'est
pas pourquoi c'est pas mal ça
t'enfuir les
bien parce que ici sinon ça
gagne ça va être la partie qui
Vaé
hy on se bat a priori si onit alors DD
totalement perdante on n dit allons
quand même laavir si on fait un match
nul sur deux parties on serait
conditionnel 3e au départage h non je
vais juste mettre ici ici on a une tour
de moin c'est compliqué c'est du
zckn mais c'est une tour de
moi si on met la
SMAT on se fait
matant r le M et on
gagne bon ben c'est pas la
joie non non non mais très très
difficile pour pour
démonterour
vraiment
ouis ouais donc démter bon gardons un
œil peut-être je peux faire démter en
petit je vais faire l'inverse démonter
en
petit gros ou en
Grand T TC
t
quel pass chaque partie
compte donc qu'est-ce qui se passe si on
joue autre chose bon en fait s'il y
a faut aussi c'est vraiment bien joué
parce que cette man faut des5 laisse
faire F5 faut aussi s'attaque le pion
sur un coup comme F4 le roi va pénétrer
c'est le roi parapluie justement pour
mentionner
oui
oui et là on est vraiment en grand
danger parce que par exemple tour 1 tour
3 on se fait mat h on a peur d'échec et
on se fait mater ça je pense que po
paraplu ça popo elle a vu donc F4 ça ne
doit pas être une option pour Pauline et
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce
qu'on intercale tour1 échec ou pas
problème c'est que sur ouis
tour1 ro F2 et on est obligé de revenir
en en 1
non ça c'est pas possible de perdre de
pion comme ça
ouais c'est pas possible parce queà
chaque fois sur A2 il y a toujours F
fou6
oui ou même roi ah j'ai réussi à faire
tchat a plein d' oui
pardon 0 G2 tout simplement aussi
ouais ah mais c'est c'était mignon ce ce
truc que je me suis prise toute seule 6
donc tour H1 juste pour montrer l'autre
variante si on prend du fot tour prend
H3 si on prend de la tour tour H2
enfilade quand bien même c'est protégé
c'est match nul c'est tellement
compliqué et euh Matth 4973 qui nous dit
c'est pas possible ah
ouais tout à fait po possible et
français chaud est-ce qu'on a juste
dis-moi les gars est-ce qu'on a du
nouveau ou pas du tout par curiosité
est-ce un point et demi à 05 mais deux
parties bien engagé voir très bien
engagé voir super bien engagé
fress il a sa qualité de plus le pion E6
va tomber ça plus qu'un pour la qualité
il y a toujours le problème de clouage
ouais ça s'abandonne cette position on
peut jouer ça pour ce clouer mais ça
risque de coûter de pions du coup ouais
ce qui est quand même cher ouais donc
fress devrait gagner et rouio sa finale
technique l'ancien élève de spironf ah
n'a fait que nul et ben non donc au
mieux match
nul pour les
Français pas forcément un peu décevant
mais bon peut-être le cœur n'y était
plus on l'a vu dans la partie de
tienne il a fait nul rapide
ok
donc vous avez en petit échiqué la
partie de démanté on va retourner sur la
partie de popo grand
échiquier un match nul serait qu' nel
corrigez-moi si il y a un arbitre qui a
son tableau Excel ouvert qui fait
calcule tous les départages mais à
priori on serait sur une défaite 4-0
synonyme de 4e place en tout cas pas de
podium et un match nul de Pauline qui
serait synonyme de 3e place et
ben
ouais pour pouvoir réussir il faut que
pe joue tour
F1 tour F1 c'est le coup qui arrive à
maintenir le la joge au milieu qui
arrive à maintenir l'égalité dans la
position alors c'est ça va rester encore
très très compliqué hein parce que
c'est le roi noir est potentiellement
dans des réseaux de
math et donc ça va c'est très très
compliqué à défendre et d'autant plus en
not ça va être on va assister à un beau
combat et juste parce que je comprends
pas à de PR à
de on est sûr que ça
gagne a l'air de dire que
OUI à chaque fois les blancs vont
réussir à
j'ai pas de coup malin c'est ça je peux
pas je mon r en fait c'est peut-être si
le roi était sur une autre case ça irit
le clouage de cet alignement est
problématique quoi vu que il il y a
jamais de c'est que quand tu joues tour
H1 il y a T tour H7 c'est
ça ouais tour H1 tour
H7 donc c'est B avec le RO en F8 ça
marche pas on peut pas jouer ça donc
faut vraiment jouer tour
F1 c'est vraiment le coup tout à l'heure
de roi F8 roi G7 ro F8 ou qui au 39e
coup donc dernier coup en Z
not h mais après c'est tellement c'est
naturel d'aller sur bon ici on risque de
se faire
mater et et du coup elle est sur c'est
peut-être ro F7 ouais ro F7 pour aller
en E6 l'idée je pense en cas d'échec
ouais ne pas se faire coincer le roi sur
après la sur la
7e ouais mais c'est vrai en zacn enfin
de toute façon il y a ou pas de Zn mais
il y a pas beaucoup de temps aller sur
une case noir c'est mais bon l'chac bien
joué point d'exclamation
ouais mais elle a bien joué aussi he sa
technique de je répète deux fois chaque
fois mais pas trois à montant alors ben
après d'une certaine manière s'est mise
en difficulté parce que à force de
répéter s'est retrouvé obligé de jouer
pour3 qui euh
h le coup fa aussi si il fait mal l'ordi
trouve tour F1 donc il est serein mais
tour F1 faut
vraiment avoir l'idée de donner le pion
en voyant que 4 tour F3 on peut le
prémoverver que même là-dessus TF3 on
attaque le pion puis après c'est pas
c'est pas fini hein c'est c'est c'est
cette finale cette finale où
euh il faut mettre le on peut tout à
fait la perdre quoi même d'ailleurs fut
prend F5 on peut la perdre celle-là
elle qui est extrêmement compliquée hein
c'est
h très très dur très très dur à jouer de
la part des Noirs donc ça se joue a je
crois qu'un coup a été joué sur fou 6
jouer là jou je n'aime pas alors elle
aime pas à cause de roi
F2 faut-il aussi que l'Ukrainienne
trouve le coup ro F2 ça fait ouais on va
essayer de comprendre déjà donc sur
là-dessus on joue à deux et maintenant
il y a plus de F 6 parce que on fait
échec
ouais enasse tour1 et tour F1
HH donc
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres coups qui
pourraient
être
piégeur naturel pour pour les blancs
voilà Tchin logique ouais Tchin suivi
euh et il y a plus F pr F5 qui protège
le pion
ouais
ah donc re8 ça a clairement du
sens si on vient ailleurs sur
la deuxème
rangée
A2 prend 2 et sur T H t maintenant tour
H 2
enfilade et donc a priori c'est pour ça
qu'il faut jouer ro F2 comme ça
sur Party a dit quelque chose de non
n'importe Démé qu'est-ce qu'
raconteour ça ça
t vous me faites pas de faux espoir non
non c'est pas un faux
espoir
incroyable démoné là faut pas lâcher
perpè elle prend le PERP et PERP plutôt
facile à oh là là génial démter
bravo donc on peut se faire mat aussi
attend
i mtenant mainten beurre on veut
l'argent du beurre là-dessus aussi on se
fait maen
ouais faut bien j tour G4 H8 et tour H4
hein je pense que c'est ça tour H7 tour
ah c'est chou c'est horrible ce qu'elle
se prend dame
G6 après il y a et oui mais c'est qu'il
y a dame G4 et dame prend des de ah
c'est encore ch jouer en fait non mais
il y a un perpè aussi on peut jouer dam
G6 tuas un
perpè ça c'est ça c'est connu ça simple
ouais oui
oui génial quelle est l'erreur
de je te Peris pas pourquoi je me
[Rires]
fais qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui
se passe ciel bleu qui dit Yosa grand
MRE en problème spécialité
MATD non mais je beaucoup d'sult origin
av jamais fa mais Yosa à chaque fois
qu'il y a une position la première chose
que tu cherches c'est un
MATD non mais c'est vrai c'est non mais
il faut le dire surtout quand c'est un
MATD ukrainien ah
donc
qui fait nul quel soulagement
maisement j'en reviens à jeis ce qui
disait ça se joue aussi chez géobul et a
Serbie donc il faut quand même que la
Serbie perde
allons voir les Serbes allons voir les
Serbes allons poisser les autres
équipes parce
que on est où
elle est où la Serbie ser sont juste
auudessus de de nous mais ça disparu
parce qu'elles ont terminé leur
[Musique]
matchit je l'ai pas j'ai
Serb on dit bien Serbia je ne rêve pas
oui j'ai azerbaïjan Serbia ouais mais
pourquoi je les ai pas mais elles font
quoi alors attends je juste refresh le
kazou j'ai pour le moment j'ai
1 c'est quoi ce délire c'est celui-là
c'est ser bien en premier
attends
jeu il est tout au bout je sais pas
pourquoi euh
il y a pour
l'instant un
partoutor jack à gagné
R et donc
ici ici on est pour les blancs l'ORD dit
c'est
égal ici on est pour les Noirs l'ordi
dit que c'est
gagnant il faut absolument cette finale
de tour soit gagnée il faut pas le
miracle un Serbe dans l'autre ça change
vraiment quelque chose si f mat nul les
Serbes je suis pas sûr P qu'on est
devant toujours au départage non je sais
pas je ne sais pas ça
c'est s'il vous plaît on a
besoin
sal calul
ditesnous
on veut savoir parce que du
coup
ah va c'est revenu
bon n officiel chez Desmé on vous a
montré le perpétuel et attends H4 jouer
H4 jouer et après tour
H1 le pion est bien jouer Tchin même ou
t t ah mais c'est ça l'idée H5 surprise
F F7 ah
tricky et donc c'est chaud en fait c'est
ultra
chaud vous voyez attends je je remettre
sur le petite échqu par que du coup on a
plus qu'une
partie alors non ciel bleu euh
l'Azerbaïdjan alors la France le le
avant cette ronde Bulgarie première avec
13 points
azerbaïjan seconde avec 12 points et la
France 3e seule avec 11 points non c'est
pas ça 14 13 12 14 13 12 Serbie 11
points et ensuite une flopppée d'équipe
à 10 points ah non donc la France per
elle reste à 12 points toutes les
équipes ah non mais c'est l'ordi qui
déconne pardon je t'ai coupé parce que
j'ai vu mat en 11 s'afficher mais l'ordi
propose F pr H3 excuse-moi de t'avoir
coupé mais j'ai une crise cardiaque a
pas de souci pas souci vas-y vas-y
vas-y donc en gros la France ok a perdu
faut que la Serbie perde comme ça la
Serbie reste à 11 points si elle fit
match nul si la Serbie fait match nul
elle passe à 12 points et donc après ça
se joue au départage plus la flopppée
d'équipe de 10 points qui peuvent
remonter à 12 points et donc c'est ce
qu'on est en train de calculer si la
France perdait 4-0 ce dont on a eu très
très peur en fait au départage
ben l'Ukraine prend a priori prend 48
points d'un coup au départage ce qui est
juste énorme et donc là en diminuant
l'écart de la défaite en fait la France
peut-être peut-être que les Françaises
c'est pour ça qu'on a absolument besoin
d'un ou d'une arbitre on a besoin de
quelqu'un avec sa calculatrice on a
besoin que quelqu'un nous calcule les
score mais c'est fortement probable que
la France ce soit soit en train de
s'assurer la 3è place h alors après le
le drame est en train de se nouer parce
que ça ça sera pas terminé avant encore
plus de 50
coups
c'est voir peut-être plus parce que si
le pion e ouais alors en fait il' un
monde parce qu'en fait ce pion il est
mort ne croyez pas à la possibilité de
faire nul en jouant juste des coups
comme ça non ce pion il est mort
d'ailleurs il est mort tout de suite
ce qui est pas plus mal parce que
parfois s psychologiquement de le
défendre pendant 30 coups il finit
toujours par être perdu il est toujours
perdu ce pion sur la 7è rangée il peut
être nul il peut être défendu mais là
justement il y a il y a trop de de moyen
de passer par derrière et donc voilà on
a cette finale roitour contre roitour
fou nul théorique mais même des grands
maîtres à plus de 2700 la perdent
régulièrement je crois que même Magnus a
perdu récemment en partie rapide contre
Nakamura euh en blitz c'est sur internet
mais bon donc si même Magnus peut peut
la perdre vraiment tout le monde peut la
perdre cela dit c'est Mach théorique je
sais que Pauline a déjà ouvert des bons
livres de finale qu'elle a fait le
deorski tout ça donc elle a des
connaissances le problème c'est de les
appliquation ses connaissances après une
semaine de tournoi même 10 jours de
tournoi et après 5 he de jeu ici hein
c'est c'est c'est facile de de réciter
enfin c'est facile déjà il faut
connaître mais c'est facile de réciter
des moyens de faire nul et cetera ça
m'exaspère toujours quand il y a des des
joueurs qui ne jouent plus depuis des
années qui euh qui commente ah mais
comment on peut être maître ou grand
maître et ne pas connaître ça non c'est
pas connaître c'est évidemment qu'on l'a
tous vu mais après 5 he de jeu après 10
jours de tournoi tu fais des gaffes quoi
c'est tu fais des gaffes dans
l'ouverture tu fais des gaffes dans le
milieu de jeu tu fais des gaffes dans
les finales que tu as déjà vu
quoi
donc non qu' on va dire peut-être la la
Bonne Nouvelle bon coup euh la dernière
prise coup 55 donc bon 50 coup ça nous
amène au 105e coup la bonne nouvelle
c'est que les rois sont au centre de
l'chiquier donc ça veut dire avant de
réussir si les blancs parviennent à
repousser le roi sur un bord de chiquier
pour essayer de mat ben il va falloir
jouer pas mal de coups donc ça c'est
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle falloir
que donc on va dire que bon bien une une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de coups mais
oui non je
suisis d'accord mais l'UR va être sur le
bord à un moment et puis après faudra
faire nul a priori
euh en défendant donc une position
typique de
nul je vais faire n'importe quoi avec
les pièces mais à un moment le roi sera
condamné à aller sur le
bord et donc une position non mais ça
c'est la position typique de gain je fa
n'importe quoi position typique de nul
ça serait ici dans ça qui de
jouer il faut que je perde un tempo
voilà ça comment elle s'appelle
celle-là elle a un nom je crois ouais
elle a un petit nom a le nom de son de
couvreur mais je me rappelle plus ça
c'est la position de base pour faire nul
c'est la méthode la plus simple donc les
Blancs jouent un coup d'attente on
attend tranquillement avec la tour
[Musique]
et quand le roi choisit un côté donc on
clou le fou sur le roi quand le roi a
choisit un côté on s'en va de l'autre
côté avec notre roi à nous et il y a pas
de moyen de progresser quand le fou s'en
va on chasse la tour et ensuite on s'en
va avec le ça c'est le moyen le d'accord
non non c'est pas filid d'or filid d'or
c'est le gain non non non non cette
nulte un nom mais pour bien cl comment
t'expliquer euh filor c'est cette
position c'est si on décale tout c'est
ce que j'étais en train de faire si on
fait n'importe quoi et on se retrouve
ici euh
for en gros alors bon là ça sera math
mais
euh pil d'Ar c'est ça ou
pas filidor c'est ça
ouais c'est ça je suis désolée j'ai je
vais bouger pendant juste 2 secondes
j'ai mon chat qui me demande absolument
à bien sûr vas-y vas-y désolé vas-y
vas-y vas-y ah non mais alors cette
méthode nul comment elle s'appelle par
clage c'est horrible de pas avoir de
mémoire
tuux dites-moi dans le chat ouvrez un
livre de
finale pendant que je
demande
si on fait bien 3è peu importe
ou peuorte
pourquoi donc ça va durer longtemps ça
sera instructif ça prend du
temps d'amener le roi au bord de les
chiquier
mais normalement c'est forcé et ensuite
c'est au blanc à propos de
connaître j'ai quand même
googlé r Bishop
against
Bishop draw
méthode
cocrane voilà c'est la défense de
cocran la défense que je vous ai
montré le problème évidemment c'est
queil y a aucune raison que les les
Blancs jouent moins que 105
coups ah mais si la Serbie perd pas en
revanche alors on va faire popo je vous
la laisse sur le petit échiquier qui
s'est pas
rafraîchi il s'est rafraîchi on va
regarder le match de la
Serbie si la Serbie perd
pas donc
Serbie de finales de tour avec de pions
de moin enfin avec deux fois un pion de
MO ici ça serait match
nul
ça me saute pas aux yeux mais on fait
confiance à
l'ordi l'autre elle a l'air plus
compromise l' plus simple quand
même on a on a les Noirs
ici on
a on a les noirs on a un P de plus aussi
mais c'est
chaud
c'est chaud ça ça ça c'est est-ce que
est-ce que c'est évident que c'est
perdant ça doit perdre mais bon pas
évident alors elle a joué
ro6
bon même làdus c'est quoi ce tour
f43 peut-être reprends F2 surend F2
quand même B ça revient plus ou moins
même
quoi de for
men menace échec donc il faut bouger la
tour bon un truc comme ça c'est vrai que
on a de
pions ou un moment tu sacrifieras
peut-être ton P au pire contre le P C
mais tuuras les pion qui ser hyper
avancés
ok donc c'est chaud chaud chaud
cette position leur dit donne plus
1 plus 1 c'est con flip on rappelle
qu'on veut que la Serbie
perde mais je v quand même demander
est-ce qu'on veut
vraiment ben oui non on veut mais est-ce
que c'est si elles font match nul les
ser elles sont 3è c'est sûr ou pas non
je pense pas parce que vraiment au
départage c'est pas attends juste au
départage les Serb son un 136,5 et nous
on a 147 et demi donc elles ont gagné un
match donc elles prennent 13 points
c'est
ça c'est ça he si j'ai bien compris
ilells ont gagné une partie et ils ont
fait deux match
nuls bah si ça fait deux points tu
gagnes tu fais deux fois les points de
ton adversaire
ça fait plus 26 13 ça fait 26
ouais de ce donc nous on a mais non mais
nous on a 176 sont 136 et demi ça ell
peuvent pas faire plus 40 points les
filles il s'est passé une série de cous
rouges d'après d'après l'ordi c'est que
des coups rouges ça
oui mais ça c'est pas je pense c'est pas
ou ah mais elle peut pas répéter la
position elle peut plus rejouer
au6
ouais et c'était quoi qu'il fallait
jouer
F7 ah oui mais c'est c'est dommage quand
même si on peut plus jouer ro 6 c'est
très
dommage est-ce qu'elle peux jouer roi D6
non roi des 6 aussi n'est plus possible
ouais c'est qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette répétition roi
E5 et roi7 peut-être ro7 ro mais a prise
on peut pas prendre avant à chaque fois
on perdait le pion mais ah si on peut
jouer F7 c'est peut-être pas si
grave mais c'est tellement
bizarre
jou prend des 5 là et on a perdu un
tempo net sur toutes les variantes mais
ok
on dit Serbie est out donc en fait on
s'en F6 et demi ou 136 et demi 176 ok
c'est surtout les les joueuses les
équipes qui sont à 10 points qu'il faut
regarder qui pourrait rattraper la
France et notamment les matchs avec un
gros
écart alors qui on
a
Germanie P a gagné on naime pas gaz
gagner on aime pas de gros écart si
victoire il y a ça sera d'un
point9 l'Allemagne elles sont à 141 on
est à 176 la Georgie elles sont à 143
par contre ça se regarde si elle
gagne si elles font
deux la Georgie ça fait quoi
ah ah bah oui
oui la Georgie pourquoi elle pourrait
pas
elle pourrait oui surtout si elles font
ça fait quoi 2,5i x 14 2,5 x 14 si gagne
dans
match euh
ouais qui fait mathématiquement beaucoup
2,5 x 14 ça fait 35 plus
143 ce qui fait 178 et c'est là qu'on
voit l'importance du match nul de de DD
parce que son match nul ça partie nul ça
nous fait combien si ça nous fait si on
a un demi ou un point
sur et donc en fait on serait juste
devant de quelques points c'est ça euh
bah si on fait un match nul on fait un
match nul contre une équipe qui a
10 ça fait 5 points ça fait 5 points
donc ça veut dire qu'on serait à 181 et
tu avais dit
ouais facile
ouais donc pour l'instant le podium se
confirme non pour l'instant oui ok
allons voir les autres
matchs les autres résultats qui pourrai
nous ah les la gaffe attends attends
attends attends les la gaffe qu'est-ce
qu'elle s'est
prise je comprends mais quoi pourquoi il
y a a tout en prise tour de parce
qu'elle mat sur la première sur 8e
ouais mais c'était c'était concept ce
truc et donc ici c'est toujours ça raté
c'est toujours
ça c'est bon je je comprends il me faut
du temps cette ci euh non
mais attends dis-moi en fait là ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est qu'on
est pas sur du de de la première place
encore après ce coup on ne sait pas si
la Georgie ne bat pas s'il y a un match
nul entre la Bulgarie la geéorgie et que
l'Azerbaïdjan gagne c'est peut-être les
azéries je sais
pas à moins que la Bulgarie par un match
nul grâce à leur départage s'assure
quand même la la première place wou
quelle casse-tête non non c'est quelle
cassette non c'est alors popo combien de
coups 67 ça fait 12 coups
et l'ukrainien n'a pas tant progressé
que ça non le roi est toujours pas sur
la
bande il y a des grands Maes
spécialistes de ça il y a un grand
maître anglais c'est peut-être
Arkel qui a fait JIR un truc il l'a eu
15 fois et à chaque fois qu'il lu t fou
il a toujours gagné peut-être 10 fois et
à chaque fois qu'il a défendu il a fait
toujours nul et c'est c'est c'est son
GaInP tu vois
il il s'est nourri il a payé son son
loyer en jouant tourf contre
tour donc d'ailleurs je crains plus
enfin je crains je crains tout le monde
moi mais je crains plus un grand maître
moyen entre guillemets qui aurait bien
bossé cette finale comme Arkel que un
super grand maître qui a pas forcément
bien bossé genre
un sler qui est pas connu pour bien bien
connaître ses final il est sûrement
moins fort qu'un grand maître lambda qui
qu'il a beaucoup
travaillé même d'ailleurs que n'importe
qui qu'il a beaucoup
travaillé je pense que c'est une finale
si vraiment on a beaucoup de temps à y
consacrer on peut la maîtriser parfait
enfin très très bien parfaitement non
très très bien il y a un petit
changement dans le match
Serbie azerbaïjan hm
hm
voilà donc maintenant on a les les
Azéris qui euh qui dominent sur les deux
derniers sur les deux échiquers restants
ok donc ça ça a l'air bien gagnant
maintenant parce que la tour va devoir
défendre le pion C4 d'une mauvaise
manière si la Tour Blanche était
derrière le pion ça irait mais là avec
la tour devant le roi va servir de ses
propres pions pour se cacher et ça va
gagner tout seul ouais ouais à nouveau
le paraplui euh
[Musique]
ok c'est à priori la Servie on avait dit
que elle était out
mais mais bon
ok et ben retournons chez chez popo
[Musique]
voyons c'est 31
voyons comment défendre donc ici ouais
on joue qu'est-ce qu'on
joue je ben popo arrive à couper le roi
coupe le roi ouais
ouais alors je prère avoir le pardon en
7 ouais ouais pourquoi parce que là
l'idée des blancs c'est de jouer ça ça
et de pouvoir couper donc c'est on veut
le roi comme on a c'estune fois que tu
joues ça si tu mets leant E7 tu retombes
sur ta position de C que j'ai lu ce que
je
disais là ce qui est marrant c'est que
pour l'ordi tous les coups sont
équivalents si jouent ça avec les Blancs
c'est pareil que de jou ça c'est pareil
que te torturer pour c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que c'est difficile il a
travaillé c'est final parce que tu peux
pas te défendre contre
l'ordi ça
elle tu joues contre l'ordi donne la
tour et tu oui mais alors mon adversaire
a priori ne va pas me donner ma tour ça
tout euh donc tour D1 fou
D5 on peut pas assaillir le roi
d'échec on peut faire des petites éches
oui il va jouer roi des qu et oui c'est
ça le truc et c'est pour ça que quand on
commence à faire les échecs
euh on préfère avoir bon là on pourrait
jouer ça maaintenant
tuas
et c'est marant il voit ça comme une
amélioration ouais
alors c'est bizarre il doit être à
faible profondeur
ou ben je sais pas
mais
de toute façon c'est c'est nul
mais l'Étap de finale elles peuvent
vraiment te tout
donner bon pendant
qu'on qu'on dit dans l'oreillette que ça
ça se
confirmerait alors le roi est passé par
là c'est c'est toujours difficile
d'ailleurs quand tu as les mêmes
positions que tu connais mais tout d'un
coup les chquier renverse tu sais au
lieu d'avoir le roi ici tu as le roi là
et tout d'un coup c'est oui c'est dur
ouais tu dis oh là attends devrais juste
tourner les chiier
bouger ta chaise oui c'est ça mais tu
sais on me l'a déjà fait hein
euh comment il s'appelle ce Paul Valten
en
rapide c'est un rapide je sais plus
dernière ronde ça jou pour le prix ouis
bon bref peu importe et et la roi
cavalier fou contre roi j'ai plus que le
roi et mais c'était c'était la position
classique mais avec le roi qui monte sur
la colonne h au lieu de de faire ça sur
la 8e rangée et du coup il s'est tourné
il s'est levé physiquement alors que tu
avait tous les spectateurs qui
regardaient il s'est levé pour faire
pour regarder les chiquers de Bill quoi
à 90°gr et bon on était on a bien rigolé
quoi bon il a fini par trouver et et
j'ai perdu mais bon whatever alors ce
qui est bien c'est que je crois pas que
le laural popo est encore franchi un
bord franchi so aller sur un bord depuis
le
début non non il a pas encore touché de
bord depuis qu'on a cette finale
sors là peut-être donc là on est 55 75
donc 20 coups ont été joués il reste 30
coups à tenir donc pas donner la tour en
un moi je ferais plus ça mais mais c'est
je veux faire la défense que Lordi
n'aime pas c'est marrant
mais qu'est-ce qu' joue ce con il joue
ça mais il aime pas en fait il aime pas
ses coups non plus alors bon c'est
bizarre en fait ça dépend uniquement de
la profondeur en fait c'est ça le secret
c'est quand on le laisse réfléchir il
arrive à profondeur 35 et il met égal 00
quand on joue un coup tout de suite il a
profondeur 20 là et du coup il donne
avantage
c'est juste ça alors popo jouer tour des
deux qui change pas puisque ça la nature
cette
position5 leou ou fou en parapluie roi
D6 pour essayer de jouer tour tour B8
échec pousser le roi sur le bord de
l'iqu mais après roi D6 peut juste jouer
roi B4 peut-être
popo alors excuse-moi j'étais roi des6
tu
disais4 juste B4 à
nouveau sur tour C4
échec on peut même jouer sur tour C4
échec ro B3
sereinement tu es joueuse tu es joueuse
on peut on peut mais me fais pas ça me
fais pas ça s'il te plaît c'est quand
même pas
c'est ce qui a été joué ouais alors pas
encore j'espère T c qu échecs non ça va
tomber
échec là on peut faire ça parce que là
on se fait pas mat ni découvert je pense
même qu'on peut remonter en en D4 sur
tour
B3 comment ça roi des4 possible ah oui
roi C3 tour B3 roi D4
et bon tu pourras jamais mater
ouais ah non mais je voulais faire un
truc mais j'arrive
pas toute ma
vie toute ma
vie j'arrive vraiment pas comment je
peux faire mon mon truc qui sert
strictement à rien c'était juste pour
non il y aura pas de Matt en plein
milieu Desch non je vais faire ça je va
faire un P ah tu V faire un P d'accord
je vois pas que les MATD je vois aussi
les
dès que c'est aidé Mo je suis là
attends zirac nous dit que c'est encore
pire que ce qu'on croyait bonjour il est
extrêmement difficile d'anticiper le
départage car il s'agit d'un sunborn
burger
tronqué il faut donc exure du calcul
l'équipeadvers en marquer le moins de
points et cela peut changer avec la
dernière partie du
tournoi actuellement pour la France il
faut exclure l'Estonie du calcul mais si
l'Estonie gagne et que l'Angleterre ou
l'Espagne perd alors c'est l'Angleterre
ou l'Espagne qu'il faut exclure du
calcul et cela vaut pour toutes les
équipes oh là là prendre en
considération les résultats de chaque
adversaire une victoire de l'Angleterre
de de l'Arménie avantage grandement la
France étant donné les Scor fleuve je
crois que l'Espagne est en train de
gagner l'Angleterre peut-être aussi et
l'armonie aussi
euh c'est trop compliqué
ok donc plus compliqué que que ce qu'on
croyait non Arménie va perdre contre la
Pologne mais
l'Espagne devrait gagner contre la
Roumanie
et Where Is
England et je sais pas où est passé
l'Angleterre on dire qu'on
c'est et l'Angleterre a battu
la Suisse non la Suède la Suède ok alors
choise a l'air ultra confiante pas 100 %
à 300%
seulement
300 la la directrice l'ancienne
directrice générale de la F de la FID de
la
f je t'ai pris
choise bon 80e coup bon dans tous les
cas un match nul ça peut aussi garantir
une médaille d'or au 4e éiqu pour popo
si on fait médaille de bronze médaille
d'or évidemment il y aura beaucoup de
regrets mais ça reste un résultat
descend faut rappeler que l'équipe de
France était tête de série numéro 6 7
6 6 ouais 6 6e équipe ou derrière ouis
donc c'est un super résultat donc tête
de série numéro
en tout cas le roi de Poline a fait un
beau tour de l'É chiquier et pendant
qu'on nous dit juste popo on te met en
pause popo pause pour aller checker la
dernière
partie qui viendrait de se terminer
Laurent Fressin W
waouh well done bravo Laurent voilà bon
c'était un peu annoncé avec sa qualité
de plus mais a toujours là technique
assez sympa et donc l'équipe de France
mixte finit par un match
nul tandis que notre équipe féminine si
j'arrive à revenir va finir sur une
défaite qu'on espère sur le score de 3 à
c'est bon
popo refait la même chose
qu'avant jokova a du mal à je crois son
toujours pas touché le
bord onait qu'elle est dans une
[Musique]
piscine non il faut pas toucher le B
c'est docteur Mabou faut surtout pas
toucher les bord sinon
tu doctur mou dit par une docteuresse à
une autre docturesse d'accord ça envoie
des çaie des cade entre docteurs
ok en tout cas elle a bien compris les
règles et ben là si tu as envie de jouer
je pense que tu peux même jouer roi
arrête avec ton j'en
Mar c'estas tellement le tellement large
quoi roi1 roi E1 roi D2
et encore 23 cou 23 coup à tenir on est
au
82e c'est le S
5è après tu sais que j'ai récemment fait
ma partie la la la plus longue de de ma
vie ma partie classique 123 coup combien
de coups 123 coups ouais et tu connais
le record de la partie la plus longue au
monde en classique euh
ouais j'ai vu il il y a un site am crabé
le site de Tim Krab qui recessens ses
record peut-être ça été battu en tout
cas le c'est dans les 250 faut aller
voir sur crab c'était peut-être un
ancien record parce qu'il aimit plus son
site à jour et ah moi je torture les
jeunes mais non c'était moi qui défendé
j'avais plus qu'un
fou j'avais plus qu'un fou je je pas
pour le gars contre t reption je peux
dire j'ai fini par faire nul mais
c'était difficile
et et non le joueur le plus combatif
c'est de très loin
qui a genre une quinzaine de parties de
plus de 100 coups dont des parties 200 2
en c'est hallucinant
quoi lui torture ses
adversaires les tortur vraiment plein
qui craqu au final Ahou bien sûr bien il
a raison il a raison
ok donc ro C4 ro D2
j'imagine doit être
possible
toujours la même idée de bloquer le roi
empêcher le roi de de
rejoindre toujours quand vous voyez la
jauge comme ça c'est ce que j'expliqué
tout à l'heure c'est uniquement une
question de profondeur quand on lui
laisse le temps elle comprend que la
position est nulle VO là il y a une
menace de mat quand même mais de toute
façon c'est une menace qu'on est obligé
de parer peu importe ce qu'on
joue donc si on à deux coups de suite on
perd mais un coup chacune VO c'est vrai
qu'on est obligé de jouer quoi raison
peut pas ne pas parer la menace de mat
HM c'est
marrant
alors ah oui d'accord choise a fait son
tableau Excel où elle dit Estonie plus
mauvaise équipe c'est sûr bon bref
ouais donc est-ce qu'on peut dire avec
trè certitude
ah il y a jamais certitude avant que ça
soit offici à
99,9 % ouais oh la folie quelle
folie la folie la Georgienne yakajili
elle est
perdante la Bulgarie prend une grosse
option pour le
titre ah elle a mené toute la partie et
euh
euh h allons voir ça quand même une
partie où elle a complètement mené égale
et ensuite finalement craquage comme
quoi enfin moi je le répète je le dis
souvent faut pas abandonner trop vite
faut pas lâcher la faire trop
vite complètement fou cétait par là
ouais donc tour
2 ah bon là c'est toute façon c'est
tellement compliqué là tout peut se
[Musique]
passer qu'est-ce que c'est compliqué
cette position c'est
fou oh oh ah oui là c'est bien perdant
quand
même
ah c'est horrible tu as une dame de plus
pas pour
longtemps alors est-ce que c'est
vraiment
fini parce que ça il a pas de PERP du
coup et on est mat ici
on c'est par B2 h3as
plusche il y a pas de P pas de P pas
de quelle horreur du coup ça fait
Bulgarie champion
Bulgarie championne ou bu championne
Azer 2 France 3 ça serait mettons du
conditionnel tant que c'est pas officiel
le podium j'ai aussi une question à à
chois qui est F est-ce que popo sa
médaille est confirmé je sais pas
comment ça marche je sais même pas s'il
y en a en fait mais normalement il y en
a quand même des médailles
d'or je pense qu'on peut l'avoir sur
chesss
ouais chess results
ouais donc bord numéro 1 donc c'est
après la rende
donc on a pas les Françaises bord numéro
2 non bord numéro 3 avant cette ronde
Mitra était numéro 1 h mais la déf à
2568 Arab et einman à 200490 et 20441
donc peut-être que Mitra va pouvoir
garder sa médaille d'or Pauline Arab pas
joué sur classe de comment arabiz à pas
joué je crois aujourd'hui arabiz a pas
joué ouais Pauline bah elle survole
toutes les autres joueuses he perf à
200721 la seconde au bord numéro 4 fait
une perf à 2408 donc vraiment c'est
domination à plus total on va essayer de
perd bord numéro 5 Nastia avant cette
ronde était
3è ok Anastasia Savina donc peut-être
qu'on aura droit à TR médailles
ouais je sais pas si s'il y a des
médailles de bronze et d'argent
par en tout cas oua Mitra et Poline
possible je pense que j'aiab s jou lui
passe devant
tu crois c'est possible ça tu
perds tu perds
tu tu perds une Jose à 2300 ouais mais
tu perds une Jose à 2300 c'est ça coûte
cher
quoi sur seulement h par j'ai du mal à
croire sur seulement h
[Musique]
parties je sais
pas c'est c'est possible que non mais je
pense si c'est
pas forcément beaucoup moins ou beaucoup
plus alors 88e coup encore 15 à tenir
pour
popo on
rappelle le podium qui se dessine
Bulgarie championne
d'Europe
azerbaïjan vicechampionne
France 3e on touche du bois
ouais pour répondre à à ciel bleu
le je crois que j'ai acheté le CH
j'avais commencé j'ai même fait mais je
trouvais c'é un peu chip quand même pour
être franche j'étais pas totalement fan
je CIS que c'était
vraimentus donc
donc c'est cool mais en
fait il y a Magnus donc j'étais pas
ultraprs c'est juste possible qu'il a
pris qu'il a pris le nom de Magnus juste
ça d'aventre quoi ouais bah là pour le
cours che c'est Magnus était là enfin
j'avais pas les vidéos quand même mais
mais en fait c'était je sais pas c'était
il y a eu peu d'exemples alors peut-être
que le livre est plus complet
mais autant il y a vraiment beaucoup de
couressable que j'adore celui-là
j'éis ok c'est cool ça ça prend 2 heures
quoi je pas sûr d'avoir progressé mais
merci juste pour info le roi est est au
bord et il reste 15 coups à tenir h il y
avait un truc
c'était une partie je sais plus mais c
assez important de
Maxime contre peut-être yyangi mais bon
si c'est un autre joueur chinois ça ça
va être malheureux de se tromper et
Maxime faisait nul nul nul en si
fllottant il gaffe et en fait c'est pas
grave parce que il perdait sa tour pile
au 50e
mais c'est pile au 50e que oui non non
enfin c'est il jou coup et puis en fait
s'il joue un coup de plus c vraiment un
coup d'écart quoi et d'ailleurs à noter
il faut que les deux joueuse ici en
l'occurrence et jouer 50 coups pour que
la règle s'applique si si c'est 4 9 et
50 tu peux pas réclamer c'est 50 50 donc
c'est dire que faut Pauline elle joue
son coup et disent c'est 50 coups ouais
enfin d'ailleurs il faut pas le jouer il
faut comme pour la 3ème pour la
répétition il faut dire je vais jouer ça
ça va faire 50 coups chacune et du coup
c'est nul
hein donc zimirac dit euh par exemple
pour le départage la défaite de la
géorgienne fait perdre trois points de
départage à la
France mais possiblement fait perdre
aussi aux autres équipes qui ont joué la
Georgie donc ça changerait le le cours
de l'Histoire ah punaise je sais pas
zimirac c'est notre arbitre
défétiste mais donc faut compter cette
cette défaite de la Georgie pour toutes
les autres équipes ch dit que ça change
absolument rien ça change peut-être pas
le premier départage non ça change que
le de peut-être un autre départage mais
moi j'ai je comprends pas que ça j'ai
pas l'impression que ça change le
premier
départage Pauline peut perdre donc c'est
vraiment non enfin ouais non non non on
va quand même s petite
sécurité la ceinture en roulant à 10 kmh
on ne sait jamais si je dois l'avoir de
demain soir à Paris je préfère vraiment
qu'elle perde
pas
euh non non non il faut que la France
termine 3e que popo termine médaille
d'or au 4e et chiquier gagne plein de
points
ho on voulait encore mieux on voulait
deux médailles d'or par chiquier on
voulait une médaille d'or
par équipe mais bon on se contentera de
ce qu'on
a on va bientôt pouvoir commencer le
décomte s'entraîne pour la nouvelle
année ah Gill duumond maintenant que le
le roi est en A7 c'est pas nul
tranquille là c'est nul
évidemment2 c'est dans l'autre sens faut
que tu retournes les
ouais non non mais c'est c'est jamais
tranquille faut que tu retournesicé si
tu veux qu'on ait la vue côté
Poline ah oui le petit
piège c'est vrai qu'on est comme ça en
fait
hop si on fait quoi on fait
ça ça pour s'éloigner du du coin
ouais
bien que Paline
joue c'est pas si ça ça
ça puis ça on va
pouvoir alors il y a eu des coups tour
c'est vite
elle veut paraît
ça
donc elle veut ça
ça c'est ce qui se passe en s'attend un
roi3 même position non le roi é
en4 d'accord donc ro3 et là attention là
faut commencer à vraiment faire
attention avec 54 secondes à la pendule
mais l'intérêt d'avoir maintenant le
rang E3 c'est qu'on a plus la
possibilité de mettre le fou en
couverture par exemple F5 ou quelque
chose comme ça donc après ro H3 fou3 on
peut jouer ro H4 et les blanc ne peuvent
plus jouer roi fou F5 et roi F4 par
exemple ah je sais pas ça ça je tu vois
ce que je veux
dire là on doit pouvoir jouer r H4
j'imagine r
H3 bon c'est c'est chaud quoi on
transpire un petit peu ouais B c'est un
pe transpirer oui
je crois jouer tu as raison ouais c'est
c'est hyper tricky
HM euh ben les les joueurs ils ont ils
ont terminé donc on en a parlé on les a
regardé à moins évidemment vu qu'il ne
jouit plus pour le podium on sait pas à
quelle place il vont finir on va pas
tout calculer
euh mais
euh mais ils ont on fait match nul un
partout défaite de marquant victoire de
fraess match nul de Jules et
Étienne
voilà donc il reste 11 coup minimum pour
tenir pour ne pas se faire mater pour ne
pas perdre la
tour il y a plus que 11 coups à tenir 11
coups mais le roi est au bord de
l'chiquier ça commence à être vraiment
tricky tu as pu le montrer avec plein
d'exemples que ça peut devenir
dangereux et 50 secondes seulement pour
Pauline ouais non mais là ça ça fait pas
ouis je disais ça je disais ça
oua c'est chaud et donc par exemple
admettons ça pour faire des échecs ça
menace mat ça par la menace en écheac ça
ça ça très
tendu en fait y a qu'un seul coup
possible comme dit l'ordinateur il faut
il y a un seul coup possible pour
pouvoir contrer
voilà donc H3 a été joué donc peut-être
qu'on va transposer dans cette jouer
tourb jouer on joue tous les coups ou là
j'espère qu'elle va sentir le danger
parce que c'eston bah là là elle est
plus aussi sereine qu'avant avec la ro
au bord la mauvaise configuration ai
j'ai
jou3 ici ah non mais ça c'est là mais
surtout pas éche là ça ça perd de
l'autre côté ça
va 1 peutêtre que oui peut-être que ça
perd mais ça va quand même bien sûr il y
a on peut faire la spéciale mvl de de
gaffer mais en suffisamment de coup pour
que ça soit pas grave
ça
est-ce queil y a d' peut
jouer mais ça j'aimais pas parce que là
on peut plus faire la
maline non pas cette foisci pas cette
fois-ci donc obligé de faire H3 et
maintenant genre un coup comme ça tu
vois c'est c'est dur c'est très dur
idée raté idée d'aller
là parfois d'aller
là alors il y a eu des coup jouer on
joue tous les
coups on joue tous les
coups hyper méga gig
compliqué ch nous dit l'Allemagne a pas
gagné c'est la
cata
c'est-à-dire c'est plus du 300 % ah oui
300 c'était beaucoup quandme attends
c'est où ça j'ai pas
vu c'est un des derniers
messages
ma il n pas gagné
ok torb 4 jouis ça reste
nul
Reka donc elle prévient les tours G4
tour A4 avec menace très bien donc elle
a senti le
elle a vu les menaces elle a senti bah
c'est surtout que làdessus on a ça aussi
ou donc là les blancs doivent jouer un
coup est-ce qu'ils peuvent juste
attendre ouais truc c'est que si juste
ils attendent le tour G8 nous on attend
sur la 4e aussi
oui parfois il y a des histoires que
cette case et cette cas sont pas
totalement équivalentes quand le fou
s'en va et tout mais c'est pas vraiment
là
donc comment poser des problèmes ici je
ne sais
pas c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle que
j'ai pas
d'idée tout de
suite d'ailleurs je pense que la joueuse
ukrainienne non plus on est au 86e coup
plus que neu coups tour G5 G5 jou donc
on s'attend à tour à
4 est-ce que tour C4 est une erreur par
curiosité je ne pense pas ou est-ce que
c'est équivalent aussi oui donc on a un
peu de marge à l'ORS de manœuvre tant
mieux bah elle va jouer t à tour à 4 oui
logique oui voilà c'est marrant com on
arrive à prvoir tous les coups alors
qu'en fait tout fait nul mais on arrive
à prvoir tous les cous mais c'est d'ut
allez plus que coup à
tenir moi je suis unqu du dernier
message de chis là l'Allemagne pers la
cata ou je sais pas quoi
ouais tu peux nous dire quelles sont les
les conséquences
de de la non victoire de l'Allemagne je
pense l'Allemagne a dû faire match
nul et qu'est-ce que ça
change est- est-ce qu'on est certaine
que du coup nul c'est bon
parce que c'est c'est l'Allemagne c'est
quoi c'est parce que nous on les avait
joué du coup on perd des points je
comprendsi
ah Allemagne ok Suisse adversaire de
l'Ukraine donc ça serait ce serait
tellement terrible que
l'Ukraine passe devant les les française
ça ça aurait alors attends ser Affre il
y a
eu des petits changements
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut sur
échec pas certaine de comprendre
ouais les Ch ça l'air fort
elle joue juste trop MC oh là là quel
stress quel stress
popo on la connaît depuis longtemps
c'est ah là là
c'est c'est vraiment spécial quand c'est
des amis proches comme ça qui jouent
pour un enfin un titre une médaille si
importante
ouais c'est ça je vais je vais vite je
finer mon truc je
je mange une soupe et puis et puis
ensuite yoga
méditation
Amam jacuzzi dans mon
appart
alors que si coup à
jouer l' est maintenant en H4 est-ce que
c'est bien je vois pas trop d'échec
possible parce que avec la tour ici
là non mais surtout tu as pas le temps
je pense de monter un réseau de mat avec
les Blancs le roi il est en train
de tu peux pas rapprocher le RO en
plus peux faire ça ça
ça
ok ce qui perdrait
mais pas forcément de manière grave sa
version mais là tu peux peut-être
rejouer tour F4 et tour F8 à nouveau un
truc dans le genre est-ce que c'est
possible est-ce que je vais perdre ma
partie en de coup ou pas ça serait pas
de chance
mais si on on est sur du 105 parce que
ça oui donc c'est ça si on joue juste si
on laisse les blancs faire leur plan
est-ce que c'est si grave que
ça on peut
s'échapper tu
peux alors il a des coup des
coup bouger okage 3
facileé amélioration de la
part de coup
possible c'estér et làdessus un seul
coup on peut faire éche de seul coup non
je pense c'est mieux de jouer tour B4
par que finalement tu répètes la
position sans un
coup bon
allez la camme de Natacha a besoin d'un
petit réglage ah je sais pas ouais c'est
les réglag on non mais ça va moi je te
vois c'est mais
que c'est un
peu non c'est qu'en fait j'ai je me suis
déconnectée sans
faire j'ai un problème de déconnexion
est-ce que c'est un peu
plus non non non mais c'est bon laisse
lae laisse lae t'inquiète c'est parfait
je pas toucher regarde juste juste ça
doit être aussi peut-être un problème de
alors menace quand
même parce que là on papote on papote
mais il a une menace
de chose nous enlever le suspense
ouais mais non non là il y a du suspense
parce que regarde m de mattend de on jou
un coup d'attente on est mat et là c'est
horrible parce que ça regarde ça serait
le coup 105e coup c'est nul et ça 104
coup mat mais tu sa c'est quoi l'horreur
c'est si par exemple joue elle était mat
apparemment B va
voir
comment en train de N spoiler
total ça devrait être
interdit non mais donc tu confirmes la
France 3e ou pas attends genre elle elle
est revenue elle s'est pris
ça non mais ça c'est mais non parce que
ça c'est mat trop trop proche c'est 104
ça marche pas elle devait se faire
matter au 4e au 107e ou un truc comme ça
peut-être attends mais oui c'est le
tempo qui manque on est ici
ouais on est ici on est ici attends
attends attends priorité au direct avec
15 minutes de de délai on est ici si on
joue tour B3 on est
ma mais on est math c'était attends
c'était quel 55e coup parce qu'on a le
550 55e coup c'est tour prend le5 de de
qui des blancs c'est les blancs donc les
Noirs
les les Noirs au 104e c'est bon 104e
c'est bon pour les Noirs mais non parce
qu'il y a une prise de pion au au 55e
oui mais tu joues 55e ça fait 1 mais les
Noirs ils jouent leur premier coup c'est
le c'est CP du coup les blancs c'est 105
les Noirs 104 non j'ai dis n'importe
quoi ben non les Noirs c'est 104 c'est
105 parce qu'à partir de tour prend E5
tu repars de de de 1 et un coup joué
c'est blanc et noir donc les blancs ils
jouent tour prend E5 et noir tu joue
tour prend le 5 ça fait un coup quand tu
joues leur coup ça fait un coup non je
veux dire un coup quand tu commences une
partie d'échec blanc noir ça fait un
coup ouais
oui c'est ça la nul pe être réclamer
après le 105e coup de blanc tu as pas
besoin tu es pas obligé de jouer ton ton
ton 105e avec les Noirs donc en fait ça
allit mais de toute façon pas de souci
ici a priori elle se fait à part si tu
joues ça quoi non justement là tu peux
réclamer tu peux réclamer tu dis tu peux
même dire je vais jouer ça
mon dis pas ça
mais euh et oui mais c'est là en fait
mat Pauline a réclamé tu crois non mais
attends mais c'est pour ça que parce que
elle est mat là où il y a un coup elle
est mat là c'est mat
non ça m forcé là et donc mais a joué
oui mais elles sont fouté je pense
pardon désolé non elle s'en foutait pas
du
tout ah mais elle a joué un coup en mode
Z not de de l'espace non là en fait faut
surtout pas jouer c'est si tu joues un
coup tu as perdu et donc là elle non si
tu joues un coup tu as perdu si tu joues
un coup tu as perdu si tu écris ton coup
que tuappelles l'arbitre que tu dis je
vais jouer ro H2 ça fait match nul parce
que ça fait pile c'est exactement pour
ça que j'ai vérifié c'est c'est 50 coup
noirs le coup blanc les blancs viennent
de rejouer les Noirs avaient joué le 50e
ici non les Noirs ont joué 49 coups là
ça fait 50 blanc et si tu dis ça ça fait
le 50e mais ce problème c'est que si tu
le dis pas mais que tu le joues tu es
mat tout de suite il
plus il a plus de cou ah c'est hyper
méga chaud en fait donc il faut
connaître le règlement il faut connaître
le règlement ah ouais c'est si tu parce
que si tu te trompes et que tu réclames
mal jouer madame et puis cord tu joues
là c'est génial elle a réussi à faire sa
gaffe mais donc là le coup c'était tour
non parce que ici il y avait ça en fait
elle a choisi la piire case ah non mais
elle avais pas le choix ici tour B4 si
tu avais le choix ici et ça ça
va d'accord et sauf que là elle a choisi
la la pierre case parce qu' le fou qui
contrôle par fou qui contrôle et du coup
là tu mat
W là ça va réclamer en plus ah je peux
te dire imagine le méga stress c'est oh
là là punaise c'est pour ça tu veux au
demi coup près au demi coup
près que
l'histoire non mais il y a pas t ici ici
c'est en prise non il faut surtout pas
jouer c'est en fait prise une prise tu
repars sur 50 coups c'est
soit de
troll donc alors tant que c'est pas
officiel moi je vois pas la nul he c'est
peut-être ça négocie peut-être qu'il y a
une réclamation des
ukrainiennes j'aurais bien voulu voir
les images et voir ce qui est en train
de se passerarbitre doit être en train
de compter les coups il d' dû demander à
son arbitre chef qui demandait à son
arbitre surf oui parce que en plus les
arbitres moi j'ai à part quelquesuns
quelquesunes qu'on aime bien mais sinon
j'ai très mauvaise à priori sur les
arbitres en général combien de fois on a
vu des d'arbitrage nul
officiel donc est-ce que c'est certain à
N officiel qui n
officiel ok j'avais vu nul s'afficher et
là ça a disparu alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on refait ça si je fait
watch très
bizarre
woman non vous voyez ou pas mais les
chiquier n'est toujours pas considéré
comme terminé il y a la réclamation donc
c'est si on compte
bien dernière capture
ici 55 blanc donc ce qui veut dire quand
les blancs ont joué leur 105e ça fait 50
coups
blancs et les noirs on jouer
e il les noir on va jouer notre 50e donc
je sais pas ce qu'elle a choisi
elle va jouer son 105e ça fait 50 sauf
tout reprend EU2 sauf tout reprend2
oui oui bien sûr
sur surtout pas reprend de àab je vais
jouer avec en plusvec en plus son
anglais que j'adore popo Love
You donc elle a dit
l'arbitre ah
là je pense qu'elle a
dit R
Mo and
is my poo c'est
hor popo alors mais c'est je suis en
panique en fait tant que c'est tant que
je vois pas nul France 3e je vais être
en panique en plus ce qui est affreux
c'est que ok le truc c'est qu'il faut
qu'on attende que le classement soit mis
à jour pour être sûr à 4500 % que c'est
ok mais m si je fais confiance à donc
nul officiellement bravo popo donc c'est
ouf en fait on était parti on moi
j'étais déftist parti je croyais au 4-0
presque et fin on éta parti victorieuse
on parti on championne d'Europe je ve
dire en milieu de en milieu de de match
en milieu de match des Français éta
moins bien sur tous les
échiquersim on a cru au 4-0 et 4-0 ça
aurait été ça aurait été catastrophique
parce que Ben l'Ukraine
serait passé devant les françaises
auraient pris la troisème place du
podium et donc là grâce à une
défense héroïque de Démé grâce à une
défense héroïque de Pauline héroïque et
miraculeuse on va pas on va pas
oublier ou mais c'est sans enlever
vraiment aucun mérite à nos championnes
c'est il a fallu que la pièce qui était
en l'air ou les pièces qui étaient en
l'air retombent du bon côté mais vas-y
je te laisse
conclure non mais en fait c'est juste ok
mati nous a dit que la France était 3è
est-ce qu'on est sûr et certaine que la
France l'équipe de France féminine
d'échec a la médaille de Bron au
championnat d'Europe est-ce à combien de
pourcent on est sûr ouais ouais ouais
parce quee si je
tape test result n'est pas à jour test
result n'est pas à jour je suis en train
de refresh depuis tout à l'heure ça ne
bouge
pas h bon ça ça pas à
jour jeouv au
chat alors est-ce qu'il reste en même
temps il reste des parties oua il reste
des parties plus beaucoup de
parties qu'est-ce que c'est dépche-v de
finir il va où
non mais c'est une blague propose nul
Dra hop on en parle plus c'est bien
allez non non dégage-moi ça euh je crois
que tous les échiqués sont
terminés est-ce
que on peut affirmer à plus de
99,999 % que la France est
3e
alors sur sur le site de sur.com la
France est
4e mais il met tbreak trop bizarre c'est
quoi c'est quoi ce
tbreak après je suis pas sûr que ce soit
les bons
départages donc t no merci nous dit à
France et 4e sur TS 24 si 4e ah quelle
horreur non non non j'y crois pas ah non
fait pas ça crois pas j'y crois pas
ouais cette ch résolle ce qu' fait
fois
ouais et pour le moment on n pas encore
le résultat donc c'est vrai qu'on est
en est-ce qu'on a des information sur
les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que je sais pas est-ce
que sur X ou quoi que ce soit est-ce que
la Fédération
aurait aurait mis quelque chose est-ce
qu'on a du nouveau est-ce qu'on peut
savoir s'il vous plaît
please
dites-nous une confirmation
officielle je vois
rien ça serait vraiment le scénario
atroce que
c'est un sprint là
non je rien deux sont côte à côte mais
tu attends que mais c'est c'est quoi
ce mais c'est pas le bon je vois 23 22
et demi 23 et dem c'est pas ça
sur tu vois bien que
sur TB2 TB3 c'est ça
le c'est pas le même départage
ouais ils ont mis
le
sur Chess.com c'est le TB3 je sais pas
si vous voyez mais sur.com c'est c'est C
colonn qu'ils ont mis en premier
départage alors qu'en fait c'est 7
colonnes qu' fa
mett on va rester avec vous jusqu'à 23h
on va attendre d'avoir les résultats
mais c'est pas parce que c'est pas les
points de partie c'est c'est le berger
tronqué tout ça tout ça
ouais c'est un truc assez bizarre qui
compte tu as personne dans
l'oreilletteocha ben
non je sais pas
si je pourrais appeler popo mais je sais
même pas si elle
sait je vais envoyer un message
à
pense que eux-mêmes ne doivent pas
savoir non
elle nous a elle nous fait vraiment
vibrer cette équipe de France je trouve
ça juste
génial j'ai envoyé un message à popo
mais je pense il y a peu de réponse il y
a peu de réponse par qu'il y a peu de
chance qu'elle réponde parce qu'elle a
pas le
téléphone je sais pas à quel point elle
est loin de l'hôtel ou pas mais doivent
être ensemble
alors bon
ok euh il le bleu qui nous fa une
citation
ouais non ah
non non ciel bleu non stop
bon allez chess RS c'est fou mais donc
je comprends pas et sur Chise 24 ça sera
le
même le même faux de partage ou
pas je
pense alors en plus si la compétition
est terminée bon courage pour trouver
sur chzon 4
F al attend comment donc les filles ont
terminé toutes leur parti hein c'est ça
ouais donc a priori mais je crois que je
crois qu'on aura pas les départages
affichés enfin c'est galère je sais pas
si tu te rappelles les autres
compétitions c'était
souvent juste un peu avant la remise des
prix que tu avais les départages ah mais
là c'est pas c'est c'est pas le tournoi
de de
DD 608 quoi
c'est non mais il me semble il me semble
que c'était c'était jamais trop trop sûr
enfin c'était pas immédiat quoi tu
devais je sais pas ce qu'ils font
mais estce qu'on a une annonce de la
Fédération
ah mais ils mettent le même
départage il même le ils mettent le
départage qui n'est pas le départage de
donc d'après ce que vous voyz VO pas
mais d'après chess results le départage
utilisé par Chess.com et chess24 n'est
pas le
bon alors Matthieu qui nous dit les
adversaires des Français ont gagné leur
match et avec la France est devant de
base après faut
voir donc Mathieu ne saurait pas non
plus ce qui s'est passé quoi personne ne
sa
quelle
horreur donc là on est il y a toujours
pas de certitude à 100 % on est sur du
déjà a priori du a priori
oh c'est pas possible de laisser du
suspense comme ça c'est horrible il est
où le le site
officiel site official il sera
là il y a un truc
normalement on peut connaître rules on
va commencer par
ça TC TC touc
ouais donc le premier départage ce n'est
pas bonne nouvelle ce n'est pas le
départage de chess 24
et.com cool le premier des partages
c'est bien le sunborn
berger avec
euh le plus mauvais
exclu non c'est pas ça du tout qu'est-ce
qu'il dit
c'est ça si si c'est exactement ça donc
c'est bien chess RESOL qui a
raison c'est bien
Chess.com
Eton 4 on tort zimera qui nous dit 207
pour l'Ukraine 210 pour la France donc
l'Ukraine n'est pas devant la France
après il faut
calculer Grèce et
Pologne gr es ont pas fait un score de
ouf je crois
[Musique]
ouais pas si loin non plus tu vois genre
l'Ukraine elle était là quoi
vous voyez pas mais toi tu VO donc
l'Ukraine était 10e et la Grèce était 5e
non toi tu vois les autres pas
rgl la grèissce a fait a gagné que 2 et
demi à 1 et demi contre la
Slovénie faut tout calculer et jou
contre la Slovénie la Slovénie qui était
qui avait 9
points serait tellement at TR parce que
on a joué pardon vas-y fini vas-y vas-y
je t'en prie je t'en prie non en tête de
série donc nous on est tête de série
numéro 6 on a joué 1 2 3 4 5 7
9 donc un moment comment en ayant joué
toutes les meilleures tu peux tu peux
être derrière quelqu'un qui a exo en
nombre de points si quelqu'un marque
plus de points que toi tu es derrière
évidemment mais execo en ayant joué 1 2
3 4 5 7 9 en étant toimême 6 tu tu peux
pas faire mieux quoi c'est c'est c'est
pas possible de faire un meilleur
tournoi sans marquer plus de
points avec en
plus la nul de
popo au bout du suspense la nul miracle
de démter miraculeuse de
démter et juste pour reprendre juste
pour
information Bulgarie championne d'Europe
azerbaïjan vicechampionne d'Europe et la
France à
99,999 % en P
on pense mais on n pas de certitude
parce qu'il n'y a rien encore sur les
off on pense c'est c'est chaud tu vois
tu regardes ça là c'est écrit là les
gens les gens voient pas trop mais c'est
là c'est écrit France 3 France 3 Ukraine
lapsus Ukraine 3 France 4 sur ch 24
c'est écrit
Ukraine 3 France
4 sur chess re le site qui fait plus
fois c'est rien écrit et nous on est là
à dire non mais c'est bon faites-nous
confiance
euh on est 3e parce que bleu blanc
rouge
mais bon bon sin est-ce qu'on attend un
potentiel résultat peut-être qui va
sortir avant 21h30 ou
22h je pense qu'on en saura pas plus
avant je vois toujours rien sur les
réseaux sociaux mais normalement trois
hein normalement trois
mais on a eu le message de popo qui nous
a bien confirmé ce qui s'est passé hein
à savoir ça récllamation pile au 50e et
euh donc un un coup du mat peut-être je
vais je vais laisser ça comme ça là ça
vous voyez mais he pour rappel s' y en a
qui en route pourquoi en se r d'échec on
ne commande pas des
échecs au 55e coup qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé 55e coup de cette partie c'était
il y a bien longtemps c'était une autre
vie t prend5 jouer
50 coups plus tard plutôt 50 coups
blancs et 49 coup noir plus tard les
blancs sont gagnants
vont soit gagner la tour soit faire
faire mat au prochain le Matth est
imparable si ce n'est par tour C4 qui
perd la
tour et donc là si on joue un coup on
perd la partie il prennent elle prend la
tour ou elle fait mat et si on réclame
la nulle en disant B elle a joué tour
enfin elle a pas joué elle a écrit tour
C5 si elle réclame la nulle parce
qu'elle a fait c'est bien match nul ce
match nul au bout du bout dans une
position où c'est objectivement la leord
dit mais nul parce que c'est c'est match
nul si on rrclomme 50e mais sinon c'est
mat en un ou g de la tourant en un donc
en fait c'est totalement gagnant hein et
donc ce match nul sur le fil peut-être
que ça va apporter le quart de la moitié
de point de
départage pour assurer un podium qui
serait tellement
mérité tellement mérité ça serait
horrible de terminer à ailleurs que sur
ce podium dont on pouvait espérer encore
il y a quelques heures la plus haute
démarche
ah là là chess résol allez bosser les
arbitres un
peu bon on aura pas mieux hein je crois
on va pas attendre si les arbitres sont
partis manger j'ai déjà eu le coup
hein sérieux
mais pourquoi il y a pas les
appareillement pour demain bah je sais
pas on mange oui mais nous on attend en
fait nous sommes des arbitres nous
sommes des êtres humains nous avons des
besoins
ouais si bleu je vais aller fêter ce
titre en écoutant enfin cetre ce podium
en écoutant un petit lar tiens çaend
sais je crois il me semble quand en
Slovénie les France la France avait fini
V championne d'Europe on avait pas eu
les résultats immédiatement c'était les
gars qui avent compte qui avait fait
tous les petits calculs ça me dit un
truc et c'était juste c'était peu de
temps avant la remise des prix que les
résultats avait été officialisé mais en
attendant on est allé manger et tout
donc je pense que ça va pas être
immédiatement mais 21h 20 la remise des
prix est pour pas très longtemps je
pense ça doit être vers 22h
21h30 donc mais c'est pas sûr qu'il
metent le site à jour ici là ah là là B
non mais il y a le repas bon
ok on parle là-dessus sur.com qui
affiche France 4 chass 24 qui affiche
France 4 mais nous on est là
oui oui France
3e France 3e je pense que
ouais j'ai envie
oui c'est affreux attends je fais un
petit tour sur
mais j'y suis j'y suis je regarde j'ai
même mis un petit mot qui demande de
l'aide allez je te je te
côte on veut
savoir
ouais je pense que on va attendre un peu
mais j'y crois aussi au 3è ouais mais on
veut pas de la croyance ça
oh c'est officiel non ah non c'est
pas non désolé ne fais jamais ça ça ne
va pas tuétais sur Twitter et j'ai vu la
France 3e mais c'était au championnat du
monde donc je
3è quoi vous avez terminé 3e du
championnat du monde non non tu étais
dans l'équipe oh c'était il y a 2 mois
déjà maintenant désolé mais oui la pass
jou à
Métro après les calculs nana confirme la
France est 3e du championnat du monde
qui s'est terminé en
septembre on est arrivé 3e en septembre
c'est bon les arbitres les arbitres ont
fait on fait le calcul
et 2 mois après ils ont mis à jour le
site c'est
bon dédicace à tous nos amis arbitres
évidemment
hein euh
ouais non mais Twitter
euh Twitter ne sert à rien de
façon son Twitter ça pas enfin ouais je
suis d'accord avec toi
il y a que quand on en a besoin
qui qui n'est pas là
aïe AE AE a a si vous avez des news on
prend on prend toutes les
informations
bon nou toujours rien
quoi 184 ça
fait de quoi tu parles
Mathieu de quoi tu
parles c'est de quoi dé partage de la
graisse ou
quoi 210 à
199 mais vous vous pouvez pas les voir
il faut faire les calculs à la main quoi
en fait vous pouvez aller voir sur chess
results le classement précédent et faire
les calculs à la main mais c'est pour ça
que d'habitude c'est les arbitres qui le
font hein c'est enfin c'est qu' le font
de manière automatique nous on n pas on
n pas de logiciel et pourquoi ils ont
pas lancé leur logiciel mais parce que
parce que c'est c'est l'heure du
repas chaque chose
l'ordinateur mange
aussi B faut croire mais pour l'instant
je regarde le match
nul sorti on y croyait plus à partir de
de G3 on y croyait plus
là je sais pas si tu es d'accord mais si
à 21h30 on a rien on arrête ça me va on
arrête ça me va j'ai ma soupe à aller
cuisiner
et moi j'ai raté mon sport ah mais tu as
plus transpiré ici qu'à la
salle mais grave euh donc il y avait un
match nul miraculeux après E5 moi je
peux le remonter parce que c'est
tellement beau ouais c'est très très
beau ou t pr 5 donc ça c la partie
démontée dans l Cornett tour pr 2 mat
menace un seul coup cavaliet B5
tellement facile à rater et après c'est
chaud par exemple dame D8 parce que la
dame attaqué faut protéger F6 prise
prise dame à 5 et tout peut arrivé ici
même une victoire
blanche mais donc après G3 on y croyait
plus
G3 donc le le seul autre coup pour parer
l'échec regarde te nous dit que elle
avait vu tout ça mais elle a oublié
l'idée d'amage 5 avec il avait oublié
ouais dommage ah ouais c'est dommage
parce que si tu dommage dommage tu
trouves d' machin tu joues ça
et et tu as toujours au moins perpète
quoi
et plus il affinité he l'ordi donne
ça
euh plus il ainité qui arrive le pion F
non attends surtout que la jouise
ukrainienne elle é en Z not hein déjà
mais ouais ouais non c'est ch il a moyen
de retourner la PO àond y de rourner
position pardon après ce qui entre
guillemets dans cette partie le en gros
il y aura pas de regret dans le sens où
finalement la Bulgarie a gagné son match
et l'Azerbaïjan a gagné son match donc
oui c'estàdire qu' gagant français en
gagnant son match on était 3e mais au
moins le calcul aurait été plus simple
on serait déjà en train de manger ma
chérie là c'est un peu plus
tendu il a fallu donc oui parce que j'ai
TR père et du coup là on y croit plus on
y croit plus du tout on s'attend même au
potentiel ouais a trouvé toutes les
chances pratiques
ouais même g il faut le jouer quand
même3 avec échec c'est chaud et donc la
tour G7 que donne l'ordi que donne
l'ordi il donne tour D1 désolé là c
HECI il donne ça
c'est pas si simple parce que y a il y a
des
échecs c'est c'est quoi la différence
non c'est pas d' F7 il joue roi
F8 bon ouais c'était en pratique ok
c'est avec 30 secondes par coup tour
ga sur tour àch après tu peux revenir
avec les tours les tours en G8 tu fais
plus mettre
oui oui oui je suis d'accord et donc
c'est s à combien de pourcentage la 3è
place tu disais à priori tes calculs
c'était
bon to donc qui est le mari de
Démé Matth
cornette champion de France 2016
mais cela ne nous regarde
pas des
inconnus le mar oh oui loui prends soin
de ta de ta petite ou c'est plus
important ah bah oui oui Prin de la
petite avec le son pauvre papa en train
en train de taper sur la
calculatrice
le classement n'est pas sorti ben il y a
2 minutes non non toujours pas non il ne
veut pas sortir on leur donne 2 minutes
de plus on a dit je pense qu'il doiv
être en train de revérifier toutes les
parties à la main aussi et donc Twitter
j'ai jeté une bouteille à la mer enfin
plutôt j'ai repris la tienne et je l'
relancé mais c'est pas allé plus loin
non
ouais mais moi non plus oua je pense
c'est fou quand même communication de
mais c'est c'est tu imagines ça dans un
autre sport la honte quoi quand même
pour les échecs quoi c'est si la
compétition n'est pas terminée je veux
bien ça ça peut
arriver on dit bon bah il y a des
parties encore en cours on peut pas mais
là il a plus de parti en cours depuis
une demi-heure maintenant tu imagine ça
15 minutes de délai quoi tu 15 oui en
plus il a 15 minutes de délai donc ça
fait TR qu4 d'heure que toutes les
parties sont
terminées et on sait pas pas imagine tu
vois le je sais pas je sais pas comment
ça marche dans les autres sports je la
regarde pas mais j'imagine que ça que ça
marche
mieux moi je regarde pas les autres
sports non pas je feris même pas en
nommer des autres je crois le dernier
match de de RBY que j'ai vu avec toi
c'est y a 15 ans à
Toulouse parce que tu m'avais
traîner j'ai vu tu as regardé aucun mat
de la Coupe du monde de rugby là
ouais non non non mais la coupe du monde
de foot avant non plus non j'ai pas
vu si j'étais un resto pour un match la
coupe du monde de foot mais du coup
j'étais face à la télé parce que sur les
tables il y a toujours tout le monde qui
veut se mettre du côté à la télé et MO
je de l'autre non non c'est vraiment ça
parfois j'ai j'ai regardé quand même des
matchs avec popo justement qui est fan
de du PSG et de l'équipe de France
France on a regardé des matchs mais si
j'ai pas une amie proche qui vibre moi
je m'en fiche tellement
que que ça m'intéresse pas et j'ai vu un
match comme ça tu sauras tout un match
au stade c'était pour l'anniversaire de
matache on est allé avir un match de la
Coupe du Monde de FO ah bah oui pardon
j'avais oublié que tu étais là ah oui
mais voilà c'est la seule fois je suis
allée au stade la seule fois jeis au
stade là
voilà bon ben 21h 30 toujours pas de
classement je suis
prête je ve dire je suis prête à
m'engager sur une 3è place de la France
mais et sinon sinon quoi aucune
certitude en fait ce qu'on disait c'est
que sur tus24 ou tus.com le poète
les le classement qui est mis il est pas
bon parce que oui non mais ça mais ça
aussi c'est quand même
extraordinaire ça c'est tu as deux sites
dans les échecs et sur les deux sites le
classement utilise un mauvais départage
alors que les règles sont écrites hein
mais
celuilà c'est c'est le
chat bon le CH donc sur les sites
officiel rien sur les sites officieux
mais sérieux chess24 et Chess.com c'est
pas le bon c'est pas le bon classement
c'est sur les
retransmissions les retransmissions ils
disent quoi ils ont dit quoi est-ce
qu'ils ont été capables de de mettre un
podium ou pas sur les commentair mais je
peux aller
[Musique]
sur c'est vrai que j'ai oublié ça ça
slack est-ce que il y a un
truc le slack de
l'entreprise
d'accord a rien
attends je
vais
mais oui c'est trop
long c'est trop trop long là
d'attendre on fait nos petites
recherches on se
renseigne
la dernière chance sinon ben faudra
attendre dit sur chess
results je pas cliquer France
3e large large large Ukraine 4e pour
rien donc si jamais je la je la remontre
si
jamais ici dans cette position où popo
était mat au prochain ou perdre de la
tour au prochain si jamais ça faisait un
demi coup de moins c'était terminé mais
parce que son 50e coup était bien le 50e
et pas le
49e on termine 3e et non pas 4e chaque
match
nul de chacune des joueuses de chacun
des matchs mat a servi à ce que la
France termine
3e au bout du suspense au bout du 50e
coup de la dernière partie au 105e coup
Pauline Guichard la meilleure buteuse et
médaille d'or au 4e échiquier a
apportter le demi-point décisif pour que
la France termine
3e de ce championnat d'Europe 2023 3e au
championnat du monde
avec toi dans l'équipe nana 3e au
championnat d'Europe sans toi dans
l'équipe
nana quelle belle équipe de France
évidemment c'est on peut même être déçu
un peu parce que la France a fait la
course en tête mais rappelons
6e au départ sur la liste de départ tête
de série numéro 6 cette équipe de France
il a fallu bien des
exploit individuel et collectif pour
arracher ce podium waouh
ouais c'est un résultat incroyable c'est
vraiment un résultat génial pour pour
les filles alors c'est vrai qu'on espéré
on a espéré les voir tout à fait en haut
mais cette troisième place ça reste je
sais je me rappelle même pas avant cette
année quand est-ce qu'on a on a fait un
aussi bon résultat quand est-ce qu'on a
autant vibrer avec avec l'équipe
féminine et et franchement merci
beaucoup merci à vous les les joueuses
merci à la capitaine au
sélectionneurs merci pour Ben pour tout
ça quoi merci de nous faire nous faire
vivre ces émotions à à 100 % à 100 à
l'heure enfin c'est juste génial et et
vraiment impatiente de voir la France
sur tous les prochains événements parce
que je le dis je le répète je le répète
encore une fois mais toutes les autres
nations maintenant vont devoir faire
avec la France pour les premières places
avec l'équipe française avec les
joueuses de l'équipe de France féminine
tout à fait et aussi pour conclure tu as
donc tu as tu as remercié Yan gzoli le
sélectionneur tu as remercié Sylvia
alexevia la capitaine je voudrais aussi
remercier l'équipe de Chess.com qui a
accepté qu'on fasse ce stream c'était
enfin c stream d'ailleurs on a commenté
hier aussi c'était pas prévu à la base
et on leur a demandé non mais il y a
quand même l'équipe de France féminine à
suivre et donc on a pu mettre ça en
place de justesse et heureusement parce
que ça aura été quand même horrible de
devoir suivre ça sans pouvoir partager
cette belle équipe de France avec vous
ok juste j'en profite juste de secondes
on a aussi les médailles aux échiqué ah
très
bien alors Mitra Mitra 2e ok derrière la
joueuse Georgienne ça joue à pas
grand-chose malheureusement et bien sûr
Pauline Guichard Méda d'or au 4è et
[Musique]
chik bravo poo et et voilà donc on a
deux médailles auchiqu avec des
résultats des résultats vraiment
vraiment incroyables on peut féliciter
chacune des
joueuses mais oui toutes les joueuses
qui ont apporté Ben qui ont été je
indispensable oui mais chacune a su
répondre présente chaque joueuse était
là chaque joueuse dans les moments
difficiles était était là elles se sont
accroché on a pu voir démter qui qui n'a
rien lâché sur la partie d'aujourd'hui
mais absolument rien Sophie qui s'est
battu qui s'est battu sur sur l' de la
compétition elle apporté des points
importants et puis même aujourd'hui ça
aurait pu m mieux se passer ouais et
surtout faut pas oublier que Sophie et
Pauline reviennent du Grand Suisse donc
c'est des joueuses qui ont joué ben déjà
oui un tournoi cont des joueuses à 2004
2005 2003 elles ont eu quelques jours de
repos et elles ont repris l'avion pour
enchaîner avec championnat d'Europe donc
là on est sur sur des joueuses de très
haut vol merci yocha ben merci à toi ma
chère nana et puis sur ce merci à vous
en dernier dans le chat ou simple
spectateur simple spectatrice de nous
avoir suivi hier et surtout aujourd'hui
et à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
avec l'équipe de France ou ailleurs